Sorry, sorry for being late.
Oh, I was doing a practice with my VTuber rivals team.
I can't really say who's in it because it has been announced
yet.
It's like there was a lot of things going on.
Like people were getting rotated and stuff like today.
So like I'm like worried that like I was like, is this
finalized?
Well, we just had a scrim.
So so like we practiced we had well, we didn't have full
team scrim.
tank player wasn't couldn't make it um so i had to get a
ringer like well i had to get a pro player to ring for us
because i was just like i don't know anyone so so like
obviously it's not very much fair but like he was also like
coaching us at the same time so you know it was like
coaching plus uh also ring as a tank player so uh um guys
yeah we were casually just playing against like diamond GM
teams.
Uh, so, uh, so yeah, we were playing against diamond GM
teams, um, and I'm nervous.
I'm really nervous because like, I feel, I know it's for fun
and stuff like that, but you know, I, I, you know, I just
want us to win at least one game.
I just, that's really it.
I want us to win at least one game.
Everyone's working really hard.
leave at like 4 30 because obviously i have to do the stream
and so um so four people actually we we actually everyone
else stayed behind um the entire team stayed behind to get
additional coaching uh from our pro so like he's doing like
a vaude review for them and like giving them tips on how to
play and like what comps they should run and stuff like that
so you know you know he's he's helping out a lot and um and
i hope we get you know i hope we win a game that's all i
want that's all i want for us so sorry for being late anyway
small announcement small announcement so some of you guys
might have already seen this announcement because it was on
our official doki merch twitter yes the doki merch twitter
account is associated with you know doki buried it's
associated with me and um and uh they already announced it
already on the twitter account but we have let me pull it up
because this is technically a hashtag sponsor technically it
is hashtag sponsor but like it's just a very small portion
um but there is an msi aim lab challenge that is going out
right now and they are currently doing a giveaway for their
monitors so on this stream i will be doing a giveaway for
their monitors at around five um so like in 25 minutes um
it's 25 510 so in uh not 25 sorry 15 minutes in 15 minutes i
will be doing a giveaway for their monitors that the monitor
that i'm using right now the mag x50 monitor um it's really
good i'm actually i actually managed it when we're doing a
soundproofing thing um i managed to swap ask them to swap um
swap the uh yeah 15 minutes sorry you know i'm bad at math
so i managed to swap my really old monitor with the m
finally the msi mag x15 monitor so we're going to be doing a
giveaway slash raffle um ticket for this monitor but there
are requirements to it regarding aim labs so first off
please download aim labs right now it is free on steam so
let me i need to read my instructions to make sure that um
that i got everything so um it is free right now on steam
And there is a little challenge that you have to do.
I'll show you guys the challenge real quick.
But let me do the pin promo message.
Check out the MSI monitor.
And very good.
I love it.
I use it to get.
All right.
You know how good it is?
I got top 500 yesterday.
good it is.
All right, I'll show you guys I'll show you guys how fucking
good this is.
So as you guys know, I've been playing Rink for the last two
days, and in two days I got top 500.
With this monitor, by the way, here we go.
Let me pin this real quick.
I got the picture here.
Don't worry, I took the screenshot.
Of course I did.
this is the per i didn't expect it to happen but this is the
perfect time perfect way to chill so so i played gambit wow
look at that 4.5 hours played literally start playing like
two days ago the first time the first season um the new
season and then i played gambit and i have only lost two
games on gambit this is how sexy it looks like guys by the
way i'll show you how sexy this is um look how sexy this uh
this looks chat uh where is it there you go look how not the
last book though like um you know like the what the pros say
the pro players whenever they tweet this out like never kill
yourself like
yummy yummy so so it has 500 hertz for this monitor uh it's
sexy one of the keywords so so um so that is how good this
msi monitor is i literally by purchasing this monitor you
can get top five not me top 500 and then there's the little
asterisk not everyone could get top 500.
You just, this monitor doesn't actually guarantee you top
500.
So, yeah, results may vary, not guaranteed.
You had a little disclaimer on the bottom.
So, you know, it's been pretty good.
It's been pretty good.
Anyway, let me read it.
Let me make sure.
So, MSI, like I said, has graciously provided us one MSI Mac
x50 500 hertz monitor as a giveaway for one lucky dragoon
during the stream so dragoons please open your aim labs and
um click on this link i think this is the right one yes
click on this oh my gosh this link this is not a spam link
guys and it'll redirect you to the msi aim labs challenge
i'll do a demonstration of it and all you have to do is um
if your name gets chosen uh Give me a sec.
I'm getting my AIM last.
So if your name gets picked, you will have to send a
screenshot that you did the challenge and send a DM or reply
to, you know, Doki merch, the Twitter Doki merch account.
And just throw a screenshot that you did the challenge.
That's really it.
But you have to have AIM last...
You have to have a screenshot that you did the challenge.
The link doesn't work.
No, you need to have AIM Labs open to have it work.
That's the thing.
You gotta have AIM Labs open to have it work.
But if your name gets picked, you gotta make sure you do the
challenge and send a screenshot of it to the Dokey merch or
DM.
Don't worry, I'll send the Twitter link to the Dokey merch
account.
So for those who did get picked, it's just one lucky dragon.
But there are other prizes.
There are other prizes.
this is a campaign from the 17th of november to the 17th of
december and this is an msi ranking challenge so there's a
grand there's several prizes so grand prize gets also gets
another like if you get first place in the msi aimlapse
challenge you can get uh you can win a monitor basically
like the the ms meg vision x mpg monitor and the second
place and third place gets two monitor the attending prize
10 and until 10 lucky players can also get a hundred dollar
steam wallet so this is randomized so you don't get first
second third there is a chance by participating in this
challenge you will get a hundred dollar steam gift card um
and 10 winners will be randomly selected so the in lab
leaderboard closes on december 17th but if you want to get
if you want to um get a Right now!
Do the Aim Lab challenge right now!
And be here for the giveaway.
Is this locked to NA?
Mod, is this locked to...
That is one thing I actually don't know.
Mod, is this locked to NA?
Like, I actually...
I actually don't know.
This is not in my briefing.
That's...
Yeah, that's not...
That's not in my reading.
So sense.
Make sure you download AIM Labs.
Click on this link.
I'll send the link over to you guys now.
Have to have AIM Labs open for this.
And click this link.
And it will.
It should be able to take you to the challenge.
So I'll show you guys right now.
AIM Labs.
Whoa.
There you go.
I have.
This is like the one time I've ever used AIM Labs.
labs is for a sponsor so i clicked on the link this is me
clicking and then it took me here but if this is your first
time doing it you'll have to like confirm something um
you'll have to confirm something so so it took me here i
clicked on the link and it instantly took me here and this
is the challenge it's like a one minute challenge let's go
all right i did the challenge like to test it out so yeah i
do that and then whoa oh no i'm gonna fuck up my challenge
now i messed up already i was warmed up too from rivals and
then you guys must be like what the fuck is this it's
welcome to aim labs this is what everyone does before they
play video games but that's not me apparently not me though
but it does help a lot it actually i will say it does
improve your aim a lot too um i just it's for like like this
for the really serious gamers that actually want to climb um
this actually is really good warm-up and does improve your
aim i just i'm a very lazy individual but if you want to be
a better player um do aim labs because um because it it does
help you improve a lot yeah okay yeah i'm not this is a bad
number this is a bad one for me i'm messing up.
It sucks because I did warm up too.
I was playing Ravos for two hours.
I was in a, I had to play DPS.
By the way, I have to, I have to off-roll.
Um, not because like it's in the rules, but like, um,
because of the comps we're running, I have to off-roll on
71.
I was so close.
Yeah, I have no, I can't play Gambit Because like we're
running 2-2-2 and stuff So I have to play DPS So I got a
grand DPS So look at that So yeah, so You can send this
screenshot Okay, legal residence Yeah, okay, so these are
the places That can apply But so yeah, and you just take
this screenshot and then post it in the um i think it says
yeah it says task me tell blah blah blah what does it say
where's the msi challenge so this is the leaderboard so if
you get first second and third um you'll be able to like win
the bonus prizes as well so the neat thing is that you can
watch this guy to see how he did it like how did he so he
started jesus christ what the fuck so do the challenge right
now because I will be pulling the giveaway winners um I will
be pulling the should I do it no I won't do it in the stream
I will be pulling the giveaway winners in maybe in 10
minutes in 10 minutes so dude yeah he is a machine so you
can see how he does it Jesus Christ how long bro he wants
that PC so wait I want to do it again give me see if I can
break my record let me go see it right he did here bro he
like knows where to flick instantly too that's the crazy
part Oh, no, this is not a good record for me, either.
I already don't think we're going to hit anything.
Oh, no.
Alright.
We're fine.
Alright, there we go.
I gotta lock in.
I don't think I'm breaking any records, though.
I don't think I'm getting a high score.
I might be messing it up.
I just want to get 69.
that's all I want give me 69 come on I don't ask for much I
just want it to be nice is that too much to ask for oh my
god there were four people living here there wasn't four not
anymore there was four people living here
48 we're climbing i'll be like bam this is a home invasion
yeah i'm top 50 out of 3 300 and people i mean this is like
my first time doing it so i think i think that's pretty good
that's pretty good for my fourth time uh fourth time uh
they're still downloading no okay okay how about Oh, man, I
feel bad for those people who are still downloading, guys.
How about this?
All right, guys.
All right.
I'll be nice.
I'll be nice today.
I'll be really nice.
I will pull the raffle in an hour for those who are still
downloading.
So in an hour, I will pull for BSP.
I just see like some dragons are still downloading the game.
Okay, but Medi, how long have you been doing this for Medi?
How many tries to take you to be 17?
hmm I'm at 17 she can't keep up with jaguins because I know
some of you guys have been already for those who are already
following the dokey merch account I know you guys have
already have already been trying to do this challenge so in
an hour has been trying all day
fourth try and i've already broke top 50.
um but anyway for those who are still downloading i will
pull up i'll do the giveaway in an hour um and then i'll do
the i'll do the giveaway in an hour for everyone just so to
make it fair because i know some people are still
downloading it um and yeah i look forward to see who wins
who wins the special monitor but make sure to follow the
dokey merch account if you win don't worry there is if
nobody said if your name gets pulled and you don't we give
you a five minutes we will give you five minutes um to uh to
uh send in the screenshot so it's not like nobody said
anything so let me link i'll do the dokey merch link as well
dokey dokey merch twitter let's see all right here it is all
right here is whoops let me just get the actually i'll i'll
do a new pin tweet here is the dokey merch uh i'll do a new
pin tweet too um join join the uh i'm gonna say my word join
the msi challenge here okay oh wait i can't okay it's just
gonna be a join the challenge there you go there you go join
the challenge there you go it has the link here you go you
click on that and then uh oh wait that's not the link oops
give me a sec oh there you go it tells it gives you the
thread it gives you the thread look at the thread and then
it here it's here do we need a twitter for that yes you will
need a twitter because you will have to contact uh um you
have to contact the dokey merch uh uh twitter account or
reply to their tweet with the picture of the um of the
inline chat but only if you're chosen only if your raffle
gets chosen chat's moving too slow can you spam the link
more okay all right announcement done i gotta head over to
the cloud layout but i think that is every oh um oh sorry my
mom was like i'm gonna be way in half an hour so sorry the
mod that's running this was like i did not i thought you
were going to do this like right away but okay um i was
gonna go in 30 minutes so i guess i have to say it out now
yeah okay oops thank you to the mod that's handling the
dokey merch twitter account for staying overtime so to make
sure um he's like oh okay i Okay, I guess I'll stay another
hour.
Thank you to the Doki merch mod for staying an extra hour to
make sure we do the raffle.
So make sure to download AMAPs, do the challenge.
That's the only requirement to be eligible to enter the
giveaway.
But that's really it.
I played eight hours straight and formed the Guna Ramb, but
we can leave that part up.
Many thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
point it's just muscle memory at that point anyway all right
let's hop in the car sound guy are you here i accidentally
fuck up my sound balancing because i forgot to save um
battle also i need to delete all my tabs because uh
battlefields gonna take up a lot of so give me a sec let me
um
uh uh oh give me a sec real quick i gotta close everything
because I don't know if I can run battlefield like if I have
all these things open all right there you go let me boot up
battlefield also remember that guy that was like level 200
plus um apparently he revealed that he was actually revealed
in the comment section of that mod um that he was very drunk
when he played with us so oh my god boot up marvel rivals by
mistake a sec so so it was maybe a mistake to let him join
us because we were trying to win and he was apparently very
very drunk uh when he joined us like that was no mistake i
was not aware that he was not sober at all if i knew he
would not have been playing he would not have joined our
squad Hello Toss money into the S&P 500 Whoa Hey guys, are
you ready for a 12 hour stream today?
Nah, not really Not really Sorry Not really, sir, not really
Why are you not ready?
Don't you love playing Battlefield?
I thought you love Battlefield I don't know, man I don't
know about Battlefield You love Battlefield bro it's kind of
hard man this game it's okay we will adopt someone into our
squad by the way i found out remember that winnefield guy
that was level 200 plus that was oh yeah he was very drunk
when he was playing with us he and he still did destroy
destroyed he was apparently he commented in that vibe like
and was like sorry guys i was very very wasted like men have
two mood either completely locked in you know yeah yeah true
true true he was you he was so better than all of us like we
we're only half a man he was all the way i just want to say
thank you for thank you for organizing the cloud axel i know
that what the yeah you guys are really wanting to push for
this i'm so i'm so glad that you like decided to keep
playing with that you're like you're so okay you know he was
like in our discord messages he's like bro we gotta keep
playing man like we have to get one win I think I've only
chatted him that that he was like man we gotta do this again
and then they're like but he was like oh I'm embarrassed
though he can use can you and can you and Lteris say it on
stream because like I'm a little embarrassed because like I
am what the fuck now we just say to call you out Axel no
fuck we want to give him credit you know we were like no
come on Axel he should take credit for setting up such a
wonderful idea Everybody say thank you.
Yeah, thank you, Axel.
Thank you.
Bless.
I did not do shit.
What?
I literally just said, yeah, the time has been still.
I just said, yep, okay, sounds good to me.
I see you then.
Yeah, yeah.
And then we're like, really?
It sounds good.
You're so right, Axel.
It does sound good.
It...
God, he's fucking gaslighting, man.
No, we would never.
We would never.
Look, Axel, they're all saying like Aniki the goat.
Axel's the best.
Look at that.
to say thank you so much Axel thank you you are these people
all right you know what I'm gonna be like one of those
street performers I'm gonna put out a box and like if you
really want to thank me guys yeah if you really want to
thank Axel you can super chat on dokeybird's channel and
I'll don't worry I'll make sure that Axel gets the cut I
would make sure that I'll send Axel the money to later same
over here too yeah yeah same over in Altair's channel but
membership Yeah, yeah, membership only.
But here you can send the memberships out there and then the
super chats on my channel.
And then you can, I guess you can subscribe to Axel.
Nah, no way.
That's crazy, bro.
What the fuck?
This is, shit, they're, shit is like paying taxes.
They're the fucking government.
It's because the people, it's because of you people.
You people, who is, when you slide for that?
You people.
No, that's how the government speaks to us, hey?
all because of you people the government is able to run and
all that but also we're gonna fucking tax you extra that's
what that's what you guys are all doing whoa we're not
taking money from anyone we're not exactly yeah yeah oh
thank you oh thank you for the super chat gator thank you
thank you thank you thank you for the gift of membership
thank you well anna thank you to the super chat thank you
thank you thank you thank you man it really pays off to be
these people It really pays up These people Yeah, we're good
people Crazy Why would they give If we were bad people Why
would they give money to us?
I don't know Why do we give the money to the government You
know Same question I'd like to ask I don't want to pay taxes
Doesn't the government Like take care of the internet For
Australia Ooh I don't know about that bro Yeah No in
australia is like government owned that's why the internet
australia sucks yeah makes sense actually oh my god this
guy's level hundred seven but too bad i'm not in australia
no more i'm actually i'm actually mr japan now oh my god
japan ish yes sir yes sir i'm mr sushi now you know damn you
got the jp internet now no more i do i can download
battlefield in like 10 20 minutes you know oh my god you do
that sometimes you like unassault some big games just to see
the speed yeah yes sir just to flex on him you know just to
flex yeah it takes longer for the game to patch than the
actual game to download that's like no yeah no i guess that
it would take like an hour or some yeah all right i believe
in gaku nukem the level 107 oh someone get the a from gaku
gaku got oh gotkin sorry gaku and nukem guk nukem oh it
could be guk nukem what's it he's a war hero don't say that
word oh is it a bad word bad word oh i thought it was like
not spelled like that but just don't say it oh oh so so so
what is it no no no no no you should google you should
google it what g-u-k-e i don't even have a second Now I'm
gonna...
Now I'm gonna...
Now I'm gonna search it if I can spell it.
Now, now, now, now, now, now, now, now.
I thought it was an item from...
Hey, Mr. Clancy, this guy right here...
Wow!
Let's go!
Let's just jump!
Yes!
First... What if we win this first game, guys?
What if we...
We end stream?
If no matter what, if we win this first game, we end
stream...
What?
Okay, I'm down.
I'm down.
I thought it was either the Guma carrier couple, or I
thought it was the item from...
Stop saying that!
What?
Just call him Nukem!
No, it's Guma.
Yeah, it's Guma Caria.
And then Guma Caria is bakery.
You guys don't know?
It's just me?
Maybe I'm just too big of a league fan.
All right.
Guma Caria.
I go grab the gun.
Oh, that's my knife.
What is everyone so scared of now?
Because if you know the word, if you know the word you'd be
scared if you know the word you'd be scared if you know what
the word is you'd be very scared i'm not chronically online
like you guys it's not no no no no no it's not a chronically
online thing i will tell you that it's a thing i experienced
in my childhood yeah yeah i think i got it indeed my friend
indeed it's always yeah yeah it's you know it's yeah there's
only one thing that you guys would be scared of it's racism
okay it's a word that every game will censor it's like you
can't type it in game chat why the hell is it his in his
name no because it's not spelled like that it's not spelled
like that but you are surprisingly pronouncing it very very
close to it i just thought it was good for the coke thingy
from schedule one that they have Oh, what?
Yes, Q.
Oh, they Q.
Yeah.
Oh, you haven't played one of the best games in the world.
What is the best game in the world?
Schedule 1.
Oh, so you, no, I have, but I got scared of playing it on
stream.
Why?
Oh, I can see it.
Yeah, I can see it.
Yeah, yeah, you can see it?
I still have my like, why?
I can't play it.
Yeah, because I still have.
Why?
Well, you guys can't play it, right?
Oh, people are right.
Okay, okay.
I'm turning over, because like, you know, I'm like...
still have like the fear the corp of fear coming oh there he
is nukem look at nukem bro nukem's fucking oh what what bro
he killed everyone yeah bro nukem's doing it bro i think
we're gonna win let's go no i'm gonna jinx us yo i'm so down
for that what's going on here whatever okay if we don't want
we have to invite him i'll be like okay i'm gonna glaze him
bro you're so good Good.
Just risen up a little bit.
Hey, I'm a VTuber.
Oh, you're afraid of me?
Oh, never mind.
Also, to my sound gap, is everyone okay?
I don't know if my sound team is alive.
Bro, where do we go?
I'm just following Axel, but I don't think Axel know what
he's doing.
We could do a mission.
Yeah, let's just do it.
I don't know how to do the missions.
Yeah, how do we do the missions out there?
um i think they appear press m and if we finish the missions
around the map we get experience and some really good loot
where's the missions oh three missions nearby evasion the
script aligned oh that's sure signal hack i don't know how
to do this but let's do it it looks cool all right look at
this guys we're top 24 teams Let's go!
I'm going to the Alina Latina shit.
If I get shot, I get shot.
Someone will die.
I will be the war hero.
I'm getting shot.
Okay, wait.
No!
He's down!
Where?
Oh, wait!
That's our carry!
Wait, where did he die?
Wait, he's all the way back there?
It's okay.
He gets back in.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're still doing this.
All right, align the Atena.
Go to the other Atena so we can line together.
All right, it's over there.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I'm aligning this signal string.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep,
beep, beep, beep, beep.
Oh.
It's over here.
Where is this?
I think I have a heat.
I have a heat.
Oh, there you go.
I got it.
I like this.
No hoser watching.
Can't hide protect us from it.
I'm hacking.
Hacking.
He's back.
I'm hacking.
I'm covering.
I hear shots from the north.
I hear so many shots.
Did we do the mission?
Right over here.
On ping, on ping, on ping.
Okay, okay.
I'm looking.
Okay.
Oh, hey, let's go.
Some gift subs.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
One down, one down.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright, good luck, guys.
Keep shooting.
I'm gonna keep walking those gifts, so you guys keep killing
them for me.
I leave it to you.
Mission complete.
Let's go!
One more, one, Come on.
Behind this truck.
Let's rally on that RB point.
Oh yeah, no, he's dead.
There's one more guy up here on this house.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm on the Russian house.
Wait, you're dead.
Whoa!
On ping, on ping, on ping.
Okay, no!
I know you're dying!
He's on the hill on ping.
Whoa!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Careful, careful, careful.
Eetha, that guy's sniper.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know if I can do anything about that.
That shit's scary.
You could cry.
You could, you could.
You're a little pathetic and you get some...
Whoa!
Okay, I'm just gonna chill.
It's okay.
You can res yourself.
Wait, are you okay over there?
Did we loot that thing back there?
Did we loot that?
I don't know.
No, I'm being a little loot goblin.
Nukem, nukem, come over here!
Wait, where is he?
Kachatah!
Don't worry, nukem.
I'm here for you.
I'm following nukem.
because I'm pretty sure there's like a read up their
teammates res or some mr.
Nukem was your what are your orders sir wait oh what are you
fine yep just sniper shooting at me here thank you take what
you need is he still sniping oh I see him yeah he's still
sniping I hit 42 I got like 42 on him He's such a little
bitch What are you?
Okay, you know what?
Fuck you.
It's just one guy.
Are we getting one guy?
You're getting one guy.
I'm getting hurt.
We're getting one guy.
Ouch Thank you.
We're out body block.
I have no armor I didn't drop some Somewhere I body block
you.
I appreciate that.
I think we should leave this area.
I don't want to be here anymore unless we unless we like run
it up to him all right you how confident are we to run up to
this guy i'm confident not that confident i'm not gonna go
to mr new i'm going to mr newcomb yeah he's our leader he's
he left us already oh my god oh this guy sniping yeah yeah
no oh wait no Oh Punch
Oh nice Oh Oh I nuke them Okay nice You Nuke No more One
more One more I got him I got my gun Boy I got shot I'm back
Back behind Behind behind behind Behind behind behind
Behind작 Island Don't worry I still have a rest Oh Oh Oh Oh
It's okay We just gotta We just gotta Yeah me and Axel We
can we can clutch this We got clutches so Newcombe can stay
with us.
Thank you.
I'm not joking.
Here we go.
Where's mine, man?
Where's mine?
Thank you for the super chats.
Oh my God.
Let's go.
Let's bump Axel to the next tax bracket.
I know.
Thank you for it.
By super chatting me, I will help Axel out.
What's with all the greed here?
Where's my super chat, guys?
Don't worry.
We're redistributing wealth.
Oh, I don't know about that, dude.
tribute that's what it means actually i swear to god if i
die oh one of us oh you got one and i got one yeah we each i
think this one's gonna go are you gonna get the team leader
or you're yet oh thank you if you die now i can get you okay
i got the squad leader what is this merch that's just
dropped axel did we drop merch did i drop merch when did we
drop merch when When did that happen?
When did we draw merch?
Did we draw merch?
Oh, I'm gonna slay time!
Oh, that's not good.
Guys, we won't be safe here, so we gotta leave.
A lot of downfall.
I got shot from somewhere north.
Looks like- Okay, this way.
Alright, I go.
I'll go west.
Oh my god, Nukem, you- Wow!
It's on me!
It's actually on me!
Oh my god, guys.
You guys have to rest me now.
you're gonna have to res me after oh i see whoa i'm getting
airstruck okay al tander is people behind me so good luck
good luck everyone okay i'll watch behind i'll watch behind
good luck everyone i'm covering you i'm covering you this
time for real oh oh my god that's you
there's more mascot plushies of us hey yo check out joki
merch dot com for more merch as well oh if you do you know i
have a custom controller as well you're the boy gaming doc
jp
oh i need armor okay it's fine how do i get up you guys guys
i i don't know who he's shooting at but i don't know how you
got down the hill guy down the hill okay ping did you ping
yep i pinged okay that over here i don't see it's another
guy on the hill he's hit 56 i see him oh this is a really
bad guy so hard to use this gun is this guy in the bad bad
wait i'm getting whoa i don't know where i'm getting shot
from it's a shipping container right there okay i'm gonna
back up a little bit yeah mr nuke is like in narania bro mr
nukem ditched us shall we do wait this is this is defying
the laws of gravity Oh my god.
What?
Yay.
Wait, custom weapon drop.
Custom weapon drop.
Let's go to that.
Oh, that's what he was going to.
Guys, we can't let Nukem die.
We let him die.
Wait, there's someone dropping.
Someone dropping.
Oh, right in front of us.
Right on the...
I got shotgun.
Kill the hole.
Oh, wait.
He's gonna get really, really good guns.
We gotta be careful.
He's dead.
Oh, nice.
Someone else found him.
Yeah, now I'll get through.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm a dead.
Oh, wait.
Behind?
What?
I can't do that.
That's crazy.
They're just scratching you.
No, we're just scratching you, man.
No, come.
That was a beat.
No!
We got nuked.
The nuke of got nuked.
I see the strap we're trying to go with.
Every time we lose, we get a sub.
That's how it is, mate.
We'll be millionaires.
Until we get shrouded.
Shit, we have millionaires.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, but nuke of was pretty dumb.
He said, okay, but he did ditch us a lot.
So I don't know.
I don't know.
That is true.
It's like a lion.
I don't like his name.
Which part?
It's hard to say.
I don't want to say the wrong word.
Which part?
Which part of the name that you're not like?
Can you say it out loud for us so I know what to do?
I'm a peacemaker.
I don't like...
You guys are too paranoid.
You know, you guys are too...
This is why being blind to a lot of things in life is just
better, you know?
You know what I'm saying?
Sometimes you might get in trouble.
So there's a Korean proverb called, Don't put your head
under the pear tree.
You know, don't put yourself in that position, right?
Yeah.
You put your head in what?
Why do ostriches do it?
It's like, so don't stick dick in crazy type thing.
Ostriches aren't humans.
Yeah, why do ostriches do it?
If you want to be an ostrich, do you want to...
Yeah.
Aren't you a bird?
Ostriches can't fly!
So, they can run...
Oh, those fuckers.
What's an ostrich again?
Those guys are big eggs.
The big egg guys.
a big emu ox axel a big but they run so fast though they're
very fast runners yeah they're like emus they're like emus
we have emus they're like they're like emus but like i don't
know which ones i think i think ostriches are faster than
emus i'm pretty sure they're like emus without horns they
both taste like they both taste like have you have you ate
an emu ostriches have the the top part isn't don't emus have
the little top horn thingies they have horns i don't
remember what emus look like what does an emu look like is
that is that why they lost the emu war the horns i don't
remember i don't remember what they looked like they have
the little thing on top right the little oh my god it does
have a horn yeah right i was like don't they have that yeah
i don't know i think they lost every war man what war did
the australians win how Wait, but like, how would you lose
the war?
They literally threw criminals on the island.
Not the Emi one.
Like, don't you guys go hard?
Like, why else did they banish you from the United Kingdom?
Banish who?
That's how Australians were born.
They took all the criminals from the United Kingdom and then
shipped them to Australia.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That's what I'm saying.
So, like...
Yeah, so how did you guys lose the war?
What do you mean?
How did you lose the war?
The wards against animals.
It's all against animals.
I don't know.
I thought you guys were talking about the people losing to
the British people.
No, I'm talking about the evil war.
Yeah, who cares?
Yeah, I'm talking about the evil war.
I don't know.
Fuck, maybe they thought that out.
All those fuckers don't taste good.
We don't want to eat them.
Yeah, just shoot it.
Maybe just do it.
There is a lot of people.
Heading to this mansion, by the way.
I don't think this is a great idea.
It's alright.
No discrepancies.
I believe in him.
I don't have a...
I'm dead.
I think he's dead, guys.
Okay, cool.
Alright.
Okay, I got some guns.
Alright, well, see you later, guys.
whoa is that a lambo that is a someone sent a nuclear strike
down to on us and i hope i live sounds balanced don't worry
this house is a mansion i'm okay wait where where are wait
where are the other you guys oh i'm running you ran because
only a squad of three were sent to shoot them over to time
they learned to send out scouts to warn the flight to run
that's insane bro i got two and you ran good job good job
bro okay all right we we both died i guess i'm so sad it was
such a good gun i didn't know what gun guys what gun was it
it was so good someone's like oh they dropped at the golf
course that place sucks oh thanks guys oh i'm watching out
here sniping no pressure good job i'm watching you i'm gonna
touch you and kill you nice yeah good touch i'm watching you
still out there no pressure okay okay i'm going i'm
upgrading my sniper yeah yeah yeah oh oh i'm no longer
watching you can start shooting again oh wait watch me again
so what does a dude gotta Do you go on the front page of
Twitch again, yo?
What do I gotta do?
How the hell did I get on the front page yesterday?
That's right.
Oh, you were on the front page?
Hot tub.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Do a hot tub.
Everyone loves the hot tub stream.
The Twitch method.
It is currently hollow day.
So if you guys want to go check out hollow live production
talents on twitch.tv.
Or you can check out my channel on YouTube.
It's dokey day, too.
Oh, dookie day.
Every day is dookie day.
Is that why I got on the front chain?
That's crazy.
Yeah, yeah.
When you're playing league, you need every help you can get.
Whoa, I got a rat on my ass.
Shit, I got a swan down there.
Wait, where are you?
Someone down there.
You coming over?
I don't know.
I'm running over.
Hi.
Did you guys kill the rat?
I think so.
Oh, hey, nice.
Someone on me, I'm here!
Okay, I'm here.
I'm actually not here, I lied.
But like, I wanted to make sure you're feeling comfortable.
Talk about it's on the ass, bro.
Yeah?
So... On the roof, on the roof, on the roof.
It's on the roof?
Oh shit, he's right here.
Another on the roof, careful.
Wait, what the- I was like, who's that?
Who's that as running?
Wait, I'm getting shot at by something.
Roof, Roof, Roof, Roof.
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
Oh, my God.
He's 100, 100, 100, 100, 100, 100, 100, 100.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, I'm still dead.
Okay, never mind.
Great weapon just really said, hey, I'm gonna.
Axel, run.
Axel, run, run, run, run, run.
Where's the red thing right?
I don't know.
Press M.
Hey, you think I have the...
Let's go straight forward.
Straight forward.
Wait, our fourth left.
Wait, he left us.
But we were being...
Okay, you're right.
We don't need him.
He doesn't appreciate real talent.
yeah now we gotta we gotta look for like at one you know we
gotta appreciate flightless birds oh oh oh oh oh i don't
know i don't know you can get that readable now i believe oh
whoa whoa that is more than one person shooting by the way
whoa you got killed by jenna the giant yeah they beat those
kills bro they've been playing for for like ever since since
this demo came out and he still haven't won yet but not like
us though we're gonna get it today guys fucking Jenna of
course it's a you have a redeploy yeah this guy's this guy's
oh this this is rat she called him them a rat this is rat
hey chill out okay guess guess guess why you're able to come
back to me you're gonna get shot at I was a good man how
this gladiator has a coliseum yet he's still so good at
running away from fights I know right right that's how
that's how he's never died in the coliseum fight he just
runs away until the guy just watch the people he runs he
loops him around he runs around the coliseum until the guy
gets tired and then he shoots them humans are endurance
hunters i just watch the people fight instead of me fighting
what about the lion how do you live through the lion
obviously do lions taste good i wonder i don't think they
taste good you know i think that's illegal
That's why humans don't taste good too apparently Because
it's dark meat Dark meat Dark meat doesn't apparently
Because it's too firm Because the muscle Our muscles are too
firm Oh but you know what firm meat goes good with Oh that's
true I wonder what it tastes like The red meat is really
nice I agree I agree Sir Alright I got Watch our roof.
I have a sniper.
When are we going to have a pizza party, by the way?
Oh, yeah.
Pizza party.
Pizza.
Who is this at pizza party?
Pizza time.
Pizza is caught up.
Yeah, Axel, when are we going to have the pizza party?
Yeah, we should have a 3D pizza party.
Oh, fuck.
All of us in our motion capture.
Can we have something else?
Like, can we have tacos or something?
Taco Tuesday.
Yeah, taco Tuesday.
Yeah.
Like, tacos are better, man.
But yeah, pizza and tacos.
And then we have to be next to a bathroom just in case.
I don't know.
The pizza in Japan is so disappointing when I heard pizza.
Oh, man.
That's not fair.
Axel, come and enjoy the pool.
It's like...
Fuck that.
It's because, like, cheeses.
I mean...
Fuck the pool, man.
I don't even go to the beach, bro.
Don't worry, Altair.
I'll be in the pool.
Oh, girl!
That's right.
I infected the pool with my cooties.
That's...
Oh, shit!
I'm getting shot at!
They're shooting at the pool!
The pool's close.
pool close i'm still getting shot at she was pissing in the
pool bro she just goes in sneaks in and chucks a little bit
up wait airstrike i'll be okay in this house right let's
move over houses no i should be okay they won't know hey
guys so i thought what i thought it'd be like the tiny
airstrikes you know where tiny ones little do i know it was
not tiny i don't even know what the hell they are i don't
know either but they sent out this goddamn airstrike that's
messed up so hard it's over here do you guys see them yeah
but it's so hard for what i what time should be highlighted
in my
I'm looking.
Hit one for 38.
They're going over this way.
Yeah, they redeploy.
Outside the map, though.
I'm trying to say I'm trying to find a better gun.
Oh, no.
There's no more better guns.
That's the best we can get.
Oh, I knocked one.
Wait, he did?
Nice.
He said I hit.
We're going over right side, right side, right side.
Right side?
You ping?
Oh, I see.
I see him.
This gun is...
really bad to shoot though so i don't know how much i can
help
i don't see it what the is shooting people under the
redeploy 17 33.
125 on the ball i hit 33 on flesh i feel like this is gonna
be bad if we 63.
oh they're going right side right side right side yeah yeah
they're like here oh they're shooting back how dare they
keep the high ground on them keep the high ground i don't
really think we have high ground here yeah we just gotta
move in this yeah we should move in i'm gonna move in whoa
i'm moving in this zone i'm getting my knife out okay oh
look there's a chest here like open this chest in the open i
don't want to be out in this golf course for long weak
coward you're a coward like sometimes life don't give you
cover you gotta take it Sometimes you gotta get a bird
instead of a car.
Sometimes maybe good, sometimes maybe shit.
Always 50-50, what do you mean?
Yes, sir.
Yeah, oh, oh, in front of us, in front of us, in front of
us!
I'm shooting.
Up the hill.
Ah!
Oh, no, I'm dead, I think.
Nice.
I'm getting shot behind us, the people we were shooting at.
No way.
Guys, we might get flanked by people.
goodness i whipped out my i got a dead one okay on my way on
my way there's one to you there's one to you grabbing this
you're like my now my now i have dfib i've dfib oh wait it's
so quick dfib what the hi okay wait i think that's a sniper
here i dropped a sniper car car car car tank tank hide wow
if you get close enough you can attach a thermite to it I'm
not one of those people that's good.
I'm not going to die a hero.
I'm dying a...
I'm not dying here because I'm live.
Because I will live.
You are live.
I'm running, by the way, guys.
I'm very far.
You're like 10 feet away from me.
I'm so far from you guys.
You're so far.
Sayonara.
Bro, he's one.
recoil.
I hit 140.
This recoil fucking sucks.
I might die.
Is he inside?
Yeah, he's sniping.
Oh, there's a tank!
That tank is sniping!
Oh, shit.
I need armor.
I have armor.
I'll drop your armor.
Okay, so I got fucking tanked by 20 miles away.
I don't go worse.
I don't understand.
Yeah, go Reds.
I'm gonna try to hit the fence.
When we get a tank, we get instantly destroyed.
When they have a tank, they live.
That's not fair.
Eco rights.
It's because I'm a woman.
How do you attach a thermite?
Do you need to be holding a thermite?
Oh, there's someone there.
There's someone there.
There's someone at the redeploy.
No, they're at the redeploy.
They're like camping it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's hurting.
Yeah, let's go to the zone.
Let's go to the zone.
Yeah, yeah, it's not.
There's another redeploy right here.
Okay.
Like to your right.
Just don't get near the tank.
Oh.
What the fuck?
What?
I got...
He's like walling or some shit?
Wait, he was just ratting there.
Oh, no!
It's out there.
Our life is in your hands.
Clutch your kick Wow, there's people up there.
Oh, no.
Don't worry, this wall will protect you.
This is my wall.
It was made for me.
Guys, don't worry.
Oh, it was not made for you.
It was not made for you.
This wall deported you.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
It's gonna be the third game.
Don't worry, I believe it.
We're getting close here.
We're from 16th place.
the 13th place guys we're getting there we need a squad
member who who can be loyal and not leave yeah that's right
you know what because that guy that guy fucking left us yeah
I'm gonna block him I'm gonna block him because that guy met
what was your name no discrepancy wait i'm gonna oh we got
it i was gonna send him a message and be like not ggs wasn't
no discrepancy the guy before this no no that's the guy that
left us i ripped don't worry i'm petty i remember names all
right no i remember there is you notice oh he's so lucky we
got oh wait here he is f1 okay yo i got 100 gifts from
twitch what holy thank you twitch dang hey youtube where you
guys at hi youtube wait damn just dunking on him like that
so i sent the guy assault emoji fuck you wait i got an
assault emoji yeah i gotta send i sent him yeah yeah you can
do equipment none of them have ever replied back to me other
people have sent messages to if only they knew what they're
missing out on wait we got level one guy guys i think we
should leave i think oh he's a controller and his name is
soft actuary bro it's like his birthday it's his is this
10th birthday 10 year old birthday finally he finally got
playstation 5 and he Does his mom gift him him a Battlefield
6, too?
And now he's here with us.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, we appreciate it, Mr. Twitch.
Big love.
Yeah, I had a question.
If Mr. Twitch, if you still hear, how the hell did he get on
the front page again?
Are you not on the front page?
I don't think so.
What do I got to do?
Wait, but how did he get...
Wait, you must be on the front page because they gifted you
a hundred subs.
Is that how it works?
I don't know.
Yeah, because why would they be on your stream?
right now I don't know maybe they're like maybe there's like
an insider in twitch who's like where are you multi
streaming or exclusively on twitch exclusively on twitch
whoa an exclusive twitch stream yes sir Wow that's crazy
because we love vtubers exclusively okay so watch watch your
watch a language I'm not that shit you know it's fine It's
okay.
He's on Twitch.
They love me for who I am.
Remember, Altair.
On Twitch, you can say all that stuff.
On YouTube.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
On Twitch, you can say everything, anything you want.
They love me for who I am.
I'm an honest man, you know?
Yeah, exactly.
I keep it 100% real, you know?
I don't want to do that like, oh my God, I'm such a nice
person.
You want to be like, what's his name?
Nice to meet you.
The guy that's...
I want to do that.
Team right there.
Watch out.
Who is that guy's name that does the whole...
The Fortnite guy?
I don't play Fortnite.
No, no, the guy that's like...
No!
Oh, I got killed by Kanoli.
I don't know anybody who goes like...
Oh, look at my dog tag!
No, the guy...
No, I'm not talking about Ninja.
Is it...
Is it Nick?
Yeah, Nick.
The guy that's like...
God, what was this Fortnite scene?
Nick Fuentes?
Nick Fu...
What was this famous thing that he says to this child?
I don't remember.
His child, he's got a child.
Never back down, never what?
Yeah, never back down, never what?
How did that guy just...
Oh, one more, one more going your way.
I'm coming back.
On me, on me, on me.
Yeah, but that guy never swears at all because his entire
channel is dead for the children.
I'm going to try to find one singular gun.
How did I broke my ankle again?
Oh, there's people on me.
There's people on me.
Axel, can you raise me?
Oh, shit.
There was a person.
I know in the heat of combat, you tend to forget about me,
but it hurts sometimes.
No, I just don't.
That's deep in my...
I'm camping.
Bro, my aim is all over the place.
God damn it.
It's like me on a drunk night trying to take a piss, man.
Fuck.
Like, whoa.
There is a team here.
So I'm...
I'm a little...
Oh, shit!
Is him again?
I thought you guys killed him!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, dog tag for you!
No, don't use that again!
I'm not giving him my dog tag.
Bro, fuck the canoli guy.
That guy is crazy.
Nice colossal.
Yes, sir.
Yeah, there's him.
Okay, our child is dead.
I have 11 bullets.
I don't know what I can do with 11 bullets.
Just hit it all.
You don't have, you have 180.
What do you mean?
100.
You must be blind, lady.
Shit.
Bro, you have 11 in a mag.
What do you mean?
Is that the gun that I'm trying to use though?
Hell no!
What the fuck is 11 out of 180?
Oh, wait, I...
Okay.
Whoa!
Bro, I was putting armor on, man.
This guy's a fucking rat.
He's a...
This guy's a rat!
So how do you check the Twitch front page?
I need to get like more familiar with Twitch, you know?
Go to twitch.tv.
okay twitch twitch dot TV when I type that cage will just
pops up and I think is I watch him too much I was cage all a
bit too much oh so that's how it works in holiday okay I'm
gonna mess up a little update with the with the microphone
okay here is a monitor thing the monitor is in a lot but if
you do win the monitor and you're outside of na msi will
work with you to get in-country equivalent or a steam wallet
code of equivalent value so just let you guys know for the
monitor hopefully they let me loot yeah wait where are you
guys counter mission we can do this bus all right here we go
i got fine i swear to god if i see canoli again i swear to
the fucking guy if i die to that same
That was an airstrike.
Axel, let's go and learn some of Tennis.
Come over here.
Where's the child?
Oh, yeah.
The mission.
Oh, there's a child.
Okay, I'm just saying.
Oh, there's people ahead of people ahead.
Okay, I only have one gun.
North.
Oh, let's just kill him, man.
We already died so many times.
If we kill them, we can get their guns.
Think about it.
How bad can it get?
Yeah.
Wait, where are they?
You lied.
I...
You may feed it one shot one shot one shot on the hole in
front of me.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay.
No, I got this fucking.
Oh my god.
He's down.
I'm here.
This guy.
Darkness.
Oh, yeah, I'm here, me, me, I'm gonna like, I'm gonna slice
it.
I don't know what I mean.
I got him.
Nice.
Okay, he didn't want me to grab his dog tags.
I mean, good for him.
Me too.
Can I get rid of that?
No.
Oh, Axel's down.
Wait, what?
What?
I forgot to pick up Axel.
You did pick him up?
That guy is not a chopper.
Look at him.
He's not a fucking chopper.
Bro, what is he doing?
He's flying.
Wait, there's someone in the air.
That's... Oh, wait, there is.
Wait, I'm not even gonna bother.
I know it's not gonna work.
I know I'm not gonna...
I can do anything about that.
You just gotta believe, Doki.
I don't believe.
I don't.
I know my limitations.
I'm a oh wait our guy died let me res him
the hose right watch yeah guys we gotta res our boy he died
in the chopper
yeah I noticed that he was dead guys he died in the chopper
but um hey we all sat on this it'll be a little faster
Sorry, I'm doing some, I'm doing some signal stuff.
If we all stand on this, it would be a little faster, guys.
I'm hocking.
I hopped!
Yay!
Is there another signal thing?
Nah.
Where do we go?
Do we just, we should go, no, we are in zone.
Can we go closer to zone or nah?
Let's try to, let's try to do some apex strats and just find
a spot inside.
rat oh there he is wait which way is inside okay we should
oh shit we got lit yeah where's our loot where is it it's
coming down it's this one don't get crushed oh wait that
happens whoa money money money all right let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go we gotta go to zone fruit salad
yummy yummy yummy yummy what's that's mama me no fruit salad
fruit salad the fucking wiggles wasn't it the expendable the
what the big oh yeah wiggles are australian i forgot about
that yeah the australian we got this thing called our
wiggles yeah you guys invented He got the bloody wiggles,
eh?
Yeah, the bloody wiggles.
Is someone on my ass?
Where are you?
Where's your ass?
Oh there.
He doesn't have one.
That's true.
That's why I'm like, where is it?
That's why we're trying to find it.
We're all trying to find his ass.
Axel, where is it?
Where's his ass?
You lied.
Dude, Axel.
It's like a piece of paper floating in the wind.
I literally just saw some dude looking like Jesus falling
from the sky.
It'll be a cardboard forever.
It's so sad.
Guys, we gotta go.
Let's go deeper in the zone.
Wait.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up,
up, up, up, up, up, up, up, I do have an airstrike.
Granade.
Airstrike.
Okay, I'm leaving then, I guess.
I'm gonna fucking cut this tarp.
Ha!
Oh, my God.
cut this guy off get an idea oh i see him he's up he's up
okay okay okay i see my sim over here i'm ping i broke his
armor i broke his army he's dead he's dead room room whoa
car on my ass okay okay okay oh what i literally just died
that easily i need up i need up i need up i'm dead i'm away
oh no are you kidding me Oh no, oh no, oh no, it's over.
I had such good loot too!
Bro, how the hell does a car just get destroyed that easily?
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Oh no.
Live!
Where's the child?
Oh.
Axel, watch the child.
Watch the child, Axel.
Watch him.
How do I watch him?
You press E.
Oh.
Oh no.
Oh dear, he's fighting for his life.
He's trying.
Oh no, bro.
He's taking cover.
Oh, he got the mate.
Oh, he's burning.
He's burning.
How do you miss every shot?
shot you're on a shotgun no what are you doing is that's the
zone let's get out of there oh oh there's a guy camping on
next to him nearly had him you nearly had him oh my god
tears literally fighting for his life oh my god i was so
focused then yeah you were so who is a good battlefield
player who is a good battlefield player that we can just be
like we need a fourth off on him john grab i just at twitter
who is good at battlefield come join now once in a lifetime
opportunity we are one hour in we've already given up it's
oh guys it's only been one hour guys we can do it i've it's
the other hour.
It's the other hour that will make it.
It's not about the first hour.
It's always about the second hour.
And the third.
I believe.
And the third hour.
Guys, we have literally 12 hours.
Like, we can do it.
Wait, what?
Yeah, we only have 12 hours left.
We have 12 hours.
Oh, wait.
But Axos exclusively on Twitch so we can go longer if you
think about it endurance thon yeah because on twitch you can
stream longer than 12.
hell no hell no we could do like a subathon impromptu
subathon one week one week is there a butsu if you don't win
within 12 hours idea guys that's why he's that's why he
streamed it on twitch because he knew he was like oh i can
stream longer than 12 hours if we all if i do it on twitch
so it was his idea sliding what is this idea thanks axel
thank you why am i getting gaslit bro jesus by who so thank
you for the super chat too and the membership wow wow so
generous and kind so generous that's crazy man what will we
do about generous generous axel crazy all right we got
section 10 20.
I want to hop into section 1019.
We killed him because he didn't do good enough.
Yeah, he's been playing.
Every time he dies, he deletes his account and makes a new
one.
He deletes his Steam account and he makes section 1019,
section 1021.
Someone's like, did they win the game?
I don't know, Mr. Little Big Planet Shin.
Are we still playing the game?
No, we already won.
What do you mean?
We won the first one.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I leave the moment we win that game.
I would literally, when I see the win screen, I will end
stream right there.
But don't worry.
No outro.
Even if we don't win.
I'll leave even if we don't win, yo.
No, no outro.
I leave call end stream.
My contract says I can leave even if we don't win.
No, no, no.
This is, it's in our title.
It's in our title.
title says our title says also where the fuck is this guy
landing us my agent said no my my talent is not is not
continuing i'm your agent no i hate to break into you i'm
actually your agent it was me all alone it was me all alone
i know i'm your agent the deadline the trade deadline has
passed already it's me you're too late no it's me do you not
remember We had our meeting earlier today.
No, I don't remember.
Shit.
I didn't tune in.
I was there at the meeting.
Well, too bad.
I don't remember.
I have a meeting where we all get $1,000.
I remember.
Oh, you weren't there.
That's unfortunate.
Oh, yeah, you weren't there.
That sucks, bro.
Yeah, no, he's dead.
He was not being helpful.
well i'm looting alone so what the hell why is this mag gold
i am so scared i only have a pistol why is this magazine
gold yellow it's like peace color what the is that our homie
died oh my god what's new what's new okay i don't have much
ammo left god maybe we should be nice to our teammates maybe
that's maybe that's what's stopping us from winning now oh
you guys are fine now all right if you win with us i'll buy
you dinner whoever you are okay sure not not you no no no oh
well you gotta buy me dinner so i can be nice why does that
have anything to do with you being nice where is that gun i
literally dropped oh my god oh oh my god that's what the
what the people are just dropping in me well that's a unique
problem more more more more what's going on i'm on my way
die die die someone west i think there was one more person i
think guys i i don't know what's going on i've just been in
this area all right i'm fine now who is this dead okay this
is this is a semi sniper you want this is mine it's mine
i'll give the seal tear um yeah oh you want a shotgun no but
Fucking what else can I do?
Let's say I can find another gun later What is this battle
pickup?
Whoa, oh cool from one shotgun to a shitty shotgun.
Let's go What the heck am I using oh by the way, I dropped a
shotgun that was actually a shotgun.
I lied Yeah, I kind of noticed it was a shotgun It looked
like a sniper.
I was like whoa It's so long like a sniper rifle why thank
you i killed like five people here axel i have a weapon for
you i have a weapon come here oh what's this check it out
man what the is this oh it's a rail gun yeah i wanted i
found your rail gun yeah give it a try oh artillery strike i
want that someone's over here over here over here oh my god
i just saw him he literally landed right next to us you're
landing in front yeah yeah yeah yeah okay i got two nice we
got all of them what the why are they why are they all
landing on us like what guys i think we lost i'm pretty sure
we lost too many games that the sbmm is like on our side
there oh yeah no sb oh oh there's the lady no
am so sad i wait is that another guy on us yep there is no
way section you cannot oh my god wait he's doing movement oh
bro okay this is that everybody no there's a guy in front of
section young yeah he there was a guy all that nice thank
you for loot people appreciate it nice oh it's the same guy
i killed before they came back just for revenge all right
you're good to go They thought they could take us down.
I swear to God, I think...
Bro, this is not natural.
I got, like, so many people running at me.
I'm coming in.
Where's my body?
Dude, this gun is OP, the one you gave me.
But it takes so long to...
People, people, oh, oh, oh.
That's me.
People, people.
You scared me.
Where are the other guns?
Oh, there we go.
Oh, are we really gonna do the...
Okay, no, I don't want that.
I don't want the response.
No No, someone else take the rip the gun hacksaw.
What is that guy someone else take this is the rail gun
Should you try shooting this try shooting this shooting
what?
Huh vehicle vehicle no don't shoot the vehicle.
We'll need to shoot it No, no, no, should have blown up and
kill us off.
Yeah, it's okay No, no, no, no, do not kill us.
Do not kill us.
I worked too hard to be to be killed right now ah oh wait
p20 oh i like oh i like p20 i'll take an ammo drop i have
the p20 and then i'll grab the car bad okay we're really far
from the zone so let's let's start moving yeah yeah yeah
i'll agree and we have a car we can move in with the car
guys we could also blow it up that'd be pretty cool we can
okay how about this we drive a car into someone and blow it
up yeah oh i like it yeah yeah you like yeah i'm cooking
right now guys i don't like being the driving well you don't
want me to let's go to defense nexus and just sit in the
house and wait this is our best bet also there's people
fighting defenses nexus right now so i don't know now but we
got a car but the thing is is that if this car blows up
we're all just dead you know yeah but then it requires don't
blow up our car okay just don't
I think it's safe right now.
Kind of sucks after constantly carry this when I'm like.
LNG kit.
We just stay here and wait.
Let's find a good defensible position.
Wait, there is another shotgun.
Hey, guys.
There's a blue shotgun over there.
Where do we wait?
I'm away here.
Actually, no.
We should wait in a room where there's no...
entrances and exits.
Or, I mean, there's one exit.
Yeah, I was like, wait a minute.
That makes no sense.
I'm going to find a room and I'm going to live there.
Maybe right here?
Isha.
Where are you living?
Where's your...
What apartment did you rent?
Stop stalking me.
I'm in my own place.
Away from you crazy people.
Oh, hi, Doki.
What's you people, huh?
I'm renting this room.
What do you mean, you people, huh?
you know what i mean whoa oh you're gonna go grab it all
right i'll cover you i'll cover you don't worry i got you
bro i got the highest two covers right here i've never let
anybody down yeah i have but not this time people people
people watch out the running over all of mississippi where
oh this way okay i'm coming over Oh, at Axel?
I hear them.
Ow, ow, ow.
Wait, I don't have, like, an angle here.
Oh, I got one.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Nice!
Wait, with the rail gun?
That's crazy.
Where are they?
They're right at that smoke.
Oh, I see them.
Right here?
Is there someone running below me?
I don't know, but...
I don't have long-range gun.
I'm really nice.
Oh, oh, my.
ass what it takes so long the rail gun can't be just fucking
go it's a real gun have you never used a real gun i don't
play western games i'm sorry guys i'm sorry res axel he has
a real gun bro that's crazy my i just realized my gun is not
long range so wait the axel's coming back in we stay here if
we stay here we'll section 25 the forbidden section okay
this one is definitely fire range.
Ooh, more ammo.
I can give more ammo to people that need it.
Air strike, air strike, watch out.
Where?
No, section!
Oh, no!
I'm coming over, I'm coming over!
Yeah, there's a lot of good loot on, like, sections body.
We gotta save his ass.
Saving, saving, saving.
Oh, I'm getting shot.
Oh, no.
No!
Oh, no, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Guys, maybe this was not the perfect place to live.
Oh, fucking pouch noodles.
Right up, Doki.
Right up.
Okay.
No.
I'm trying to head over to the next closest redeploy.
Oh, this is a little...
Oh, I'm getting artillery strike right here, but it's okay.
Why is this game so hard?
You think they're right below me?
I missed the days of...
Guys, guys, do you think they're right below me?
No idea, but you got this.
You think I got it?
Uh-huh.
You know what?
I'm going to be a little evil.
No, I don't believe you got this.
You're right.
Sometimes you need a doubter, you know?
You're so right.
Wait, no, no, Ducky, no.
Why do I even try?
No!
You're so right.
No, yes.
Just give up right now.
Altair is gonna be my 13th reason.
What?
What's the 12th reason?
What's the 12 honor reason?
Watch this.
Axel was the previous 12 reasons.
Axel got the 12.
Altair was the breaking point.
He's already hit me with 10 already.
Just need three more, Doki.
Hey, if you can withstand 10, you can withstand 100.
You know what I'm saying?
Just think about it like that.
can suffer doesn't mean they should right yeah exactly wow
guys this is the worst redeploy i've ever seen what the why
are the other real boys so open like what is this i'm where
i'm just like i have to look everywhere there's no way if
there are stream snipers you're gonna protect me hey stream
snipers i know you guys want to drop those custom weapons
I'm gonna go loot my dead body.
We are not gonna loot your dead body.
Yes, I am.
You are not gonna loot your dead body.
I learned so hard.
There's a...
There's something you need.
It's a bad idea.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna loot my dead body.
That's what I'm gonna do.
Maybe if you were here, you would have been.
I'm coming back.
Axel.
Why are they so green?
really man it's just my dead body bro man people nowadays
dude inflation has made people go crazy oh where actually
you don't realize just how crazy people would go over for
your dead body all right how much how much do i get paid all
right i'm going ahead i will negotiate i can i can negotiate
i can why are you still there axel why the are you still in
there you got shot at try to go get
in oh section no is there is there a team there oh my god
that software is we go we go we leave we leave we'll resume
the uav outside we got it we got a chauffeur a little bit
that's a uav uh it's like uv online you know oh like a
straight i got i got the rocket launcher i'm guided rocket
launcher by the way i'm guided oh someone's using a redeploy
right now The only redeployment is like literally right
across the map.
All right, do we go?
I guess we do, don't we?
All right.
I think we got it.
Ladies first.
I use my grenade along, sure.
Yo yo, I'll show you guys something cool.
Check this out.
Yeah.
What the fuck did you do?
I'm watching, I'm watching.
I'm checking it out.
I already, I already used it.
Oh, you put a little wrap for us?
why are you such a quick shot bro come on a ladder oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa that's dangerous man all right we're gonna
have to go to that next read-up play without running the
open field saving private section oh bro a chopper oh oh my
god there's a chopper here i don't feel that whoa this
chopper is like on fire holy yeah yeah this is why we don't
use the chopper hey if i die i die i don't know if i can
make it there in time i can make it there we got it there's
a lot of ash fire gunshots but like that looks so safe yeah
i'm on my way guys wait you're getting shot at axel axel oh
i'm kind of fucking them though okay if you're gonna die you
better look at this look this guy's covered like oh oh so
you gotta die soon you gotta die soon five seconds i'm out
of here with the vehicle die axel come on i'm drive maxin
right now where are you shooting at super far north okay i
got the vehicle oh my god i got out i got out i guess
somewhere over here i just said i'm gonna drive out of the
oh my god he actually did it he actually made it that madman
What a mad man.
Come on, I'm Japanese.
You know, I'm Japanese.
I watched a lot of it.
It should be.
Hey, welcome back.
Yay.
Welcome back.
But we'll go.
We gotta leave.
Straight, straight, straight, straight, straight, straight,
straight.
All right.
Don't you save my life over there?
I didn't do anything.
What are you guys doing?
own life.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm safe now.
I am dead.
No!
Where did he come from?
Wait, where are you?
Why are you over there?
Guys, guys, come here.
Come here.
I have the best spot ever.
Guys, no, no, no, no.
There's no way.
Unless they throw an artillery strike, we're fine here.
Unless they use that one ability that everybody has.
Yeah, yeah, don't worry.
oh there you guys look at okay but we don't shoot oh come on
i'll tell you why did you have to notify everyone because i
killed someone okay that's cool you need help wait what the
hell you don't need help right because i'm just gonna i'm
lying i think i'm good oh i can refill ammo by the way if
you want ammo squads left seek squads yeah that's why i'm
yeah we gotta we gotta make sure we Okay, I'm gonna go get
lunch then.
Good job, guy.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What if we die?
I'll tell you.
If we die, he's gonna have to keep playing.
Fucking hoes.
I thought at some time.
If we die, we're also gonna have to keep playing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But he wants to eat lunch, though.
It's okay.
I had a dinner already.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
An hour ago, so I'm not that hungry.
Oh, okay, yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah, all right.
He's just, you know.
Yeah, just...
Oh my god, what the fuck was that?
Did you see that?
it's my drone oh that's your drone wait the wind field said
i'm ready only if you're not drunk wait we're in zone guys
the guys the work this is perfect zone guys guys guys don't
don't know attention we chill we chill we chill let me try
to kill this guy we chill um that is the opposite of chill
no no i've got a drone it's okay intense moment what if i
become like that one dick okay we're in an intense moment
i'm running ads
that's that's what they call a dick move a dick move are we
good are we good i don't know i'm chilling in my building oh
where's this is so good for us it's so good until they throw
in the artillery strike but this is so good for us like
honestly i think we're fine even with that yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's Hey, bro.
Hey, we chillin'?
Yeah, bro.
We chillin'.
Hey, bro.
His face is so bloody, man.
Me and our bro.
Chillin'.
We're still in zone.
We're still in zone, guys.
We are not going to be in zone soon.
We are not in the zone.
We're getting shot at.
We're getting shot at where we are.
Oh, shit.
Leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave,
leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave, leave.
And there you go.
Okay, chat.
I'm running ads.
I think it's GG's guys.
I think it's GG's.
Got one got one.
Oh no, from the back.
Oh my god, there's a sniper right there.
There's a sniper right on me.
Don't don't don't don't pick up the hill.
This hill has a sniper.
This hill has a sniper in front of me.
Yeah.
Oh no, this is bad.
This is bad because that team is literally looking at us and
there's last two teams and they have...
Oh, um...
I'll tear.
I don't know.
The only thing I could do is maybe I can airstrike this.
This is a huge poor economy right now.
We shall.
And I'm there.
It's fine.
My airstrike went off.
My airstrike went off, but I died for us.
I don't know if you can rest me, but my airstrike went off.
Oh, I can try.
I'll tell you.
I don't know.
I don't know if this is a good idea.
I got killed.
I gotta kill.
My airstrike did it.
I- I- Okay, this is it.
This is it.
Oh, this is it.
I gotta kill.
Let's keep laughing.
Let's keep smiling.
Okay.
Am I gonna get to run my ads, man?
These guys are staying alive for a bit?
Oh, God.
Okay.
They're fighting.
Should we go?
Okay, let's go.
I'm dead.
No!
This one West, one West.
I'm dead!
Second!
No!
They're fighting but the fight fucking ended so fast!
All right, guys, I guess it's time to run the ads because
they lost.
You know what?
I'm also gonna run ads.
This is evil time.
bathroom people are running time oh I'm so sad we were
almost there we were at so close we were almost there
they're so close they're just guys like the drunk guy was
like I'm ready but I can't I want to ask him if he's drunk
are you drunk I can't ask him that what if we only get him
in if he's We invite him for one game and then if and then
we and then we kick him No, no think about it like you know
those if he blows over a point zero seven then we keep him
in yeah Haven't you ever seen those like Chinese kung fu
movies the strongest guys are the drunk ones you have the
drunken style That is so true.
That is so true.
Okay, be right back.
I'm gonna go to the restroom All right, while you guys are
waiting.
I guess I have to do my giveaway thing.
So I'll be right back to Wait, you do giveaways now?
no no i have a i have a sponsor with msi right now so all
right yeah yeah yeah yeah so i'd be right back real quick
too i'm gonna death in real quick all right guys almost did
not forgot about the giveaway everyone uh i didn't forget
about it guys anyway so let me let me pull up the giveaway
rulers real quick
okay um alright so the key way we're gonna give it away let
me next alright the key wait I'm on the wrong one I'm on my
Twitch night bot give me a sec I'm on my Twitch night bot
give me a sec guys let me get on the YouTube one because
that's like VIP.
I don't have VIP here.
I don't have VIP on the...
Oh, I have to access it.
Alright, give me a sec.
I got...
Yes, it's me.
This is me.
Alright.
My YouTube channel.
So for those who don't know, if you've done the AIM Labs
challenge with MSI and you...
Yes, continue.
And you have a screenshot ready.
If you get picked, please have a screenshot ready for...
For the MSI, monitor, raffle.
The monitor is only restricted to NNA citizens.
So if you do win the raffle, MSI will look into getting you
another monitor that, or I don't know, get used to something
else that they can ship you in your country.
Or get a Steam wallet code of equivalent value.
So I don't know.
I think the wallet monitor is like $1,000 plus.
So you win this monitor, but you don't live in NA, you get
$1,000 worth of steam money, basically.
So if you guys win the raffle.
But you have to make sure you do the AIM Labs.
Do the AIM Labs challenge.
And be able to have a Twitter account so you can DM the Doki
merch Twitter account that shows him the screenshot if you
get paid for the raffle.
Anyway, let me check.
Alright, so the key word is exclamation point.
this is a keyword to enter the giveaway so let me do done
all right i will be pulling here so use exclamation point
msi to enter for the monitor i will have i'll have it play
for hello and no i'm not okay good winfrey's not drunk now
okay this is winnable this is so winnable everyone entry
i'll let it play for uh for like two minutes until like uh
621 and then we'll pick it to make sure to use explanation
point msi for a chance to win a monitor yippee oh my gosh so
many participants so many people
participating No, he's not getting drunk, guys.
We have, we were so close.
I can't believe we got to say, I didn't know, I thought they
were, I thought the guys were up the hill.
I should not have just ran out.
I was like, they're up the hill.
That's where we last left them.
And I was so, goddamn, I was fucking too in that game, bro.
I was fucking killing everybody with a goddamn pistol too.
One more minute, guys.
One more minute to enter the, I got so excited.
They're fighting.
We third party.
And then my apex unga bunga brain went off.
Alright.
621.
The moment it's 621, I am pulling the winner.
I'm pulling the winner, guys.
Yeah, the fact that the fight was so fast, too.
Like, the moment I went off, the team already died.
Oh, we got in a... Oh, wait.
in the game i didn't expect that i'm still doing my giveaway
guys i'm oh i got timed out we got timed out for an activity
i was like what oh we're still in the lobby together thank
god i was like where are we all right calling for the winner
and all right i'll give 10 seconds for those who want to
enter at the last second 10 9 8 7 6 5 Four, three, two, one.
Choose a winner.
Pocket Printy.
Thank you for winning the giveaway.
Congratulations.
Please, like I said, take a screenshot of your AIM Lab
participating in the AIM Lab's MSI challenge.
The screenshot of you, of the, you know, if you're the, you
know, the, you know, That's the stats page that I did
earlier.
So basically where you get to see leaderboards and like what
you got and everything.
Take that screenshot.
Send it to a Doki merch Twitter account.
We are going to confirm.
I will be on stand down right now.
Stand by.
Sorry, stand by.
Let me see.
So this is the Twitter account.
Please make sure to DM or reply with a screenshot of the
result with your Twitter account.
So they can confirm.
that it is you and also you know confirm not you know
confirm that it is you if your twitter account is a
different name to your youtube channel please give us
evidence that this is you that you are pocket print me make
sure so we're i'm on standby right now i'm on standby right
now to get confirmation that you have sent the information
but to be fair we will give you five minutes to do this so
make sure you get all this done in five minutes guys i can't
sign it it's not even sent by me i'm not the one sending it
it's sent by msi oh they did it okay i'm waiting for
confirmation right now from the mods i'm waiting i'm still
waiting i see waiting for them oh we're waiting show please
show the youtube handle as well if you can pocket that you
that it is you show that you own that youtube uh youtube
channel so we don't it's not like some random person yay
congratulations pokey congratulations we're winning the
modded yay all right back to battlefield add done but thank
you again msi for the sponsor please feel free self i have
been using this monitor for my gaming the last week or so i
mean i literally got a top 502 days with this monitor so
like it works like 500 frames is crazy it actually is makes
a huge difference all right anyway here i'm i'm deaf in
hello i'm back i finished my ad welcome welcome just in time
for our ad hey buy your regis alter and axel serious hoodies
yeah sure okay i'm done we got the drunk man on our team
yippee yippee all right i'm ready i'm ready too wait are we
are we matching all right he's not drunk this time so like
okay okay like i swear to god if he doesn't get us top 10 in
this game we kick him dang hey that that's what you said
that's what i said that's right that's right we have
standards here also if i don't want to kick him i just want
to punch him i mean you can punch him are you gonna punch
him in the balls uh in his bloodline maybe in his fields
yeah what would you say to make to mentally hurt him
windfield more like loose field no no thank you for the pity
laugh now i appreciate that oh wait look at what windfield
said you see how you see the hose we're watching yeah he
sees our hoe
how fast fast are your feuds we got an honorary hoe here huh
look are you are did you see what winfield said look at our
look at the chat look at the squad the party chat i'll let
you punch me in my field like the ball sacks does that mean
you know what they call it they call it a sack whack a sack
wax how do you know so much about sack wax oh bro you got
whacked in the sack fuck yeah wait for fun oh yeah but I but
I was like I was I was like an insane magician at doing sack
wax bro I'm not even kidding oh so you would just do like
like abracadabra and whack someone's back yeah yeah i was
literally like the voldemort of backwacking i'm not even
kidding the one who showed up in me like people in seventh
grade they would have their fucking hand over their crotch
because they were so scared of getting whacked from all
angles it's like he's right behind me isn't he guys i was
like i was the magician Walter White of Sackwack.
The Walter White.
I would grab, I would have something, right?
And I'll pause it to him and say, yeah, I'll like, I'll say,
hey, can I borrow something?
Oh, wait, I'm the jump master?
Okay, sorry, you're jump master now.
Well, yeah, I'm giving it, I'm giving it.
You can give it.
I don't need that code for a second, right?
And then I would, like, throw it in the air.
And because he had to catch it, he said code, right?
You gotta catch it.
Yeah, I'm over here.
of knowing starts of nowhere so he got to catch that shit
and as soon as he catches it yeah i unsheave my hand your
hand and i would uh whack just swipe into that yeah whack
thine sack you would whack dine sack right there it's just
bgs you know it's just ggs they don't they haven't so much
yeah they don't have human rights after that you know i like
i have told so you ended their blood like that early damn
that's hardcore i started for middle school yeah it started
they're they're infertile in middle school i was i was
really good at it dude i was really professional you're
really professional too yeah i'm very proud of you man i'm
so proud of you don't want me i can tell to my grandma look
it's also serious you know the sagwacker yeah that's why
that's why you don't have children grandma that's why you
don't have I was just too good at it, you know.
It was like...
It was a legacy.
Wow.
You were...
It was a legacy.
What happened?
Why did you stop?
Some sacks were not meant to be whacked and he sacked.
He whacked too hard.
What is this?
Oh, this is my grenade.
Too close to the sack.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
They must have nothing.
I was like...
I flew too close to the sack.
Have you got okay, but have you they ever like got you
though did it get oh, yeah, it did obviously You know
Michael Jordan didn't just have only wins, you know, he had
some loss He also sacked whack, you know, Kobe Bryant
Michael Jordan LeBron James They all had losses in their
side backers.
Yep.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can't have a perfect record Exactly,
you know, it doesn't make the game.
Okay guys, I think we got a hope out here guys Can I have
some healing, please?
Chair.
And KK, you slut.
Whoa!
Only because I must!
Only because you must.
Oh, shh.
Oh, my god.
I got one.
Oh, shit.
There's our air strike.
I got kill confirmed, though.
I'm gonna assassinate Thor.
Let's go!
What's our grenade?
Grenade.
Where's their homies?
I'm gonna steal their items.
I'm gonna steal your body.
Wait, where are you?
Don't kill, Hank.
Nice.
Where's the bodies?
I marked them, but...
Yeah, there's one more over here somewhere.
I'm here.
Wait, I'm gonna get the dog guy?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's dog tag.
That's right!
Cheek him!
Tell them where- One ahead, one ahead, one ahead.
Oh, ammo drop.
Whoa, shotgun.
judge oh he's throwing a grenade we gotta run at him right
i'm going right yeah he's dead yeah he's not living that
there's a sniper right here wait whack his sack whack is
we're here to continue axel's legacy oh that that was all
that was it i was like it was it was a short-lived legacy
you know it wasn't that long we gotta continue it we could
be the Backers.
Yeah, yeah, we're the Sack Whackers.
I hate this name though.
because we have TSW.
TSW the Sackers.
Oh!
Let's waft your sacks!
Okay.
Nice.
We have TSV at home.
I'm down, I'm down, I'm down.
Oh whither you?
I got you, I got you.
I got you.
I got him.
Don't worry.
I already have a...
I already have a deal with blue balls.
You know what you want to do.
Thank you.
Oh, geez.
I'll just naturally regenerate.
Thank you very much.
Or I'll just die.
You know what?
Hey, real fact.
So fucking selfish.
Where the hoe's at?
One more hoe.
So unappreciative.
Sometimes I can do it.
Sometimes I can't.
I learned how to whack the sack.
Whacking the sack.
Woo!
It reminds me of that fucking sack whackers.
The South Park song.
Taisetsuna Mono, protect my balls.
It sounds better with his weapons.
Let's fight.
You guys don't know?
Oh man, we should have grabbed the car.
Taisetsuna Mono, protect my balls.
Sack whackers.
Oh, there's a mission.
Where's our mission?
Let's just kill someone.
Should we hunt someone?
Oh, I guess it's just us finding someone to hunt.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a package in front of us.
Wait, there's a guy that...
Wait, there's someone to kill on our left side.
I think that's the mission, isn't it?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God, guys.
This guy is 200 miles away.
I'm not...
I'm not.
Fuck that.
Oh, are we going to go with the chopper?
Chopper?
And then we just gunned it down from the skies?
All right.
believe guys surely we won't die right surely i'm just gonna
jump okay i don't want i don't want to i don't want to fly
excellent it's up to you i'm gonna be the gunner i want to
be the gunner okay winfield winfield drive the plane you
have 200 no no get the game oh gosh i shouldn't fly i really
shouldn't fly winfield no get winfield winfield fly the
plane you have 200 levels my ice cream please level 200
that's like oh goodbye i'll do it did you get in i'll say
heck yeah i did all right kill him kill him it's right here
Oh, oh, oh, oh, I see him.
I can't.
Oh my gosh.
It's a perfect fire.
A10 war dog.
Oh, I got him, I got him.
You got him!
Yeah, I got him, I'm gonna jump out, I'm gonna jump out.
There's another one, another one, another one.
Don't worry, I got you.
Let's go.
I'm gonna go over there and get fucking sniped.
Nice, you got him, you got him.
I'm stealing his armor too.
Dude, that was actually pretty easy.
Yeah, that was pretty easy.
Yeah, that's what I'm seeing.
We gotta let him drive this guy inside.
This guy inside.
Yeah, I'm coming over.
How did that work?
How in the world did that shit work?
Oh, wait, someone redeployed on top of you guys, I think.
Oh, on top of us?
This guy left side of this building.
Alright, I'm here.
Wait, there was a...
Oh, I didn't see the mission reward.
Wait, we got a reward behind us, guys.
We finished?
Oh.
Yeah, but he...
gave us a reward and we didn't even take it okay let's just
go to the woods whoa bye guys I'm going helicopter so yeah
they didn't know we failed why the fuck didn't give us a
reward all the way wait someone took our reward someone took
our reward in front of me let's kill them whoa oh JK I lied
protect your sacks I lied you're really good at gaslighting
yeah JK I lied oh we got another vehicle we got tank tank oh
shit actually yeah yeah yeah yeah it's tank tab don't mind
if i do wait there's a car in front of us watch out your
line your line i think like i think he saw me i think that
was take i think that was take i think that was a take i see
a big explosion i think that was a t oh yeah that's a tank
no that's a tank i thought that was a car but that was a
tape guys what's the time oh you can be like oh look it's a
rabbit oh it's a killer rabbit oh no don't hurt me I'm just
a little guy who's sniping mr.
sack whacker all right protect your sack here comes the
whack that's good that's really fucking Honestly, it could
be like a pro game.
Oh, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
They're right.
I hit something.
Oh, they're gone.
Bro, this LMG takes 20 years to aim.
Okay, their car is so fucking fucked up.
Yeah, if they get shot, it's just CJs.
I think they got off the car.
Oh, behind, behind, behind, behind.
Ow!
Oh, no.
no oh no wait he was they were the ones that we got down oh
these are the people we gunned down earlier too oh we're all
back in psp is now team sack beaters no i'm gonna go to the
custom weapon drop why not bro i might as well yeah sack
beaters oh no honestly my mom's gonna cook with me Pro
gaming team, you know, and then it's like a goblin holding
like a fucking sack, you know, the sack whacker Don't doubt
your inability TSV brings infertility
People on me.
Oh, you are so far out there you are so far noted I'm
leaving we gotta leave
What's this Why is there an ice cream truck here?
What am I going to do?
Oh, Altair, we said we are leaving.
It's okay.
I had to drop really far.
Altair, what are you doing, bro?
Don't worry, he's resing here.
It's called a quick teleport.
That's true.
It's okay.
There's a custom care package here too, so...
He's resing, he's going to book that job.
I learned it from League.
It's called Quick Backing.
Ah, the proxy.
Yes.
The proxy people.
Disgusting.
Alright, don't worry.
See, I helped out too.
Boom, boom, boom.
That one second changed everything.
Thank you for the save.
You guys be careful.
Oh.
Oh, isn't that?
Oh, Indiana.
Indiana Pacers.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Get copyright striked.
It's true.
I'm on Twitch.
That's true.
You got to happen to you.
Oh, I see you.
He's over there.
Come on, you can outsnip that.
Indiana Pacers.
If he peaks.
Yeah, he's pussy.
Also, there's still 20 squads.
I feel like I've been fighting a goddamn war.
all right all right what's the call we what do you mean
what's the call oh hamburger hamburger bro those guys just
why is there a car yeah yeah there's a car in the fucking
ball i mean that's pretty normal i've seen that yeah really
really love the mall really america now yeah do people not
do that God, it's like a battlefield.
Guys, it's like a battlefield right now.
I feel like we can literally chill in this area.
Bro, we can like we can literally chill, like, live here if
we wanted to.
In a mall?
Yeah, in a mall.
Have you never lived in a mall?
My school, one of my schools was in a mall.
Oh, vehicle, vehicle, vehicle.
Where is it?
Wait, someone's resing, too.
Have you guys ever wanted to make those videos that's, like,
hiding in the mall for 24 hours?
Yeah, but then I'll be able to trade out my beach.
All right, guys, this is my new path.
There's, like, a zombie apocalypse, you know?
I would love to do that kind of stuff.
Who would be watching your YouTube channel in a zombie
apocalypse?
Me.
The hoses are watching.
I'd watch it.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, I should be going to you.
guys i just realized i'm not in zone i feel like i've been
walking away from zone i was walking up deeper and deeper
away from zone vehicle vehicles tank tank tank tank don't
show your face you're gonna blast you i think they're going
to blast that place aren't they guys look at this is my new
hiding spot they will never know i love how everyone just
stopped shooting as soon as Don't worry, I have their backs.
I have their backs.
Yeah, come up.
Is that all drone?
I got one.
I need help.
I'm coming.
I think they're gonna res.
He's right here.
Feels dangerous here.
Use caution.
Get domed.
I think they res.
My guy's gone.
Come on.
I killed one.
Not sure if he was related though.
What is this fucking beeping sound?
I killed him again!
Nice!
That threat!
Squad white Okay, that's right Kathy works Wait, wait there.
Oh shit.
I'm grabbing that I'm grabbing this Wait, explosives
explosives watch out What's this anti-vehicle drop I'm gonna
grab this grab getting our army What up?
On my way on me on me on me on me on me on me on me on me on
me on you where's on you?
Oh my god, you're on the roof.
No, I'm not on the roof.
I'm inside the building.
Wait, how are you?
I'm riding somewhere.
I'm riding in one of the...
Yeah.
I don't even know how to get to this guy.
Oh, Rattadon.
Yeah, it's the same guy.
Okay, okay.
He's real low up there.
He's real low?
Okay.
I don't know how to get up there.
That's the thing.
Go outside.
There should be a staircase.
Oh, wait, wait.
In front of me.
Bro, he's one.
He's one.
No, it's the same guy.
Winfield!
TTV bad aim.
Oh, he was so low too.
Guys, I don't feel bad aim.
Winfield, please.
I am so healthy.
Ah.
I told you, I knew I was healthy.
Wait, can we even get you?
Winfield.
Winfield, how would you do that?
He's ratting so hard this TTV died.
Goodbye.
Okay, that's not what that's what's not the TTV guy though
Oh, no, you got this Oh, no, oh, no, I believe I believe my
friends are dead Push me to the edge oh my friends are dead
How could you guys die?
Oh my god, I went the wrong way how do I get out of this
house i mean odd time because we died oh my god how do i get
out of here i'm so scared oh there we go oh tv batting died
nice guys there's no real toy guys oh is there no more
there's no more oh come on how are we gonna win this okay
there's a report button at the below This is how we're gonna
win this, guys.
I'm gonna make sure nothing bad happens to me.
Report Doki Bird for Master Beta.
I gotta make sure.
Okay, so we did get top 10, so Winfield lives another day.
Yeah.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, I see the fire.
spawn bacon no there is no respond yeah wrong game axel
wrong game yeah hey wait wait wait is american why the this
american people love bacon so much i don't get what's so
good about bacon anyways it's okay oily it's okay but it's
not that good come on right does someone agree with me like
i hear people behind me all right you hear that i think
that's the radio isn't it I don't know three footsteps near
yeah yeah yeah I literally hear them right behind they're
right behind me aren't they oh my god they're right beside
me and right behind me guys oh my god oh my god just act
like you belong what the fuck
What?
That's an ad worthy death.
There's no way.
There is no way.
And they owned this guy's walling.
I refused.
This guy had to be walling.
Like, there's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Or you just got stream sniper.
There's no way.
Don't see.
He knows exactly.
He went in there and shot the building and then left.
Like, there's no fucking way.
There's no way.
Crazy.
How did he know?
That's just life, sometimes maybe good, sometimes maybe
sheep.
Oh, they have recon?
What the fuck is recon?
I know every...
There's recon in this game!
I think I just unlocked my drone.
Wait, how the fuck you unlock shit in this game?
Level up.
I'm level 10 now.
There's a monitor sensor.
Oh my god, there's a recon class.
There's a recon class?
That's a sniper class, right?
Is that the sniper?
I think so.
Oh, they have motion sensing.
Oh my god, there's a recon class.
I'll tell you, why have you not been reconning?
I'm trying.
I'm having trouble believing that.
because I think I remember that like you have not giving me
intel on I gave you intel when they were running up on us
and then we died anyways no no that's not true yeah you gave
your intel via your eyes but what about your recon yeah my
bet I'll give you guys wall hacks next time yeah where are
my wall hacks oh it doesn't spot you if you're prone or
crouch there you go see our level 220 man knows how what it
knows how it goes you can sprint walk out too oh yeah okay
I'm gonna next time I next I'm just gonna prone respect for
not using armored vehicles thank you we tried and then we
died no axle tried and then he fucking shot come on what do
you mean did you not get shot at no no I try to I try to
block their vehicle and then they just blew me up I was kind
of crazy man I don't know what they used against me but how
about the chopper method hey that's pretty cool you know we
just went in gun them down that was sick but i ran out yeah
yeah that one was sick though i like that game plan we had
we're getting better though we're we're the consistently top
yeah yeah we're getting better too yeah yeah all the
children are on as well which is great i'm glad more
children please play this game
bullying kids exactly guys finished school came home
finished their homework that's how it should be the games
you can play for 30 minutes today honey and then he pops on
the one game gets destroyed that's how it should be get
destroyed by the sack whackers bro talked about well i'll be
whacking sir don't we're gonna make sure they their boss
never come out oh my goodness we're gonna make sure their
boss never drop They are not bawling.
No!
Yeah, I need to advocate for these guys.
It's okay.
I will, like, type in all chat saying we're doing you a
beneficial thing in this time and economy.
Yeah, yeah.
It's not a good time to start, kids.
In this economy?
Yeah.
Not a good economy right now.
Guys, we're doing you all a favor.
We're relieving you of your...
line up line up we'll charge tickets too wait we can do that
yeah yeah we can do that now well we can i think now i'm i'm
i'm getting yeah now yeah you used to do it for free and now
look if you're moving up in the world once you can monetize
you can do anything yeah exactly oh i don't have a shotgun i
don't like this i got an airstrike let's like you go i like
that anyone else man i'll just grab those intel cases to
give you more experience yeah i don't know where it is it
just it's it's yellow oh yeah i grab him when i see him is
it just me or does his accent get a lot more australian
recently it's probably because he's homesick he's looking
homesick that's why i don't hang out with too many americans
dude i want it i want it i want an accent you do have an
accent it's american yeah it's an american accent yeah yeah
vanilla is also a flavor sure yeah yeah vanilla is a flavor
that's why it's called vanilla yeah sometimes i want to be
chocolate frosted you know sometimes i want to be strawberry
pudding well i'm sorry but your expectations are a little
too high well i mean in this time and age you can be
anything you want out there you can be a broccoli for all i
care and he's gonna be so disappointed when he's not you
gotta be real no well you know that's why you just say i
wouldn't love you if you're a tomato okay even if you truly
want one you can just you can just leave here one you know
oh no that's what that's what's important wait someone
landed here wait someone landed on this i'm getting towards
axel wait they're on the roof right now i'm looting i think
that was me we just you or landed there oh okay i literally
saw yeah okay maybe it was you wait why are people in my
chat asking me if i would fuck a veggie hell no what is
wrong with you guys axles after that veggie tail veggie tail
i mean look at larry though have you seen larry's larry the
cucumber he's larry the cucumber i don't know what about bob
the tomato my veggies man like what's his name the asparagus
guy bro he's vegetables i respect my vegetables yeah
cauliflower okay cauliflower is good i found all right
what's like your what is your go-to fucking vegetables
that's your go-to vegetables shut up axel we are having a
moment do in your spare time?
I'm Canadian.
That's a bad thing.
I am Canadian, you racist.
How dare you profile me?
Just because I'm an NA, you profile me as an American?
Yep, too bad.
What are you going to do about it?
Cry, huh?
I'm going to report you.
I'll report me.
That's right.
We'll get you banned.
Artillery inbound.
Does anybody have RPGs, because you can blow up this
building, I think.
Oh, no.
If you can take out these pillars.
I got a bomb.
Someone said something in my chat, but I can't say it out
loud, but it was pretty good.
Say it, say it.
I need to say it, Hannah.
You share it?
You want me to say it?
I got...
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
There's a plane.
There's a choppy, choppy.
Don't drop us!
I'm dropping down, guys.
There was someone sniping at us from up top here.
What?
My ankles broke.
Did you not use your fucking parachute, bro?
I don't think so.
My ankles broke for a reason, you know?
Hey, it's called saving.
Saving what?
Saving my parachute, you know?
Listen, I care about the environment.
you know what the parachute that is like one cracked up top
no they're not peaking you need ammo here you go take it
thank you they're not peaking anymore yeah they're scared
they're such whoa wait i have this
There you go.
Pick me, pick me, pick me.
Did it hit?
Okay, you know what?
That's my air strike.
Oh shit!
Nice air strike.
That's mine.
That's my air strike too.
Oh yeah, no, they're dead.
Yeah, I think I killed them.
Yeah.
I sent it mine as well.
I sent it mine.
Go back in.
Let's go.
Guys, the building's gone.
Guys, I don't think I can get on that building anymore.
I think the building's gone.
Yeah, I think it's gone.
There's people shooting from over here, I think.
I can fight.
I got his shit.
Noink.
Over here, over here.
I'll top the roof.
I'll top the roof over there too.
Okay.
On ping.
I'm on top of the roof.
Right over here.
Oh, this one?
Down on the roof.
Oh shit!
Okay, I shot you guys because I was like, who shot me?
Wait, over here, over here, from here!
Wait, my gun got jammed!
What?
It did not shoot again.
Guys, I can't get over to you.
No, no, no, no, no, no, he's not gonna shoot, he's not gonna
shoot, he's not gonna shoot, he's not!
It was the fucking tallest shit ever done!
Okay, burn behind you!
Why did my gun get jammed?
the one i'm playing i'm sorry i can't get over there guys
bro i thought he wouldn't shoot but he shot oh no oh no
they're doing the thing we did to them they're doing the
thing we did to them get out of here get out of here bro
winfield is living on a certain way out here what happened
to you uh so the zipline broke after you guys went over
there yeah it's all stuck on the roof bro that guy like
stared at us for so long when i was trying to res you uh we
gotta we gotta like go back to that place and rest the ship
that we got
all right don't worry oh i'm here thank you winfield thank
you winfield's got a purple bro that was my purple what the
where's my purple i think i deserve a purple as well.
I'm alive.
Oh my god, there they are coming back.
That's like the death bill.
Oh my god, I'm gonna shot at.
Oh my god.
No!
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he's right here.
He's right here.
He's right on you.
Axel.
Dude, how the hell does he know I'm just there, man?
Oh, because he knew I was there.
Dang, it's just like you know where we are every single
time.
Oh no.
Winfield, Winfield, Winfield, don't do what I did.
Get him, yeah.
Oh my god, go, good job, Winfield.
That's my level 200, and, oh, never mind.
Never mind.
Oh, Winfield.
We're.
He can rest us.
Oh, wait, he can.
Loading feed.
Winfield, redeployed.
Winfield, just go for, just, just go for a res.
Don't be a hero.
We need a hero.
just rest us and then we will be the heroes streaming on
twitch man why oh because youtube is a bomb when it comes to
music are you listening to music right now oh no not really
it's just when you sing dmca stuff oh wait have you ever got
marked have you guys ever got dmca from something you just
hummed nope never yes you cowards wait really what song i
don't think so um i was doing a guitar stream in my in my
membership and then i got flagged for it okay but that
doesn't count you're like literally playing the notes to the
song that's not that doesn't count i meant like something
like you know yeah but maybe maybe today
oh you know what we'll actually get to mark
baby i'll kill you i can't believe this was a stream that i
found out that you were a terrorist for those who don't know
baby shark is like the most anal company out there regarding
their properties what what property do they have baby shark
we're going to ip they're using baby shark you can't uh baby
shark what's that one crab rave song it's like don't don't
don't do don't do don't do no yeah that one need the deer
it's the crab the crab rave
there is a crab rave all-school league players would know It
would just send each other that shit when you win lane at
the fucking entry.
Dr. Mundo walking up.
Guys, we will be okay, right?
I'm going to follow Winfield.
He knows.
No, Winfield has the idea.
Look, he finds a house and then sits in here like this.
This is how we get first place, guys, I believe.
LMG kit.
readings while we're here axel axel donation readings you
know whoa whoa whoa whoa where's my thank you for the uh
where's mine yo where's mine yo yeah if you don't if you
super chat to me don't worry axel will eventually get the
bunny guys don't worry where's mine don't worry don't worry
if i get the membership thank you those who are not watching
twitch and are actually youtube watches don't worry don't
worry here in whatever you guys are standing i ain't getting
it on dokey on dokey bridge channel you can get you can
donate here and axel will get your cut stop singing baby
shark baby shark there's a weapon drop over here in the
middle of the street we can watch it for kills okay you get
kicked for afk ah mr platinum sky i think even the five
gifts you see that's what we're talking about that's what
i'm talking about thank you for the five
sack wax that is five ball sacks to your way yeah every
gifted every gifted sub gets a gets their own whack in this
someone's resting over here well okay west from axel to axel
will give you that whack oh all right it gets a hundred subs
we'll let you suck guys guys guys guys there's a team on the
other side of that roof right now oh my god and i think he
has a bazooka oh that's a bazooka
I broke my leg accidentally Oh,
combat vehicle Guys, we're outside the zone Oh, he got my
armor too That sucks
Don't worry, I also have a smoke That's a thermite I
thermited myself There's a team over here and a team over
here I thought my name was It was smoke, it's okay all right
oh thank you for the 10 gifts and ships guys wow don't worry
axel will come over to whack your sack very soon why do i
gotta do that handy handy sack man yeah yeah you whack each
gift no no you are the sack you're like no no no no no no no
no no no no no i don't do max dexterity stats yeah yeah i
don't do i don't you've been training you're like a
contractor i'm sack wax to an expert, you know?
Hey, guys.
You guys need your sack wax.
Like, they don't want to be waxed by an amateur.
They want to be waxed by an expertise.
And you're an expertise, weren't you?
You're so confident.
I mean, yeah, but, you know, I'm going to do that sheet for
free.
You know, I'm a hired merchant.
You guys are hiring for $29.99 plus tax.
Jesus, shipping and handling.
Hey, Billy, thank you for that five.
You see, this is the real ones that want to get sack waxed
by me.
Oh, subject.
Thank you for the five gift and ships.
Axel will whack your sacks.
You have been queued up to get your sacked whacked by Axel.
Your sacked whack has been promised to you.
If we ever do a 3D collab, we can just easily sack whacking.
Oh, it's someone's birthday today.
It's Devlin's birthday.
Can you ask Axel to sing him a happy birthday?
That's all he ever wants.
Axel, someone wants you to sing happy birthday.
His name is Devlin.
Devlin Yeah Really, you really gonna do this shit to me?
Oh, you don't care about Devlin?
Yo, I never said that Hey, Devlin, happy birthday, yo Happy
birthday to you Happy birthday to you Happy birthday, dear
Devlin Happy birthday to you
That's right, you lost.
Yeah, I don't really have to go control.
That's looking right.
That's right.
To the next building we go to.
We can't keep riding in the same building.
We gotta keep moving.
Yeah, we gotta ride in the new building.
What is your homie to remove the venom?
What the fuck?
Why is there a flying car?
Don't worry.
It was just made in a flying car there.
Oh, there's a flying car.
I see it too.
No, what in the fuck?
What the fuck?
No, there is a flying car up there.
Oh, there's dog food.
Look at that dog biscuit for your dog.
I'm just saying, yo, you don't have armor, though.
You like...
Oh, yeah, I don't.
I'm like a baby right now.
I need some armor.
Thank you.
You broke as shit.
I gotta cover it up.
Here you go.
Oh, I hear something.
Oh.
What did you hear?
I'm closing this door.
I'm going to deal with that.
Oh, Sturkey's behind.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
The hill, the hill, the hill, the hill, the hill.
I see the nerve.
I ain't got a marksman rifle, man.
Shit.
I don't have anything here either.
Oh, there it might.
I don't see them anymore, though.
support i don't see them assault rifle kit oh i want that
kind of do you or do you not want it come on i want it whoa
okay we are going to i want to i got a moxie we got top 10.
went down people at the at the uh phone helicopter okay i
didn't see it oh my god oh my god i see him i see them in
the hill they like instantly fire squad me i was not
expecting it this is a It's a maximum key if you want.
I see them.
Wait, wait.
They're pushing up.
They're pushing up right now.
Got one, got one.
Oh!
I got tanked!
Where is this?
Wow!
Tank is south side, south side.
Guys, we gotta go in, but I don't know which way to go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go from the right side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm on the right side.
Okay.
Guys, how do I go?
I'm stuck here.
What the fuck?
There is no way to go around.
We gotta go around.
Wait, wait.
There's another guy right here in front of me.
Okay.
I guess we'll just kill him.
Don't go.
He's one!
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
There's an entire team right there.
I thirsted him too.
Nice, nice.
There's another guy too.
There's another guy too, right?
Fuck me.
Bro, they're riding as well.
They're also riding.
Oh no.
Oh, no, oh, no, oh, no, wait a few.
Oh, my goodness.
What a fucking rat, bro.
This guy.
Where's the rat?
Wait, there's a guy right in front of you.
Oh, my God.
This guy's a fucking rat.
Bro, the guy.
Oh, my God.
What?
Why is he doing this?
Go to the zone.
Man.
He knows why he's doing this.
He knows.
Oh, like, but we top 10 we got he lives another day winfield
lives another day are we killing winfield after this i mean
the moment we oh my god bro this guy is just casually
sniping everyone bro these guys play we this guy has a
fucking helicopter too god oh i got another hype chest
gotcha time i guess gotcha i got the love love love evoke
whoa use it oh what's this what does it say uh 10 sub 100
bit what does that mean huh 100 bits that's uh that's one
dollar ah hype chest on your way it says how do i how do i
unlock that so one of the guys that killed us was a hacker
or something i don't know Oh, apparently, oh, never mind.
It's a bug.
Okay, I hope it was a bug because I literally just watched
him run through a house.
Like, it's like, it's paced through.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was just like, what did I just saw?
Like, okay, he was just paced through the wall.
And I'm like, oh my God, what's going on?
Don't worry.
I gotta use my drone more.
Yeah, you gotta use your recon more, recon man.
Hey, I've been reconning.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah, you guys just don't listen.
What did you do last game with your recon?
I've spotted people.
Yeah, with your eyes, but what about your abilities and your
tools?
I pinged them.
What about, yeah, with your eyes from the people you saw
your eyes.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, you know who, you know, someone else who could do that?
Me, I have eyes too, bro.
I'm sure you do, buddy.
you know what i'll show you how oh wait that's not i'll show
you how it's done no that's right i'm gonna beat you at your
own game all right so what does what does he do guys you
scope in you can see people and point them out and then you
have a drone that you can send up into the area you can
point people out all right but what is prediction snores hey
then say
look at me my turn to recon look at me look at me yeah we're
doing predictions on my channel let's go this is the real
gambling no you should do yeah you should do gamba and be
like is he gonna go basically let's go cases why are you
gonna get a gold you should do a prediction was like
cool i don't feel like i even want golds anymore even if i
were to open csgo cases don't you want reds now yeah you
want reds now right i wanted icarus fell that's my favorite
skin oh i want a neo-noir usbs bro i love the neo-noir skins
what the are you guys talking about we're talking skin man
yeah you wouldn't get it yeah because i don't waste my money
you're right Who said I wasted money?
I invested in.
Sure, you did.
Why come sometimes...
Where are these people that you speak of?
Yeah, wherever you see the gun I found.
Sometimes the gun disappears.
Ow!
Oh, yeah, I see that hole.
I see that hole.
Do you know?
I got no gun, though.
I got no gun.
I'm with you out there.
Use your pistol.
Artillery is found.
Oh, that's not our artillery.
Wait, that's not our artillery.
That's our artillery.
One down.
Nice.
Do we get hurt by our own artillery?
By they.
Well, I'm going to find out now.
I can't take him down.
No, we don't.
We don't.
We can run in with our own artillery.
Uh-oh.
There we go.
Got him.
Whoa.
Oh, I was thinking about the same thing.
No, no, no.
It was right there.
No.
Fuck me, man.
What happened?
One down, one down.
Okay.
Finish him.
Yeah.
Last person's on the roof.
Yeah, he's on me.
Okay.
I am a little fucked up.
Oh, he's one.
He's actually one.
He's one.
How do you get to the roof?
I don't know.
But I fell down.
Hello there.
Just flop in front of me.
I don't.
You know what?
Hostile jumping.
I don't want to be medic.
I don't want to be recon anymore.
I like Artillery That's not art artillery too by the way
Stay inside, stay inside No, I'm leaving We feel down Oh no,
we feel Oh, they're going up the stairs They're going up the
stairs Just staircase Wait, they're it Yeah, that's how like
I fucking got up Oh my god We feel Oh, no Why are they such
cocksuckers, man?
Wait, there's, let me a shot for me Oh shit, this other guy
was Oh shit, this other guy was The other guy was behind!
There's another guy here, too.
How many people?
One.
Is it doable?
No.
I should have died.
I gave him a dog tat.
It's okay.
We have read up to the...
Bro, I can't kill him with a...
It's all so weak.
Jesus.
I'm getting back here.
Oh, that's not enough.
Oh.
I'll tell you.
There is a flow team.
There is a flow team out there.
I don't know if you should do that.
Oh, oh!
Okay, that guy was AI.
Whoa, whoa.
There's one more.
Oh!
Wow!
Just massive legends that guy.
I hear him healing or resing.
All right, you're good to go.
Sending you back.
This guy's dead.
All right, I'm coming over and grabbing your loot.
What are I here, Sam?
Oh, give me a sec.
I'm trying to grab loot.
Nobody.
all right where's the other guy okay i don't know where the
other gun went there it is all right oh thank you mr i think
so appreciate it thank you thank you i grabbed the artillery
strike too parish i think i have a do i have armor on your
guys this game yeah you do okay It's just glitched out.
I can't see mine.
All right, let me...
Oh my gosh, I can't even use my recon abilities.
What's the point?
Here we go.
I'm going to head out.
People are flying to you guys.
Watch out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Careful, guys.
South 210.
I'm heading over.
We're heading over.
Because we're a team.
Yeah.
Now I'm slightly faster.
If you have your knife, just like that.
exposure shut the gun in decent exposure that's right he
just has his knife running out just like that in public it's
so just my drone and spawn inside of the house b-o-v i'm in
london whoa i want to eat fish and chips in london though
that's just literally you can do that anywhere i went to
london i didn't even have fish and chips that's the one
thing i didn't have Really?
That's just fish and fries.
You can literally get five fish and...
Oh, I actually want fish and chips right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Throw the app for our fish and chips right now, guys.
I'm gonna over-eat some fish and chips.
Wait, are we in the middle?
Bro, we should just go in the...
Bro, come on, get over here.
We're gonna go to the middle and then find a house.
Alright.
Shit.
Go.
Say, everyone.
Alright.
Wee!
Are we there yet?
All right, is this the middle?
Okay, no, that's not the middle.
Wait, wait, Windfield is way back there, isn't he?
No, it's fine.
He'll be fine.
Oh, he'll be fine.
God damn it.
Okay, shoot, we're just gonna leave him like now.
What the fuck?
If we die, he'll live on for us.
Oh, oh, there it is!
There it is!
Remember that?
Remember that place?
No, no.
Okay, wait, wait.
We gotta go to, like, an outpost and just live there.
Hey, you just got to the dead center outpost.
Yeah, right here, right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is where we live.
That's where we got top two.
Okay, okay, first off, I'm going to put the car all the way
back here so people won't know that there's a...
We're, like, we live here.
Smart idea.
Like, I'm trying to make sure people don't know we live.
They're like, why is there a car out there?
Come on, come on, come on, go.
No!
My house!
They so do fucking know I'm so sad.
Okay, I'm coming back with a car.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm picking you guys up.
The world is a scary place.
Don't worry, I'm right here.
Pick up your Uber is here.
Your Uber is not here!
No, no, no, no, no.
Someone bazooka best.
Someone bazooka the zero star.
They didn't come even though they were bazookas.
Oh my god, I got bazookas.
there stay on target oh my god guys i'm feeling very very uh
very scared right now
nice oops wait so what are my what is this anti wait what
are my things that you have what is this what is this that i
just put down is that motion sensor i think so hard like
does it not tell me oh it is drone time oh so this is what
they do oh they broke my turn they were down here yeah
they're over there all right don't worry i'll also send out
my drone
they'll never expect a second yeah they'll never expect a
second suddenly third drone
oh where did they even shoot your drone i'm just chilling
wait what did i do i fired something wait can you fire
things with your oh my god wait you can damage people with
your drone why did you tell me that elton oh no my battery
is low now guys didn't shot my second drone oh no i'm just
bullying them with the sniper hi guys this is our home we
live here we're going to worm trail with me come come on
come on we're where where don't worry i got another motion
sensor right here watch this but it gets chance wait can we
have more than one mode a week we can right yeah don't worry
watch this my second motion sensor i'm away this is our
little home surely no one's gonna artillery strike us i'm
away i've been fucking cooking these guys with the sniper i
got another drone
okay oh second chance no more guys like how actual is
actually playing the game we're just like we just cry no
wait they got my emotion sensor those fuckers i got you
check this out yeah what did you get
I ain't no fucking way.
I ain't no fucking way though.
That just happens like that.
Oh my god.
Yo, wait, huh?
How did they, what was that?
How does it accurately hit me like that?
What?
Oh my god, I'm leaving, I'm leaving.
What was that?
as you were saying how many airstrikes do they have what is
this
wait what are they using what i don't even know because like
we didn't even see anything literally yeah we're not even
seeing anything they're just firing something at us how many
Isn't that what they use with the pestle?
Mortar and pesto, yeah.
They like grind the pepper.
Right.
Yeah.
Pesto Bisnell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can pick it up as loot.
Winfield, you fucking crazy!
Winfield!
Oh my god, he tried.
I didn't realize he was going for this.
Okay, so there's a team that Rita put...
I won't say I didn't have his back.
But like, you know, he's but you know what no one's gonna
expect this oh hammer drop right there no one's gonna expect
this guys oh this might be a jj's no no no no there's
another there's another read-a-play there's another
read-a-play and i think i'll tear i think we can make it to
this other read-a-play okay let's do it let's do it let's go
okay you go you go for it the one to the right i'll go to
the one to the left we split up okay all right i'm smoothing
one of us will make it like we split it up i think if we
both do one read-up i don't think it's gonna work i don't
think just die like i told you i told you i knew it i knew
it i knew it we were never gonna make it do we if we were
both there to get it we were not gonna make it i knew it you
should have came with me no Just had to yeah, you're not
getting my dog tag.
You're not getting my dog.
That's looking right that And he wins yet Bro that guy
smoked my body just so you think you try to do a finish
rate, but I I had him I showed him I fucking I fucking
Killed make sure I killed got killed instantly I don't think
you should use a drone while while you're by yourself.
I don't know man I think it's kind of cool.
Oh, look at that.
Oh It's dead.
Oh, oh, oh, there he is.
Oh, there's another.
Check the guy.
Oh, he's coming over.
He's coming over.
Oh, let's go.
All right, where do we go ladies?
Where do we go?
This, this is people over on one ping over here.
I'm going to slowly float towards the zone.
I'm not banning anyone.
I'm just heading to the zone.
I'm down.
Wait, you're down?
No, no, sorry.
Oh, let's get the car.
I'm hit with the cool kids.
Let's go.
I'm landing here.
Anyone wants to get in the car with me?
No.
I can drive.
Ouch.
above above above wind fields right next to them oh shit I
don't have Colby Oh my god no wait don't worry don't worry
I'm next to a redeploy I'm next to I I'm dead there is
another team here redeploy me please Jesus there is a
there's not a star hot control the thing is there is
literally a team right beside me guys there is a team right
beside me You can't even The moment I click that, they're
all going to be, like, turning around and be like, what the
fuck was that?
Oh, oh.
Quick, find if any of them are streaming, and then we'll
give subs.
Distract them.
Wait.
Okay.
Are you ready?
You think they saw me?
Shh, shh, shh, shh.
You're good.
Good.
Good luck.
Oh, God.
Guys, just stay very quiet.
Just make sure to not make any sound.
Remember,
guys, we don't want to wake up Axel.
Just make sure not to make any sound.
Yikes.
Oh, he's so close.
We almost got it.
It was two seconds.
It was two.
It's okay.
Top 10.
He lives another time.
We go again.
We lose another day.
Oh, my God.
Two seconds.
How does it feel, Winfield, to have your life just
precariously hanging up by a string?
Exactly.
he was almost there almost there consistent top 10 finishes
though despite what happened not bad not bad yeah yeah we're
consistent you know we've been top 10 all the time you know
it'd be really nice yeah we got top one yeah that'd be
pretty pretty nice that'd be pretty cool windfield windfield
mm-hmm why aren't you getting us top one Come on, Winfield.
The closest that we all got was when it was just Altair and
I.
That's all I'm saying.
When it was Altair and I, we got second place without
Winfield.
Toki, you wouldn't do this to Winfield.
He's been so great to us.
If he's been so great to us, why haven't we got first place?
I'll show more back to support.
I like my heal packs because I can save myself.
this stream ain't ever good ain't never gonna end oh boy
guys no no it'll end here right here right now right here
right now right here right now attention soldiers attention
bro he's gonna go grab a tank for us oh tank go grab a beer
too i can i believe maybe he plays better a knee breed or
something that's true that's true that's true i believe
actually you gotta drink too it's it's morning time perfect
time huh drink what uh strong zero oh no thank you come on
man strong zero has zero percent alcohol come on too too
tired to drink you got this too tired let's go again i
believe in us i don't want to eat pizza i won't order pizza
right now nah you know you wanna eat fish and chips oh i
know i do i don't know if there's like place open right now
for fish and chips it's 7 p.m but i feel like fishing chip
places like the good ones close so early are there there's
like four or five yeah because they're like the fish just
are asleep we gotta go now the fishy said good night yeah
the fishies are had to go to a Someone's like Popeyes.
Fucking no.
Why did he get something else like that?
Payala or something?
Where do we go?
Okay.
We're going here.
All right.
This is it.
This is the game.
I believe this is the game.
I believe this is it.
Payala.
Oh, why don't you get some tacos?
Like birria.
A birria?
A birria would go down.
not hard what you say about me abiria abiria takos abiria
well we went chinese after that chinese is good too that's
true also there is a there is an engineer thing right here
There's gunshots right here.
Yeah, but someone.
I've double shot them.
No, Winfield!
He's our only engineer!
One down.
What the?
Two down.
Are you serious?
What is the shotgun?
There's another guy right here.
Lisa.
One outside, one downstairs.
One on me.
There's no way.
There is no way.
There is no way, you fucker.
One right.
on my body outside what fucking no jesus second chance bro i
had the shittiest shotgun it's crazy
we're so far holy i guess we'll just loot these shit
scavenge house i'll do whatever is available and whatever is
here is better than whatever fuck i got earlier bro what is
this it's just someone sitting here where were they sitting
oh my god it's another goddamn shot are you serious great
game guys great game where is he where did you die in the
building where is the building in the building wait you're
died so far
I died.
Oh shit.
A lot of love campers in this game.
The more I'm covering you with you.
I love them.
That's a shotgun.
I know.
You think I don't know that?
And he has a goddamn sniper?
Yeah.
You think I...
There we go.
I'll cover you.
I'll stack these guys with a shotgun.
this guy missed in the the artillery what is my three chat
are you fucking get out of here 168 i have a pistol that's
goddamn right my turn my turn there you go nice i got my guy
walking up two people walking up two people walking up like
it it's not okay but i'm shielding
oh my god send it my guy says send it all right what it's
over here somewhere i killed one right behind this thing
over here i killed phil collins nice how do you feel about
that man fuck phil in his and his family too Yeah, that's
goddamn right.
Remember that.
Yeah, Phil.
Okay.
Maybe not.
I'm leaving.
There's an artillery.
Winfield is down.
I got no armor.
I have armor, but I need it.
Maybe.
Maybe we gotta like, we gotta leave.
We gotta leave.
You go to the newest risk.
one all right all right i'll come with you okay all right i
believe in us i'm gonna do an interview with windfield yeah
while we're fighting for our lives it's like having a subway
surfer while playing a game yeah oh oh yeah that's you i
think i don't What to do with the redeploy power Winfield
you don't believe in us and live oh wait you go there.
I I I chill up here Don't chill up here.
Don't you there's a team right here.
There's a team right here.
There's team right here That has the same idea.
There's team right here Let me check this out.
Oh my goodness What Look at me look at me.
I'm just gonna wrap up No, no, look at me.
Look at me.
They don't they don't know I'm here.
Oh, they do Shit, never mind.
No!
That's crazy.
Winfield.
Unlucky, unlucky, unlucky.
It has been.
It has been a pleasure, but...
This game is bullshit, man.
Rank 22nd place.
It's time.
We gotta...
We have to rehire a new...
A new Winfield.
Who are we hiring?
Nice.
Yeah, it's been a pleasure.
We'll adopt someone in the wild, I believe.
Winfield, it's been a pleasure.
It has been a pleasure, Winfield.
But you're out.
You're out, buddy.
I'll forever remember you as the person who was super drunk.
Super drunk.
Maybe we'll get a gamer after Winfield.
You know, maybe we'll get Winfield 2.0.
Winnerfield.
I believe.
Winfield, if you get in our game, Kill everyone else for us.
You're like one of those backpack people who just like dies
in front of us.
Winfield.
If you're Q-Sniper us right now.
Q-Sniper us.
And then land where we land.
And then we'll adopt you as our fifth player.
I'll let you join Tempest.
Yeah.
We'll adopt you.
Just land on us.
Winfield.
Wait, Winfield, why are you here?
Yes.
Winfield, we fired you.
How are you still here?
You didn't even kick.
Because we're expecting you to leave.
If we kick you, it means we have to give you severance pay.
We need you to quit on your own.
That's how it works.
If you quit, we don't have to pay severance.
You're abused to leave.
can't believe it winfield what is that curse word that that
guy said what i want seven letters wait i've got an idea
flocking guys today is my birthday can i win can you guys
let me win
a golf course happy birthday dokey happy birthday to me
happy birthday to me what did you get me as a birthday gift
elter i got you this rock no i meant like monetary value
it's a rock oh so you didn't get me anything for my birthday
you don't care i got you the most important you don't care
what and it's free how is it important it is free the one of
the most expensive things in the world is land and i got you
some land right in your pocket rock isn't land it could be
it's not land you don't care about me it's a dragon egg it's
a dragon egg you didn't get me anything for my birthday
because you don't care you know what you're that guy maybe i
don't care he doesn't care he's a mean person dude oh i got
shot at Happy birthday.
What a great birthday present.
Are you fucking kidding me?
What?
Okay, great gun.
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my goodness.
Whoa.
Out there you are crazy.
What do I do?
Oh my god, there is a...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm okay.
I'm so safe.
I'll tell you.
The railings are too safe.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I swear to God, I'm so safe.
You lied to me!
I swear to you.
Hey, look, you live.
You live.
Who's alive?
Because I'm a gamer.
You can't rely on people being gamers.
Nope, because it was so safe.
I was safe.
Oh.
Where was this?
This guy's gun.
I don't know.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, shit.
I'm gonna shot again.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I don't have nades.
This game is fucking bullshit.
Why do we spawn?
It doesn't give me nades.
Bro, welcome to the real world.
I killed one.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Oh, my God.
He also respawned, too.
Nice.
Guys, I'm gonna chase him, too.
Oh, on me, on me, on me, on me, on me!
Oh!
One inside, one outside.
Oh, 20, 20!
Oh, we don't even know how much I hit him for it.
Over here, over here, on me, on me!
Nice!
I'm so safe.
I'm so safe, guys.
Nice!
See, I told you guys, I knew I was safe.
Bro, this pistol is so shit.
Wait, who are you?
How does he have a fucking revolver, man?
Where is he?
What is his fucking game?
Crawl over here, Axel!
Nice wind field.
This game is bullshit, bro.
I'm coming back here.
One gun in this whole area.
Second chance.
What do you mean dropping in my location?
God.
kill the guy you're nice Oh my god, everyone is just here
for I wish I could have patched explosive to myself So I
could just get fucking run into them like Oh my oh wait,
that's ours Yeah, I would feel everyone.
Yeah, Winfield killed everyone.
Winfield.
Thank you.
Oh my god, Winfield There were two people approaching my
location.
Oh my god, Winfield Winfield heard what I said and it is
like leaving to me all All right, all right.
You know what?
You're rehired, wouldn't feel it.
Oh, wait, they're resting, they're resting.
Okay.
In front of me?
I got, he's slow, he's slow.
Okay.
He's right, oh, did you get him?
Nice, nice, nice.
My turn.
Nice, ooh.
Dang, nice.
Up top the roof.
My turn.
There's people on both roofs behind us.
Watch out, Doki.
I got your message.
Reinforcement.
Both roofs?
yeah which one is the other one ping on ping on ping oh my
oh yeah i see it he's one hp i'm just gonna grab his and
then try and get axel real quick are you struggling oh my
god i think i can i i can't i can't wait i can dodge this i
can dodge this i just gotta sidestep i can dodge this I got
it, got it, got it!
Let's go!
I told you, I told you, I got this.
Man, we're so good.
Wait, he's still sniping.
He's so low though.
Where is he?
Is he on the roof?
Bro, he fucking did another strike!
I have to get out of here.
Oh my god.
I'm fine.
That's my last shield.
We just ungabongered his ass.
Oh my god.
It's been clear.
Trust the process.
Yeah, cool.
Cool fucking rats once again in the building.
Just two guys sitting in a corner.
Oh, okay.
Great game.
Where is the... Okay, I'm ready to...
Hey, good job fucking coming back from your five to nine.
I'm gonna go to the next redeploy.
Great game.
I'm running to the next one.
Jesus.
How do people have so many rockets and mortars to strike us
here?
Yeah, I know.
Where did they get all of these?
I hear you.
I know.
Where is our mortar strikes?
Oh, that looks so cool.
I'm gonna be in the grass right now.
I want something like that.
I'm heading over.
I'm gonna start the...
Boomer!
Oh, wow.
You used your recon ability.
That's crazy.
No, I just killed someone.
Oh, okay.
Okay, Winfield, you gotta die, die.
Winfield, go die, die.
There's people around me.
I think there's people around me, too.
Oh, oh, no.
Lisa!
Okay, I'll tell you.
You gotta die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die.
I died, I died, I died.
Okay.
Did you get it?
I tried.
I'm heading to the next one.
Don't worry.
I did it ASAP.
I'm running to the next one right now.
I got that as well.
Oh my god, I broke my legs.
It's fine.
Are you heading over?
Thanks for always having my back, Axel.
All right.
All right, worries.
don't keep over do that okay okay okay okay i'm just gonna
hide in here then they call me mr r because i keep i'm gonna
hide here did they call you mr r what is no no resin how
would they know i'm here no one will know i am so safe thank
you axel no problem mike but we like literally use them all
the redeployers oh they're coming
oh yeah here footsteps out out out out out oh oh that's you
guys okay hey what is the exclamation mark drops what does
that do uh if the game has drops yeah twitch yeah it depends
i don't know if battlefield has drops but like it's like the
amount of hours you watch on a stream acts gives you access
to like uh extra stuff like custom skins or like uh Depends
on the game.
Nice.
Alright, I'm ready.
I hear a lot of gunshots.
I don't like that.
20 squads, 20 squads.
Guys, that's a lot of squads.
Oh wait, what's a special weapon here?
I've been fighting for our entire life, but only 20 squads.
We have because everyone got raised.
Don't worry, the moment...
A moment, a second.
Oh, hey, nice.
There's a gun.
Oh, artillery strike.
Guys, it's time.
Marksman.
It's time.
I got my artillery strike now.
Oh, Winfield!
Winfield, no!
No!
I got one!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Here, I need someone to...
I can cover if someone wants to res.
Oh, Winfield's dead.
Ow, ow.
I'm not lasered.
Oh, no.
Wait, I'm going to shot by something.
else.
Hide behind this truck.
I think this truck is safe.
Got it here.
Winfield, now!
Yeah, I'm okay.
Alright.
Winfield.
They're trying to push up.
This guy's second floor?
He's cracked.
Reach out.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Don't get knocked.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
No more duo.
I'm heading to the next redeploy, guys.
There's a car.
We have a car.
This is our only chance.
Get in here.
Exo.
Okay.
We got it.
Go.
I'll kill him.
Nice.
Or down to that list.
Oh.
It's okay, everyone.
It's okay.
Okay,
we gotta get through here and then we gotta get here and
we'll use the car as color.
Okay, fight, fight, fight, fight, fight.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, and then I'll tear it out.
We were going to this fight.
Okay, let's go.
Shoot him, shoot him, shoot him.
I don't see him.
Where are they?
Something exploded over there.
Over there.
Oh shit, oh shit.
I'm dying.
Oh no.
I'm now.
Die now.
You could have got the res out there.
I can still get res'd.
If you died now you could have got it.
You could have got another car.
I'm going to grab another car.
I'm going to grab the car and pick us up.
Wait, guys, there's a there's a res northwest.
No!
Oh my god, I got sniped.
I got sniped.
But I'm okay.
What a cinematic view.
Got me, got me.
All right, all right, there's a car.
There's a car.
We go, we go, we go, we go.
We'll be.
We go to the next one.
redeploy.
It's another one right here.
It's okay.
Finally paved routes.
Okay, all right.
There you go.
Redeploy.
Re-deploy.
I'll park the car right here.
We need to go.
See, these are teammates right here.
See, right here.
Right.
We've used like five redeploy.
guys i i don't know i don't know on the on the bridge on the
bridge which bridge to your right a little bit axle yeah
right there i saw a guy running on top of the bridge here
looks suspicious watch yourself apparently
i'm looking there's another car here too that we can use I
feel so safe.
What?
I have artillery strike too if we need it.
Team in that building right over there.
Right now.
Across the street, across the street.
Ping, ping, ping.
Okay, I see.
Didn't mean to do that.
I got the one we built back.
Nice.
I'm trying to thirst him, but I'm not gonna go.
I got shot to him.
Oh my god, I got snived.
I got sniped.
Don't let me get sniped.
Don't let me get sniped Oh my god, I hanged in there.
Get stabbed.
Fights north of us.
We can look to pick off some people.
I don't know where the sniper came from, so he could still
be there sniping.
People running across east, across the road.
Bro, where the fuck was that sniper that fucked me up?
How are these bullets just not hitting?
I hate this custom sniper.
It's so ass.
Good damage.
Where are you guys shooting at?
East.
East?
Okay, I'm looking.
They were on that truck right over there.
It was just one guy?
Two people, I think.
Okay, so there has to be another guy there then.
Oh, I'm so paranoid right now.
They could be anywhere.
Oh, we gotta go to zone.
We gotta go to zone.
Zone, zone.
shoot them in the dome dome where do we go in the zone no oh
wait wait in front of me okay okay he's one he's one i hit
40 i hit 40.
30.
that's us squad white 115 meters got a huge gunfight right
here if you guys want to stay right there starting made down
there there's also a huge gunfight and west guy he just ran
across the okay there is there was a drone near me so i'm a
little afraid about that also we have to go to uh let's see
you okay okay oh air strike we're gonna get out we gotta get
out i'm okay i'm still getting shot in the back i'm gonna
shot in the back oh they're just wrapping down in the oh my
god are you serious oh my god they were behind us fucking
hate players like and you're fucking nine to five and then
you rat your whole game come on guys let's run at people
instead hey come on oh shit oh i tried to do it until he
strikes i'm so sad i didn't get i was i didn't realize no
wind field ah the red sick dads aren't good people i didn't
think they're gonna come out i was trying to do i should
have ran i should have ran with him oh my god i can't right
below us oh my god 16 kills there that was really good yeah
that's really good we're doing it we're doing it guys yeah
we're doing it i believe it's getting there how do we kick
winfield does he want to be kicked no no he redeemed himself
because we got seven plays he redeemed himself hey winfield
i ordered pizza i'm gonna order pizza right now what pizza
is your favorite pizza you know the pepperoni with honey
spicy honey that's just so good i've not had that it's so
good it's like spicy no it's not a canadian thing it's
actually really really good i'm gonna say i like i like
spicy honey spicy honey yeah like uh the hallucinogen hot
honey it's like hot honey it's crazy good all right that
just sounds like some donald's nugget dip hot honey you
don't know you don't know you don't know good when you see
it It's so good.
That doesn't really sound like a pizza pizza.
A pizza pizza is also good.
Hot honey.
Hot honey is so good.
I'm like thinking, you know what?
Alright, I went with a pizza.
Would you guys try that hallucinogenic honey?
What the fuck?
There's this honey that's like they harvest the honey and
apparently gives you like hallucinogenic effects.
It's crazy.
i think that's them getting stung by the bees and they're
like losing no no no no i promise it's not the sting it's
the actual honey they have the hot isn't it like really
expensive that one i think it would seem so i think it was
like two thousand dollars for like one small like bottle of
it or some cheese yeah i mean i feel like it takes a while
to get that like in the middle of the rainforest and they
have to climb like these big ass fucking trees yeah all the
way at the top of some ship but they're like why don't we
just ask rpr or or or knock knock to uh climb the trees for
us that's true and get the hundred why do you do it we're
the talent we don't do that just be american just shoot
everything down you know we the talent or you can do the
bushfire method if if that what's the bushfire method oh you
just set the bush on the ocean you set the forest on fire
yeah just set it on fire come on guys it's just that easy
I'm worried yeah just say I just gotta get you get just
gotta get yourself okay pineapple and ham bro I don't want
to order from pizza huh I want something bro come on
pineapple and pizza is good why does people hate pineapple
and fun because it's weird it's so weird because the sweet
is too it's too much the sweet and like the sourish kind of
clashes with the hearty of the that's why it's good the oil
oh no oh no the game is about to start i was looking at my
pizza but i don't know what to eat why don't you get
yourself some chinese takeaway instead you know because i
want pizza i'm craving pizza you should get bulgogi pizza or
kimchi pizza pizza okay i don't think they have that in oh
i'm the jump master i don't i'm passing i don't think
that's like the ultimate the chinese it's not what i want
though i want like i want italian so american or like well
actually we're gonna chicken and honey he's not italian that
does not sound italian at all on there okay i want to say oh
wait where oh there's people inside here already fuck me i
am trying to find any kind of gun and i don't know where the
loop where loot boxes in this area i i was in oh my goodness
i found one box there's a guy with a gun on me okay i have a
another shotgun as always all i get is shotguns i guess i'm
so safe i'm so safe no you're not my safetyness is so safe
it's rated as for safe you're not safe and i know you're
lying are you kidding me like i hate this game maybe i
should just stop playing hey maybe i should someone was here
no no no no no yeah yeah you can stop play you uninstall
after after the stream bro i hate this game yeah uninstall
after the stream it's axel we gotta have we gotta have zen
okay zen embody the regis altar there's a lot of people
dying in front of me separate those murderous thoughts to
somewhere else my long-range shotgun I have so many bullets
just not registering.
It's kind of bullshit.
Yo, what?
What the?
What were you doing, bro?
Snappy, snappy, snappy.
Yeah, the S in Altair stands for safe.
You're right.
I agree.
I feel so safe.
All right.
Winfield's dead.
Winfield's dead again.
Winfield, come on, buddy.
you dead okay i'm gonna like chill a little bit and i'm
gonna stay here wait whatever i do oh does the artillery
strike work in here oh wait axel let's go axel shake him
what okay okay it just took me like 10 okay i look took me
10 years to get his oh my god his friend came over i'm
coming No, no, don't come over.
Don't come over.
He res.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I leave.
I'm getting pinged.
It took so long to get the fucking command for taking the
dog tag, man.
So, oh, Winfield's like, I'm trying to kill them, but I was
1v3, so I'm sorry.
Yeah, you should be sorry.
You should have 1v4, Ado.
In fact, I'll switch teams, 1v5.
Yeah, exactly, Winfield.
God damn.
Oh, I can't order pizza.
No, I can eat a pot.
It's my safe tunnel.
I'm a little worm.
I'm a little caterpillar in my chrysalis.
Yeah, I'm going to boil you in the pot.
I'm going to boil you in the pot.
I die.
Oh, okay.
Let's go find another arena ploy.
Sorry, I died.
Did you use that one?
A real ploy.
is uh i don't remember all right then i guess i'll go to the
next read-up plan hope that one is safe
all right that's a chopper i said went to the fucking where
the fuck is the read-up oh wait that was the read-up plan
went to the goddamn melek oh wait no it's over here i was
like where the fuck is it hey the chopper strat is a method
you know it is a method until they shoot gun us down just
don't get gunned down i don't like this because i'm on low
ground too and it's no that class does these redeploys
faster whoa oh really who's in the assault class who's in
the assault class axel i am oh i hear people people.
Second life, second life, second life, let's go, let's go,
let's go.
Alone with my pistol.
It's like you guys never died.
Heroes never died.
Oh my god, I keep getting shotguns.
All I get is shotguns.
Like there's no other gun in existence in this game.
It's just, oops, all shotguns.
Okay, yep.
just no loot no there's nothing here don't forget to check
the cars oh that's true that's true i'm gonna jump off a
building whoa guys you think we're gonna guys you think
we're gonna get the win in 12 hours guys oh i don't think so
probably not within 12 hours just one win guys but like when
When we get that win, it's going to feel so good, though.
You know?
Oh, yeah.
It's going to feel so good.
Also, there's a team right here.
Nope.
I literally saw them redeploy there.
I saw a parachute.
Up top?
Okay.
We peaked, like, an hour, like, two hours ago.
That's the saddest part.
What do you mean?
We're still growing.
Are we?
See, I'm all about cautious optimism.
are we though where are we in the middle wait guys
technically we're in the middle
technically yeah i'm gonna go underneath this parking lot
and then what is this watch this guy oh wait there's loot
here guys we loot a little bit and then we find a spot i
think technically you know i think you know i'll be able to
do something here if there was any loot to be had like what
if i just hide like there's not they're not gonna send a
strike here what if i just cry oh i can order my pizza give
me a sec pizza oh it's fine that's in there i'm literally
out out of the ring for that i'll be fine mistar pizza
deployable cover it's like like next to me but i'm okay
let's see oh oven egg cheesy alfredo personal flying in
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
What?
Northwest just flow in.
Watch out, Axel.
Axel, are you okay?
Oh my goodness!
Up top, up top, top, top!
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're up top, yeah.
Wait, they're above us?
Yeah.
It's okay.
We're safe here.
Oh, what's my three?
What is this?
How do I show it?
Oh, C4.
Oh, I have C4, guys.
Nice.
We should have C5.
Sniper.
Ooh.
someone coming down or up no no we're safe we're safe here
this is like so safe guys i think this is end zone people up
here this is end zone guys all right oh i can upgrade my smg
how oh upgrade oh you guys should have seen the barrels
fighting up there yeah all right back to ordering my pizza
oh maybe i should get my pasta with my pizza too oh oven big
cheesy alfredo pasta Yummy.
Oh, chicken of food.
Oh, I should get the chicken of Redo pasta.
Oh, that sounds so good.
Yeah, that sounds so good.
Pasta.
Pasta is so mid.
I'm sorry to say it.
Okay, well, nobody's asking for your wrong opinion.
Pasta is mid.
No one's asking your very wrong.
Coming, coming, coming.
Oh, shit.
She went back up.
We went back up.
It's okay.
I can go back to the order.
I can order my pizza, right?
I'll move like here.
Oh.
Nice.
don't worry guys i'm i'm helping
artillery strike i don't really like supreme pizza i haven't
had pizza in so long so it's so hard to decide what i want
reela thank you the super chef 48 hour stream oh wrong gun
fuck he left that oh pepperoni duo
is this the highest part of the of the building not quite oh
they look the same This one looks like a fucking a yard.
First up, pad.
Roof is clear.
It is?
Okay, cool.
That's good.
We chased them off.
Nice.
I believe in you guys.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Smoke's green.
Well, all out.
Italian sausage, classic pepperoni and caramel.
Oh, that sounds good.
I'm grabbing that.
Axel, do you see this over here?
Ah.
Okay.
There was some smoke in front of us right here.
Yeah.
Why is this item?
Oh, wait, they're deploying there.
Ooh, I'm gonna get this stuff crust.
I love stuff crust Okay, so low wind fields down.
Oh shit, wind field no, do you guys need help?
Oh from behind us.
It's somewhere somewhere.
I'm coming over.
Did you raise wind field?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Okay, that's good.
Okay, I'm going back to my pizza.
Oh my god.
Okay Get to the bottom.
Get to the bottom.
Get down here guys.
Get down here no way this is a safe spot all right back to
my pizza order oh i want to grab some oh i would love is it
the guard the roasted garlic or like the the roast type you
should get some islands black olives yeah it's just minutes
okay let me all right i got my all right let's see now i'm
gonna see what kind of beverages i want i won't order any
special just what the fuck is that oh draw dick draw a dick
yeah yeah draw somos sauce guys i'm still ordering my pizza
guys guys i'm still ordering my pizza calm down i'm ordering
my pizza right now new mission everyone
all right i got it okay we should be fine okay oh what if
you no they're right here got him got him nice nice okay i
can i can actually play that the game now all right guys
we're fine there's a there's a custom smg here oh my god
that's a different gun all right i dropped a i dropped a
sniper here if anyone's it we've got to move though the zone
is no no we're not in middle of the zone you know what you
know what this is a good place to chill when i was ordering
pizza i hope you ordered it very fast and very well oh well
i won't say fast how do i get up yeah i was like i don't do
it yet secret tunnel i like how we were outside for a bit
and we went back inside
secret tunnel Okay.
All right.
Okay, we got to try to get over here.
Yeah.
We'll try.
There is a car right in front of us.
Like a car to...
Wait, I don't get out of here.
I think we might need to take the elevator.
Where's stairs?
Oh, here you go.
Take my ammo, you whore.
Come on, take it.
Take the ammo.
Because they want ammo.
Take it.
It's right in front of you.
That's right.
Yeah, you know your place.
Spit on him.
Are you still above us?
I think we're good.
Okay, then we gotta go.
Well, there's a car in front of us.
Do we risk it?
Do we need it?
There is a chop.
Alright.
You know what?
I'll take the car.
Gunshots.
Oh, yeah.
Are we going for the gunshot?
Should we go to zone?
There's a car.
Yeah, I'm getting the car.
I thought you don't trust the car.
There's a car right in front of us that's driving around.
Well, I'm gonna go into zone.
See you guys.
This guy right at zone next to us.
I'll meet you guys in zone, guys.
I'll meet you in zone.
I think me and Winfield are gonna die.
Oh, shit, we trapped.
No!
Go upstairs!
I'm heading to the redeploy!
I'm heading to the next redeploy, guys.
I've got you.
stuck here wait wait i got an idea i got an idea i'm going
to come over i'm coming over oh no oh no okay okay okay okay
you had so much time to leave yeah oh my god what the would
you okay okay i'm i'm there is a car next to me oh my god oh
my god i didn't realize there's a there's a car I got
through was nearly it.
There was a rat.
Oh, I don't care.
There is one redeploy all the way in the middle of the zone.
I believe.
Yeah, take the car.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Am I going to make this?
I believe.
This game is a scam, bro.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I believe.
Yeah, there's only seven squads.
You just got to sit there and get I.
No, but he's not going to 1v4.
There's no way.
Of course I'm gonna 1v4.
Hello?
Don't you know who I am?
Okay, yeah, let's sit there.
Shroud 1v4.
Yeah, but that was Prime Shroud.
That was Prime Shroud.
Yeah, he's just an old man now, you know.
Shroud signed my Steam profile, so I'm- I'm- I'm- I'm- I'm-
I'm just channeling the energy that I saved since 2017.
Where is it?
Oh, did it get used?
Oh!
Eh?
Oh, it's getting used right now.
Last redeploy.
Yeah, but there's six spawns in, right?
Someone's getting shot at that redeploy now.
Yeah.
You should rat it until they're gone and then use it again.
Five, man.
Wait, wait, wait.
At this point, just rat in the grass.
You're not going to know.
You guys see that rock?
You see that rock?
Just prone on it.
Yeah.
Oh, my goodness.
There was no one else ratting already.
him too no way bro ain't no way right after that's crazy
it's actually crazy what a timing dude what a timing the
fact that he took this spot after he got out reddit bro you
actually
lives again bro was like this is my spot yeah bro just like
try to take my spot bro crazy get over at it that's okay
next game i believe next game i'm gonna kill i'm gonna kill
and watch this i'm gonna kill yeah i said it whoa kill who
Build the whole hopefully not my teammates with grenades
I'll try my best not to do that
Let's go You know what I'm guys.
I need to confess something.
I'm purposely playing bad so we can play longer.
That's why I keep dying guys I My dad works for Nintendo
Yeah, yes, I'm purposely sad bagging right now Yeah, I'm
sandbagging at the moment.
Winfield, our battle angel.
We need your buddy.
Winfield, lock in.
We need a 1v4, Winfield.
We got a win.
Come on, bro.
Well, it's your stuck with us for 12 hours.
I think he doesn't care.
Hey, Winfield, you got a Twitch.
You got a YouTube.
Winfield, come on, bro.
Come on, buddy.
Why aren't you trying?
Why aren't you trying, Winfield?
feel I thought you were a gamer my dad went to get milk I
hope he never comes
back that's kind of crazy life's tough where yeah life's
tough okay I want to have like false hope
that's crazy yeah and we still haven't won a game so
technically i'm allowed to say that oh we got so close we
got so close we got so close i missed that day when we got
that was such a nice day i'm looking at my pizza already
right now but when when we got second place together.
Altair.
Man.
Those were the days.
Those were the good old days.
Big Japanese tournaments for Apex?
Nah, nah, nah.
That one time we got second place in Battlefield.
That's where real gamers at.
Right there.
I'm so watched.
Man.
Reclaim our former glory.
Alright.
Where do we go?
Pochinkie, Pochinkie.
Pochinkie's my city.
Let's go to Lyndon B.
Johnson Oil Works.
Lyndon Oil Works.
Man, I want to marry an oil baroness, bro.
Please take care of me.
Just get an oiler.
You mean like a Saudi princess?
Just get an oil rig.
Easy.
Oh yeah, I mean, if I could just, you know, Oops, I suck at
this.
You want to marry an Asadi princess?
What would you do with that money?
Like, would you be like a house husband?
No, no, no.
I'll like go to the pokies.
Go gamble all the fucking money away?
Yeah, the pokies.
Gamble your wife's money?
Yeah, gamble your...
Not even his wife's money.
Gamble his like, fucking...
His father-in-law's money.
Bro, you know those guys can get you assassinated?
Yeah, cause they're fucking richest.
Yeah, like you think...
Oh, come on, poppy.
It's just a little bit of your money.
Yeah, like if you use up all, like, you know, his daughter's
money, he's gonna get you.
He's gonna get you, bro.
He's gonna give you more money.
Watch out.
Yeah, he'll give you more money.
You think you're gonna handle more money?
Bro, he's gonna make him disappear, bro.
So I'm gonna show him the strat to win the pokies, and I'm
gonna get him into it too, you know?
Bro, he's gonna make you gamble it at his casino.
So he gets back his own money.
All right, so money laundering, right?
So he gives me the money, but in order for him to get the
money legally, I go to his casino.
No, he builds a casino just for you.
So like, it gives you like monotony.
Just like, it's only him in the casino.
Yeah, yeah, it is.
Yeah, only him in this casino.
And he's like, yeah, but he doesn't tell Axel.
He's like, yeah, yeah, look at this new casino that like,
that just opened up, but it's actually owned by your
father-in-law just so he makes sure that you don't fucking
gamble all the money.
Hey, money laundering.
Come on.
It can't be that.
No, he doesn't even give you real money.
He just he's like, hey, pays, pays.
So a lot.
Here's some allowance and it's like fake money.
This is this is paper money from this place called monopoly
they're like oh yeah in saudi arabia we have this new
currency that we are just introducing right now and it's
green yellow red gold too yeah yeah it's our it's our new
currency bro
i'm not finding any good loot where am i hearing this bb
from someone flying in right uh in front of us not right us
i feel like there'd be someone in that i feel like there'd
be someone in that area maybe ah it's this one here it looks
scary enough somebody just redeployed i got the i got the
uav oh a good assault rifle right here oh nah oh wait oh
yeah i'll take that i still don't even know what gun is good
i've just been grabbing whatever i find Honestly, SMGs are
goaded.
They're so stable.
I'm going.
Whoa.
I'm going to this house in front of me.
Okay.
There's a team in here.
Careful.
I can use a go.
I really don't worry.
There will be.
I'm going to make sure the team disappears.
Oh, there was a team here.
You don't believe me?
No, I definitely did.
Do you see that?
There's one person, one person, one person there.
Got to be more.
Yeah, he's got to have a family.
guys artillery oh no oh no i think we'll live oh that's our
artillery now dude oh they're not gonna know double how will
they know how will they know which one's ours and which
one's theirs is there a thing they're not that's right
that's the fun of it
Where the fuck are they?
I don't know where they went.
Yeah, where are they?
They should be here still.
We killed like his teammate and then they like pussy down.
We are not in the center.
We are not.
We should go.
We could slowly rotate into the center.
You guys want to do that?
We could.
Wait, there's a smoke over here.
Did they?
Oh, invite me.
Okay, okay.
I see him.
They're literally, oh my God.
They're literally trying to fucking him.
Oh my God, bro.
the death, man.
It's just so much faster, everybody.
Jump, there they are.
Oh, shit!
Alright, it's State.
I'm going upstairs, going upstairs.
It's not fine.
Wait, you're dead.
Oh, wait, Winfield.
It's okay, Winfield.
I believe you can 1v3 this.
You ain't no nerd.
Oh, shit.
That's right.
Oh, I'm on fire.
It's okay.
Winfield's coming.
Winfield's here.
That's right.
Nice, nice.
We got a res.
Winfield!
Get over here!
Rez or kick?
No, no, no, no, no.
Winfield has to res.
Res or kick.
Winfield.
Wait, why am I not not res?
Guys.
Winfield!
Alright, guys.
Winfield, when I said res or kick, Winfield did not,
friends.
We should kick a sack.
It's time for...
We should whack his sack.
It's whacking time.
Yeah, it's whacking time.
I don't see him.
They may have fallen back.
Oh, I'll throw the axe his back.
I don't need her back.
Yeah.
I think they left.
Leave that man's sack alone.
But this is gonna be lonely, right?
right yeah yeah you should you should hold his hand hold a
sack actually you hold the sack whack that shit oh behind
behind behind oh no what oh my god i'm stuck in the bathroom
i'm safe i'm safe i'm safe thank you i'm heading over i'm
coming over artillery inbound i'm gonna take cover right now
seems yes
Oh, I'm not in the artillery range now.
We should go help her.
All right, I'm going to go over it.
We got to help Winfield.
Winfield's going at it.
Winfield's wild.
Oh, shit.
Winfield!
No, why?
Dude, fucking LVs.
Oh, my God.
It's not it.
I have to leave.
Oh, my God.
Do what you can with it.
Is he about me?
I don't know.
I don't know, but I have to...
He's on me.
Where are these guys?
I don't know.
I'm just...
One HP on me.
I need reload.
Oh my god, okay.
Are you okay or nah?
I'm dead.
Okay.
We're not okay.
I'm just gonna leave I don't trust I don't trust How do I
leave this area though?
Just jump out the window Climb up there and jump out Oh my
god I gotta find the redeployer I'm going for the redeployer
Windfield!
Windfield, no.
Windfield, you fucking wild!
Windfield, what?
I'm not I'm not going to lie, that aiming skin wasn't the
greatest idea, but it worked, I guess.
Winfield, why were you a hero?
Hello.
Oh my god, hey.
Never be a hero.
But I was born to be one.
Yeah, sometimes you can change your career path.
What if the world depends on you being a hero?
No, I don't.
Die, die, die, die, die, die, die.
Wait, what?
Die, Winfield, die.
Winfield, die, Winfield!
Winfield!
I don't think he made it.
Oh, Winfield, you fucking idiot.
Oh, my.
Winfield.
All right, let's keep going forward.
Oh, Winfield.
If we circle around security gate, it should be a little
bit, it should be a little bit safer, I mean, Axel, okay, I
was surprised Axel didn't try to redeploy to the other
redeploy.
So like...
Where's the redeploy?
Ah!
Nice.
I got one.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
There's another on the right side.
Hang on.
Oh my goodness.
Artillery inbound.
I'm in gonna die.
I'm gonna go redeploy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
People dropping in.
I'm running.
I'm running as fast as I can.
I left.
I'm heading.
I'm going over to...
Going over to Axel.
There's custom places or there's custom loot boxes.
There's are no no no we gotta we gotta go to reda ploy
There's people on me people on me.
Oh god.
Okay.
I'm running the other way Wait, what?
I'm going to the other reda ploy Dude, are you fucking
kidding me?
I'm going to the other reda ploy Bisa Oh no.
Oh no No, no I still have to live.
I still live that is your dude I don't think I can.
I still live, live, live.
I'm heading to the other read-a-blah.
There's a car here and that makes me very scared.
It's a great game, guys.
It's okay.
It's okay, guys.
There is another read-a-blah and that is the one I'm gonna
take.
I shall die then.
Goodbye.
Why do we hear this so often?
Woody!
I'm gonna hear you in my sleep.
Oh
All right, there you go.
We're all back.
Yeah All right, so we're not in the zone.
So we gotta move into zone again Where should we go?
Should we go to like Where do we go?
Where are you guys redeploying to?
I'm falling out there.
I believe.
Come on right.
There's a sniper right here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I pinged it.
Here put that sniper.
Oh my god.
Axel!
I'm not.
No, no, no, no, no, Axel.
Dude, there's just a fucking rat to think.
oh my god ain't no way man okay don't worry don't worry
there's another redeploy there's another redeploy i'm oh oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god he survived there's a
need the airstrike they have airstrike the airstrike the
airstrike the airstrike the airstrike the airstrike the
airstrike the airstrike the airstrike down there
oh my god oh my god
oh yeah those airstrikes are nuts hey please guys top 10
okay that's okay next game next game next game i believe one
more one next game next game pissing me off playing this
fuck now i see why didn't really blow up hey it's because
our graders came out afterwards everybody started playing
our graders i mean there's a reason why but everyone sticks
with that game how many players is art graders huh how many
players is art graders i don't know i mean it's a it's a
it's a what's called extraction shooter so people just come
in and come up i just see people on my friends list just
popping up playing art graders yeah i see so many people
just playing art graders everyone's just art creating and i
think a lot of people just do people still role playing art
3 days or you what oh and they'll be like don't shoot don't
shoot you that oh or if you've started shooting again oh
three oh no can you play an instrument yeah i can i can play
the flute we should we should make a wandering orchestra a
wandering orchestra actually you want to join in i'll pass
i'll be the viewer he can be the guy who like you can be our
management change and donations yeah you can be a manager oh
no i'll do that guy you guys are the band right I'll do the
fucking guy who swings his wand like a magician on the
stage.
What was that guy called?
Oh, the conductor.
Yeah.
The two person that conducted.
The one that just swings his stick thinking he's doing
something.
But you know, it's just.
Yeah.
You're just like, why are you guys?
I can do that.
You guys think we can win a game.
Guys.
Let's ask our chat.
Do you think we can win?
Guys.
Winfield you will be the bum in the squad of the bum on the
side of the road and we don't get first in this game That's
right We don't get first in this game Winfield.
You're out.
Oh, you're out and I will ban you from my stream
That's right pressure is coming That's right Winfield and
I'll ban you on Altair stream too because I modded on that
on his on this one right now I'll follow you on Twitter X
I'll follow you we don't need to win it's a it's a trash
game yeah bro Axel when we win when we we welcome to the
real world trash game welcome to the real world trash game
that's right Winfield everything is is lying on this game
now Focus what the hell is this your stream is being
featured on the home page carousel.
Yeah, I mean getting butt fucked left and right Your
language.
Yeah, so keep going Hell, yeah, let's get this guys You said
you were like oh, how do I get on the front page now?
You're on the front page.
Is that what you want?
Yeah.
Hi Twitch Can you guys change my name from Regis altar
underscore hollow serves underscore Ian to Regis altar,
please?
Do you not request for that?
Look at the fuck.
No, I didn't sign up for this event, my god.
Bro, that's on you.
You should sign up for the event and then like...
Hey, I've been asking for this for years.
And you should sign up for the event and then...
Hi, baby man.
Get destroyed, nerd.
Dead man walking.
And then like be like, oh, sorry, I couldn't show up because
I was sick.
I got sick.
I was taking a fat shit.
I couldn't show up.
Yeah.
Oopsies.
Oopsie.
I got sick, guys.
so i can't do holiday and then you get your own custom name
someone on me okay i'm coming over don't worry oh there's
three two more two more coming over still visa oh no how
many people are there two one's down two there's three now
it's three now yeah yeah yeah They got the other guy up.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm going back to Axel.
There's three.
I don't think we're going to win this fight.
I'm retreating.
I'm bravely retreating.
What a good game.
You just had to add bravely in front of us.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm very bravely retreating right now.
I'm bravely sprinting as fast as I can away from the area.
Relocating.
Oh, can I not climb that?
That's unlucky.
Okay, wait.
But what if I...
There's no way to know I'm up here.
Skadoosh.
Good at the dude.
All right.
Oh, Winfield's going back in.
Okay.
Winfield.
Never mind.
Oh, shit.
Winfield.
His name's fun to say, at least.
That's good.
Yeah, I got a shot from my back, but I don't know from
where.
I'm heading.
I'm still handing over to you guys.
someone res knew you guys careful yeah in front of me yep
we're resting we're resting oh my god oh my god oh my god i
know you're back
nice oh my god are you serious oh no oh no oh no oh no i'm
dead i'm dead here i'm dead here I'm so dead.
No, no, no.
I got cross-fired like hell.
Like there's like 20 people on every...
What do you guys got to leave?
What do you...
Great game.
It's okay.
I have one more res.
Axel.
It's okay, Axel.
I believe.
Sniper does not work with this ping.
It's just so miserable, man.
Jesus.
It's okay.
I'm finding the closest redeployed and I'm going to land
there.
Ah!
I checked that entire area.
He's still there.
Wait, wait.
Windfield is safe, though.
Windfield is safe.
Wait, we all have read-a-ploys, technically.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We all have read-a-word.
Don't worry, Windfield.
I go fly to the read-a-point.
You live.
You survive.
Okay, of course.
Look at this man.
He's running with conviction.
Where's the closest one?
I'm going to go here.
Thanks for playing with me.
us the axle no problem i don't even fucking see that
redeploy thingy i see it uh there's one to your right in
front of you i'm gonna do the craziest redeploy guys watch
these okay windfield die you gotta die windfield you gotta
die he died okay good windfield he was born to die
What are you doing here?
Yeah, there is a chopper.
There's a chopper above us.
I'm going to the house is nearby.
See if there's loot.
Oh, there's like...
Alright.
I believe this is it.
This is the game guys.
This is it.
There's no loot.
This is the game.
I believe.
This is it.
This is the game.
Axel, we need it from you too.
Yeah.
This is it.
Okay, there's no loot in this house.
Wait, there's no guns here.
Where are the guns?
You know what?
Oh my goodness, there's people here.
Wait, where are you?
Should we do a mission then?
Great.
Wait, where is Axel?
Maybe I should just fucking go on a chopper and just go
fucking like kill myself, you know, like...
Wait, you go on a chopper and then like, like fly into an
enemy.
I am gonna go...
I'm playing on NA server anyways, right?
I like keep a cannon, you know what I'm saying?
Keep a cannon that way.
Wait, Axel, you're still alive?
though for now wing ring prediction where is it predicting
uh honestly if it keeps pulling towards us this is really
good for us isn't it yeah yeah that's true we can just chill
here it's like our little suburban house look at that cheap
rent watch this guys i closed the door and yeah the rent is
so cheap that's why oh my god what the fuck i just oh it was
a lead look this is my no
when's my pizza getting here Winfield's gonna deliver it
once we win yeah exactly so no pizza until we win I wish I
had guns I have a gun for you Winfield you come over come
over here I got you a gun I found a gun perfect yeah I have
gun come over
all right 20 squads let's go we're doing it we're doing it
all right zone prediction time i think zone would will take
us yeah wait how do i ping on this map yeah oh this is kind
of cool what is this wait what are you doing are you on the
play what is that do i get that oh wait that's stupid what's
this oh is that my smoke oh oh my god could smoke this
entire time oh my god 24 hours to learn that smoke no i
couldn't i didn't realize i have like a smoke screen oh guys
oopsie so the thing that could have saved us whoa who would
have thought so you're giving me a lot of crap from my
vision where's your smoke screen huh no no no no no because
i yeah have medkit and i've been using that well i am cute
so that's what i just had a cargo i just had a car go by me
yeah and you're alive you're alive just remember that oh my
god they just see me yeah like this game like you know i'm
just uninstalling it after this probably yeah just one of
those winfield winfield go go and go go to rest go rest
right now winfield i'm gonna
strats count okay just straight for next round um we go to a
high loot area we scram we find a house and do nothing man i
don't even get the loot ship hey i'm scared guys i'm so
scared oh wait winfield wasn't in the helicopter
Oh Do you think it's safe to go outside now?
Go out there and perish like a brave brave warrior.
I'm gonna wait.
I'll wait.
There's no way Oh It'll be fun A juicy juicy redeploy yeah
hmm i want you i wonder how my three teammates fucking died
oh my god okay okay guys chill guys chill chill a little bit
chill a little bit because i hear gunshots okay guys just
chill i'm gonna wait till this ring closes and then see oh
wait what why do i see people fighting in
hacking no do you see that on the map yeah oh someone's uh
redeploying i think yeah um
do you think i can make it all the way here to the i think
you can do anything oh why is there so big he airstrikes
around me why is the world world so dangerous oh my god it's
okay i'm in the garage no one ever checks the garage i'm in
the no one ever checks the garage ah always rat thing mr
lowkey i don't know how you guys died shit this fucking
these fuckers rolled up in a tank and decided to just yeah
i'm saying we could have all we could have all been in the
garage but no matter why you guys were running around we
could all died together come on we could have all been yeah
and i'm alive i write my fucking story oh my god there's a
dud through our what is wrong with this neighborhood there
was like four things in this neighborhood this is why the
rent's so cheap jokey welcome honestly i would do that too
if i was in america i'll just i'll just buy a glove to keep
my rent cheap that's what i'm saying that's what i said last
week keep keep the crime rate Just like I wake up on a
Sunday morning.
Oh, it's a nice day.
I whip up my glob.
And then I just start going back, back, back.
Fucking in there.
You got to do it the way that, uh...
Oh my God.
Okay.
Guys.
I don't think I'll be able to redeploy any of us, guys.
It's getting a little scary out here.
No, there's so many.
There's a helicopter right there.
There's another.
Re-deploy right there.
There is.
Alright, there is one.
Okay, I have to cross the city of hell to get to that
redeploy.
And then, oh, there's, oh, that redeploy.
Never mind.
That report is God.
That's God.
Oh, and then there's also.
Oh, my God.
The zone is still so big.
If you win this one, I'll give you 10 bucks.
Oh, my God.
There's people behind me.
Oh, my house is...
Oh, my poor house.
My poor house.
Oh, no.
This neighborhood is leaving me.
Oh, and then someone used the other redeploy at the top.
So there's a team to the right.
And then there's someone in the car on my right side.
And then there's a team to our left just chilling there.
And...
Oh, and I hear guns shots to my left right now okay guys i
don't know guys you might need to leave soon okay but when
is soon oh i hear people outside my door oh and then there's
another artillery strike okay i can wait a little over a
little bit wow oh there is literally a team right in front
of me I don't know if you guys saw the flashes.
The flashes on my map.
Do you see that?
They're like having a little rave party in front of me.
You see the cute trees.
There's a little rave party.
And then there's a team to my roll.
Look at that.
They're having a party in those trees right now.
Having a gun.
The fire approaches.
And then there's like a team that's on the car as well.
Where the fuck is going on?
And then there's an artillery strike in front of me.
How many fucking...
Oh my god.
I have to leave now too.
Run, Doki!
Oh my, oh my god.
I'm going to be in the fire a little bit.
Take your knife out.
Okay.
Oh my god.
At least Deep has Poopsie died.
That's good.
Oh my.
Mr. Poops.
there mr poopsie mr poopsie okay i can still hug the ring i
can still hug the ring a little bit there's a uav above so
it probably sees you
nice kill mr poopsie again it is mr poopsie i'm sorry buddy
top 11.
Oh, squad wire.
Nice.
I'm so fucking scared.
Alright, no armor now.
No armor.
You just got to get the last three, last three.
That's all you got to do.
No armor.
Somebody.
There's a team to my right.
i know what that means i go to my left oh there's a team to
my left right that's hugging the wall just like me are you
no no you no no i was surrounded i was like you surrounded
what i do that's 10 plays 10 plays top 10.
saying winfield left oh winfield left obviously no winfield
okay but winfield i will be a generous humble guy and you
will not be banned on my channel just for today thanks
you're playing winfield just for today
i've decided to take pity on you yeah i decided to pity you
i'm so generous don't worry guys four hours in and we were
yeah we got second guys that was our first hour but we got
second you don't have to point that out i'm already getting
sleepy yo i'm getting no no but it's morning for you yeah
it's morning how can you be tired axel oh no i only slept
for like three hours come on bro come on axel come on don't
be this is this ain't it this ain't it why are you so weak
bro while you i don't you know not high paying a this ain't
like apex bro i can't find i get instant milk wait can you
pick service oh i could probably have him host oh yeah you
should be He's gonna be so miserable.
Nah, don't just keep it.
What do you mean?
Are you a pussy?
Well, I'm just too tired already Winfield's back.
Wait, how did he come back?
I thought I don't know Wait, wasn't in my lobby wait, what?
Oh my god.
You gotta lock in bro.
You gotta lock in.
I've been seeing your performance reports And um, they've
been slacking lately, you know, like you got do you want to
provide for your family when field because it doesn't not
look like you care about your family you know everyone's
worried about providing for a family just get rid of your
family then you don't have to provide for anyone right yeah
just make sure yeah i am that's why i'm telling you if you
don't want to be if you don't want to be the family guy just
you know just cut all pies hey but family they They buy you
Pikachu stuff.
Wait, I'm going to check Winfield's stats.
I'm having trouble believing he's won a game now.
I need it.
No, that's right.
I'm looking at your shit now.
We're snooping now.
View profile.
Oh, you're so lucky we got in game.
Oh, wait.
There you go.
All right.
Winfield.
Where is your wins, Winfield?
Huh?
He put it on the field.
Where is it?
I don't see winds in here.
We're auditing wind field right now.
Let's do this.
Isa.
You know, Hollow doesn't let us do sleep streams, but maybe
now the axles on Twitch he can do a sleep stream.
That's true.
Oh.
Why can't we do sleep stream?
What's so fucking bad about it?
Wait, how do you not know about it?
Because we have to do like high quality content or
something.
That's what they said.
Looks at my past like three user content.
High quality content?
That's silly.
I'm getting punched.
We need to punch.
What the?
What?
You got fully people.
What was I looking at?
i'm not getting fucking i'm telling you this game is ass bro
bro i should not have looked back i should not have looked
back at you i should have just left i should have just left
it's for all those times that you said i i'm safe i'll turn
safe no no with me all those times i said it one time now
that's a lie all those times twice no one time three no one
time one time today no no no no arguing it's gonna keep
going no no oh yep go you're gonna keep lying then oh so
that proves that you're lying lie stay alive i'm alive
that's actually a zombie boy oh wow Woohoo!
Hooy!
I need Luna.
This shit, this is all us.
Loot loot.
Oh, will I find loot?
Let's find out.
I don't know where like...
I don't know where the fucking loot box is spawned.
Oh, there it is, never mind.
I found it.
A pistol.
I air defense launch.
Thermobary grenade launcher.
I'm scared.
Spooky scary skeletons.
Send shivers down.
It's past Halloween.
Oh.
So?
Why are you doing this to me?
What is Winfield looking at?
Pick up supplies.
Oh, what's this?
What did I pick up?
Ah.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, what the hell?
Are you okay?
No, no, no.
Oh yeah, we fire.
Spooky, scary, skeleton.
Nice.
Hello guys.
I am here.
It's a sack whack.
I am here to party.
Do you want your sack to be whacked?
Come get your sack whack through the drive-through.
Oh, I see the hole.
I see a hole flying.
Where?
Okay.
Where is the hole?
Where is he living?
You said enemy man.
Wait, there's loot box here.
Let's go.
I'm waiting for the supposed ho that we are going to
encounter.
But I feel like I am.
Don't call.
Where is this ho?
Well, the other team was in this building.
Yeah, but are they still here?
Or did they leave?
Wait, they are still here.
They were.
Oh, what?
Windfield.
Oh.
someone just uh parachuted above up on the roof north yeah
right over here wait windfield has people near him too ah
right outside oh oh they're oh they're striking oh wait no
that's That's our desire.
Okay.
They're in front of us.
I feel like I hear these people.
We're sort of like outside of it though.
I think he's right above me.
Axel be careful.
They were right over there.
I'm right above you right now.
Wasn't there like a ping here?
Yeah, I saw like shots here.
I heard people.
I mean, they threw an artillery strikes at us.
Oh, right below me.
Right below.
First floor.
Grand floor.
Very first floor.
Nice.
I broke my legs, but that's fine.
Wow.
Why are you smoking them?
Whoa, what the?
I even see this guy.
King bag your fucking ass.
Squad wave.
Get fucked right there.
Woohoo.
Get reproduced.
Yeah.
I love you.
Shit.
That damn game.
Oh my god.
still have more artillery strikes that's crazy i felt like
they were through like 20 of those at us
noisoo okay what's the plan we are i mean we're in the
middle we just want to i feel i don't know we want to chill
here because i feel like everyone's gonna here well i have a
send an airstrike if you really want no no no this is my i
found the perfect place to chill i found my spot guys let's
all crouch around here guys this is our spot this is our
spot right here this one marks thank you guys come over here
where's this is our spot this is our spot we all are we in
the dead no no this is totally no this is dead center i
believe i believe our circle is good we all pro right here
guys we all prone right here and then and then there's no
way no way people will smoke no no no no it's not late it's
do you wanna do you wanna stream for 12 hours wait that's
not you where's Altair where is I'm journey oh I will leave
halfway through don't worry you guys people outside okay but
we can chill here we can chill here you won't know why why
would they know that we're here there's no way but we're
just gonna chill right here like there's no way who is gonna
find out who is it i think you can see i'm a high no no they
can't no you have to crouch you have to crouch your prone
because because they'll okay here you are gonna be okay yeah
okay that i mean that makes sound makes sound i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna okay here you go no one's gonna and then when
someone walks in we go and then we'll win actually she's
crazy right she's hate people like this hate it's gonna be
fine it's gonna be excellent it's gonna be fine it's gonna
be fine and then i'm also gonna get pizza too and then we're
gonna win and then i i'm gonna get some goddamn pizza
afterwards it wins my pizza here i'm gonna go run out and
die all right here you go here you go we can guys this is it
this is it look look i'm gonna watch the circle start
closing in i'm gonna you know i'm gonna do work messages too
while we're wow
oh yes what is what are these pings yeah let me see my pings
real quick as well two pings are here two pings there okay
oh a survey okay all right here we go all right see look at
that guys see look at that the circle is in our favor well
too bad we should have you should have clutched that game
and won us that game out there now look what's going on now
we have to do this that's on you why didn't you clutch right
now
that's right out there get into court get into fucking court
if you're gonna cry cry and prone in this corner right now
oh you fuck it you fuck go go in this court out there out
there i swear to god people can see us from here go into
this if you're gonna cry go into a corner and cry like okay
this is my corner to cry and go into a corner that's sucking
right i hope someone shoots your ass too
guys and then and then when there's and then when there's oh
wow Quiet, quiet, quiet.
Don't know.
They're here, they're here.
You feel just sprinting?
I think they fall.
No, no, no, no, they didn't, they didn't, they didn't, they
didn't, they didn't.
They did, they would have come down.
They did not.
Shh.
Chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill, chill,
chill, chill.
If anything, we can have a firing squad.
We're gonna slap their sack.
We're gonna whack their sack.
This is it.
This is the moment where we start whacking She's but okay,
okay don't don't do it for dudes whacking in the corner
dudes in the corner Right here favorite I mean technically
we could use the motion sensor right here put up the motion
sensor It's loud.
Are you sure people hear this?
Winfield can people hear this motion sensor?
like chat can people hear the motion sensor yeah well oh oh
take it take it away yes they can take it away take it away
okay okay okay okay i'm pretty sure it needs it needs uh
eyesight of people too oh look at that look at that guys
look at that we are we are still in the zone look at that
see look at that my calculations were correct we survive
another day in war what's this it's an
I also have a artillery strike, too.
If anything...
Oh, look at that.
The enemy is there.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
If we get pushed, I am throwing my...
I hear him here running.
I hear him.
I got scared.
Here we go.
Shh.
Just yelling.
John Forskin died.
Okay, okay, it's okay.
We can do this.
Okay, see, they arrived.
I told you, this is the...
perfect spot guys imagine if someone walks here and we all
just fire squad them imagine that that would be imagine that
how tilted how tilted that you're gonna imagine it has been
happening to me for the past exactly exactly and when we're
gonna do that to them axel we're gonna do that same exact
thing to them and then it will be beautiful and then don't
worry guys we're top 19 don't and then they'll uninstall
guys do it for the uninstall oh we're still for the center
for those all be uh ahead of you okay we are still in this
we're not in the center anymore but we're still in zone
maybe it'll pull downwards you know maybe maybe it's gonna
pull down guys truly it'll pull down right right yeah yeah
yeah yeah i believe i i believe i could send out a drone
again no no no no we don't need it you're We don't need
drones.
Doki, a yearns.
We don't.
Okay, so they did do a- They yearns!
We did-
I hope they shoot you first.
I don't see anybody near us.
Oh no.
Oh.
The zone's coming in.
The zone.
No!
Our beautiful spot!
I think we're fine.
I think we're fine for now.
If we decide to move.
Okay.
We just move at the very end, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's true.
slowly shrinking or we can go to ground the zero like the
house I don't think we'll make will we make it I don't know
we make it do you see that tiny house over there in the
middle oh people on ping people on ping okay that's close by
that is very close it's okay we'll wait for them to walk in
I think we can wait right do we rotate or wait guys let's
have a decision together let's I probably have 30 seconds
until my next turn.
Because we could try and go too late.
They're still there.
Do you think we'll make it if we just book it to this house?
We are fucked, the ladies and the gentile, man.
That house?
You see that house?
You see that?
There's no way we can make it to the house.
You gotta believe, man.
You gotta... Oh, they're artillery strike.
I think this is the time.
We gotta move.
They're artillery strike.
Okay.
All right, we gotta move to the house.
You saw the house I pinged?
Yeah.
Where's the exit?
You can just jump through the window here.
Just a little bit loud.
Oh my god, there's a car right in there.
There's a fucking car.
Fuck it.
We just run.
Okay.
Fuck it.
Oh my god.
It's our smoke.
I'm so scared.
okay if chicken ron could do it we can do it all right do
that to god get to that oh it's the weird slanty yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah right here our new home we finally are able
to afford this new house there's a mortgage though it's just
a little slanted it's fine it's a bathroom it's a bathroom
oh my god oh my god this is perfect yeah taking it oh did i
just fucking lock myself Oh, no.
You see?
Oh, wait, wait.
This is perfect.
We're in the same future.
There's no way.
Okay.
You guys have to crouch your throat so we don't get
detected.
I can just imagine someone is walking past opening.
this at this door seeing three of us just fully geared wait
i hear your gunshots okay i wonder about okay wait wait okay
okay no okay the thing is they have to jump in to get in
here so we can true that's true that's true i am the word
that all of us were in here okay okay oh my god how is this
coming out oh my god we have to go through another
uh-oh oh someone failed the rest yeah they did okay top 10
top 10 as long as no stop windfield stop we're gonna die
windfield windfield no one would have known we were there no
one would have known we were there windfield how could you
do this to us windfield the betrayer okay we're not in zone
guys we're not in zone how what do we do okay new house new
what is going on here there's no more houses i don't think
there's house oh my god i was like winfield winfield which
house do we go for i don't think there's i mean there's a
house right here but like i don't i don't think it's in i
don't think it's in i don't think it's in guys that's the
thing and the one above that do we go into that house there
is uh do you think we'll make it though do you think we'll
make it i don't know we're on low grounds we're gonna have
to walk up regardless i feel like we have to walk up now oh
there's a tank behind us guys i think we should try i think
we should try i think we should go there's a tank right
behind us okay oh there's a tank yeah yeah are we going yeah
we wait until the fire circle yeah
Don't go, don't go Dude Don't do don't do Nice
Nice Just keep running Dead Keep going I'm stuck Oh my gosh
Maybe just right here Right here BTS I'm actually stuck Look
you know I'm stuck now OK I'm fine I'm fine Just keep going
Keep going Keep going Who cares about me I care about you
There's people in the house Okay, yeah, on the right side
Not the left one, the right one Okay, then we'll go this
one, this one Okay, this one maybe Okay, I see, just hug the
wall, we'll go slowly creep in I have an artillery strike,
we could destroy the house I have artillery too I'm gonna
use it You're gonna use it, okay, I'll use it after I got
shot Okay, this is my last Okay This is my last resort
People in front of us close by.
Yeah I'll use it after you.
Yeah, I downed over here.
Nice nice nice nice He's in the smoke.
I can really strike this.
Oh, I got another one.
Here we go.
Nice.
Another two.
Okay.
They are tilling us.
We are go.
On us on us on us run.
We gotta go.
We gotta go
We shot my right to my right to my right.
Oh, no.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep Let's try to get over to
Winfield and Axel.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm heading over
i smoke us thank you i can't jump i don't have armor anymore
me too oh my god we're prone here oh my god guys there's two
armors right there that's your yeah yeah yeah she's just
she's we're in a good place we're in a good place yeah yeah
we're in such a good place i was smoking i got um like a
what do you call it like i can make terrain if i need Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
You have the little ramp thing.
Oh my God.
There's people in...
Yeah, there's people also.
There's a drone in front of us.
Sneaking up.
Right side.
I don't see him.
We gotta go though.
We got...
Right over the hill.
East.
Why below me?
Nice.
Last squad is over here.
Over here.
One ping.
No, there's three squads.
There's three squads.
Oh, three squads?
Okay.
There's still three squads.
There's three squads, guys.
Squad, uh...
Zone or sound?
They're up there.
I'm on the hill, up on the hill.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god, okay.
Take cover, take cover.
Yeah.
Rotate from the right, maybe.
This guy right here.
There's a guy where I pinged on.
All right.
Okay.
I'm going to try clear right side to see you.
I'm coming with you.
Give me a shot.
I think this side is pretty safe.
This hill is pretty good.
I can't remember.
And I still have airstrike, so...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't have mine anymore.
I'll try to play safe.
Okay three squads, three squads left.
I'll be careful.
Just camping.
Yeah, yeah, I'm looking behind us.
I'm looking behind us to see if there's any rats behind us.
Oh my God.
How many people there?
Now, guy.
Okay, I see him.
Okay, I think they are over there on that side.
Nice, nice.
Nice.
Hurry, shut up.
Two squads.
Okay, two squads.
Two squads left.
You can air strike that side maybe.
I think you can air strike that.
side they're down here they're down here okay oh you got
someone I'm looking
behind us just there's no any rats nice nice nice nice nice
nice one down right nice one down sorry oh no Oh, no, sorry.
I got one, I got one.
No!
Oh, no!
He's so close!
Third place!
Oh, my God!
Dude, they're so tanky.
I just can't build them.
Oh, I knocked one, too.
No!
Oh, we should have airstrike the right side.
Oh, my God.
See, my strapped worked, guys.
My strapped was the key.
My strapped.
Oh, my, we should have airstrike the right side.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we got sandwich hard.
They, they...
Oh, we have to watch them win too!
Jesus.
Oh my gosh!
How about we just take a small short break, go to the
restroom, get some drinks?
I mean, technically we went away.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You a quitter?
Are you a fucking...
Or we can just...
I'm just gonna go drink.
We can just continue another...
No, no, no, no, this is...
No, no, no.
Bro, okay, we got the strat, though.
We got the strat, Axel.
Yeah, yeah.
We have the strat now.
Like, we had such good rotations, guys.
Like, that's what we mean.
Axel, didn't you feel a little bit of the excitement of
V-Scycure back then?
You know?
Yeah, did you not feel the rotations?
Like, oh my God, we were rotating left and right.
I don't know about that one, bro.
I don't know.
No, no, we were rotating left and right, bro.
we got this oh boss like we got like our bathroom strat or
our base we should go to that same corner again we should
you're laughing while drinking water yeah i can hear that
it's kind of hard bro this game she's driving guys all i'm
saying is that we almost made We almost got it there.
We were so finished, yeah.
Yeah, to be honest.
That was, look at that.
We were fracking out in everything.
It's just that, unfortunately, we got sandwiched there.
We got sandwiched really hard.
I think like when we airstrikes, we should airstrike right
side and ran at them in the right side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we should do that.
But we, when we first saw them, we saw them on the left.
After we airstrike them, they moved to the right side.
Was that the same team though?
I think it was it was because the one knock was trying to
move to the right as well.
Oh, because I was like, I thought that was a I thought that
was a new team because like we were third So I thought the
other team was to our left and then out the no, I think the
last guy was like a rat somewhere God damn it was us against
another rat Oh, yeah, it's okay.
There's two people behind us got almost killed us what the
heck how they get behind us They were two behind us
I think oh I didn't realize that I didn't realize that I
just turned around and there's this guy just running from
the fire I'm like what oh you got cows crazy wait is my
pizza here pizza pizza pizza time margarita pizza pizza time
pizza time pizza my favorite something all right all right
here we go pizza time i'm so excited for my pizza pizza and
gaming we still didn't beat our second place yeah we still
didn't beat it the only way to beat it is to get first place
okay we're so okay okay okay we have the strat now though we
have the strat just rat we are rats we are rats we have to
rat to win all right that we do the same thing you know what
what do we land we should go back to the defense the defense
matrix area and then and then we find the corner we find
that corner yeah yeah the corner i'm gonna run in try and
find that corner that's much don't remember where it was no
guns no abilities run to the corner don't remember where
that corner is but that was a good ass corner corner right
there corner right there on red paint okay okay that's all i
need to know i'm ready i will take the leftover food i don't
care i broke my legs
okay got gun at least are you kidding me giving me two
shotguns someone just does someone just uh parachute whoa
well we're gonna find out soon yee-haw i found the corner
you found the corner okay i know where i'll tear Do you have
a gun though?
I'll tell you.
I've got two guns.
Oh, you gotta be fucking kidding me.
What a shit game, bro.
Oh, no.
Absolutely on my way.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
He was also camping.
Oh, yeah.
It's okay.
I believe.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I'll believe in you.
I can't even lose with this ping to the right.
I believe.
Whoa, out there.
Whoa.
oh that wasn't a headshot no way oh okay oh it's okay no way
we know where the corner is now the corner calls to us i got
house squatted so hard for that guy was that guy rad
outratted me it's crazy wait where are we no one can outrat
doki where are we now oh my god there's there's people over
there nothing okay i am going having the time of my life
grab a gun i never felt this way before
great game give me a shotgun i got the same gun three times
in the road fucking i'm just running out i'm a building on
my building that one okay i'm coming over What a fuck did he
die?
Bottom, bottom, bottom.
Across the street behind us.
Yeah.
Oh, they artillery strike.
They actually strike.
Nice.
Bro, give me a fucking gun, bro.
Jesus.
I've got a shotgun with these people's names on it.
Oh my god, maybe there's a gun here.
Maybe they put a gun in the security bomb.
Loki, primary crate.
Okay.
Oh, you're far.
No, I'm far.
I'm far, far, far.
I'm hoping that, you know, they'll happen to drop one tiny
gun.
You'll leave a tiny gun for me.
Oh, nope, no gun.
It's okay.
Just...
Oh, they did.
Loki burned a galaxy far, far away.
They left a gun.
Thank God.
I got a gun, guys.
Oh, oh, they read the play.
They read the play.
Okay.
I got cross right behind you.
I'm dead.
Hello Wait, where are you fucking prone please?
Oh, we see it Wait, they're fighting yeah, yeah, yeah Oh
shit, okay, let's get him But we're oh, I see him.
He's over there.
I do also have a shotgun Jesus one down guys
Oh, hey Winfield.
Oh, it's just so good miserable to control oh no last two
last two i'm dead you got this whoa where did he go oh
that's where he went oh nice spot nice spot nice yeah i
think you're clipping through but whoa was I clipping
through was I clipping through I think your arm was clipping
through no all right we got a kick doky now it's her turn I
was the one that died first though I was the one that died
first you guys can't blame that on me guys oh my god there
was still another squad there there was jesus why were they
all here crazy wow guys so painful when you try to loot and
it takes forever dude holy shit i got like a jerking action
where like my character just beating the shit out back again
first we'll smack it then we'll jerk it no it's actually
crazy wait what axel's gonna wait do you like take turns
like Like, like, Axel, who's the, who's the swacking?
Who's the other one?
I'm the whacker.
He's the.
Yeah.
Oh, Axel, are you the other guy?
What the fuck are you guys talking about, yo?
That's a yes.
Okay, Winfield was that.
The Winfield's like, he gave him a sniper and we win this.
Okay.
All right.
We give him a sniper and we win this.
I feel that.
win here i'm gonna assume that he's jorking it yeah also
what else did he say he said something else oh wait the dude
you gotta blank someplace else not this game what is what
does that mean what does that mean what is he trying to say
i don't even understand what he's trying to say They
couldn't like put some kind of realism in this by saying
survive the collapsing wall of wildfire.
It's just a collapsing wall of death.
All right.
Come on, realism.
Where's my wildfires?
Where's my bushfires?
What's your bushfires?
There were so many bushfires here.
What are you talking about?
Well, Axel didn't show me any.
What are you guys talking about?
Bushfires.
bushfires bushfires axel now that now that you're in japan i
can never go to australia now wow well that was my one
excuse you saved yourself to garner somewhere no not much
really bro there's got to be so much to do in australia like
like like kangaroo boxing emu boxing australia right now is
just like the world but like in australia it's just a bunch
of different people from different countries living there
and it's just very diversified right now so you get
Australia you get to enjoy a lot of different colleges from
different places yeah you don't really get to enjoy
Australia Australia itself honestly I feel like it's very
like I don't know unless you go to like somewhere really
specific like where I see that's a good question I don't
even know maybe Gold Coast Gold Coast seems pretty good Gold
Coast yeah Gold Coast is all right it's not bad all right
where do we go are we trying again all right oh wait i think
that's the center this time i think it's the center this
time guys it'll work guys i trust me it'll work i believe i
oh my god i thought i was gonna fucking hit my head other
people on the uh left side all right i'm going to the right
Got a shotgun.
I'm gonna try and find a gun.
One little gun.
That's all I asked for.
Hello.
One gun please.
One gun.
That's a grenade.
Yay!
Oh, finally a good shot.
Nice.
I got a gun.
Oh, he's dead.
Hey, you got D-Willy.
In McChoke that hole.
D-Willy.
Oh, do I hear someone?
You do?
I use UAV.
I don't hear anybody.
Oh, there is someone above us.
Are you kidding me?
My gun did...
They're above there.
I see them.
They're on the second floor.
Or the third floor.
They're right here in that room.
Great.
One right there.
I'm going up.
On ping.
Gun up as well.
I think they ran, they ran across.
They ran across.
But I'm going down.
They shot through you.
They shot through you to kill me.
I just can't win.
Like, it's just impossible.
I'm here.
Thank you.
I might need help.
Cover.
I might need cover.
Okay.
Maybe I should like...
Covering, covering, covering.
Okay.
They're going to redeploy to us.
I'm pretty sure.
Oh, I was behind the wall.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, my God.
Oh, they killed you!
You're my gun.
No!
I was actually...
Behind the wall, you shouldn't scare me.
Hey, what's your...
Oh!
There's another guy!
There's another guy right in here.
There's another...
No!
Okay, that's karma.
That's actual karma for what I did.
Where's this last person?
That's actual karma.
You guys are coming back in, right?
Yeah, yeah, we're going to redeploy.
I think since we...
They might redeploy back in here.
though let them come back oh no jack's gonna get his gun
back i'll meet you guys in the corner all right beautiful
all right right here hello i'm doing some better loot though
hello i'm coming in through the roof hello hello i'm gonna
grab my gun back all right and i'm ready for the corner guys
No!
Yeah, I'm done.
I'm out tabbing.
Fuck this.
Axel!
No!
Axel, we'll bring you back, buddy!
I'm gonna go straight for the redeploy.
I'm gonna bring you back.
I'm done.
No, no, no.
I'm going over to the redeploy right now.
You ain't quitting.
You ain't quitting on me, buddy.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, Winfield.
get out of here though first off let me find out okay i'm
going to the redeploy right now
i'm heading over right above me man all this to get a new pc
just to get fucking ping no solo just okay let's hope that
they don't come over this is a little risky you think they
know kind of fracking there though you think they know no
way they know no way you think they know though they know
they know they definitely know no we're fine wait you don't
oh you have to do your second chance I feel like they should
just use that you know oh my god they know they actually
came over are you fucking kidding me No!
Okay, you guys gotta redeploy, though.
Do another redeploy.
On my way.
You guys split up.
You guys went to three different redeploys.
One of us has to make it.
One of us will bring you back.
It may not be me because I'm looting, but...
It's fine.
Someone...
Right.
It is...
who okay i will fly over to what do i fly over to i'm going
back in i'm going back to a defense nexus
nice kill you sucker that's right oh oh oh they got the res
uh shit the next closest res.
I'm going to go to the other redeploy.
I'm going to the other redeploy right now.
Oh, everything's been drained.
I'm at the next redeploy.
Okay, I'll meet up with you then.
You don't know.
They don't know.
I'm at the next one.
Redeploy them.
They don't know.
I'm in...
that little the little sneaky little tunnel you were in
earlier yeah yeah yeah no more axel i got you yeah axel oh
yeah i got you axel we coming back bro they don't know they
didn't see me parachute guys i have to look both ways but
it's okay good glad you have good safety okay we're not in
the center so that's what i'm worried about i mean we could
go to the trailers maybe people next me i gotta be quiet
coming down all right i'm gonna find us the next spot i
think i think this i'm gonna do it i'm gonna go to that spot
that's the spot i think i think that is i think that's the
spot I think that's our next rat spot.
I believe I'm heading over it right now.
On two?
Because we're not in the center.
Three.
Oh, no.
There's a team right there, Rita.
We could do a mission.
Oh, we could.
I'm down to do a mission.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's do wreckage.
What's wreckage?
Oh, let's fart.
Explosive.
I'm getting tossed.
Targeted, fuck.
Oh, shit, where?
I think I'm like a mission.
Oh, you got a mission.
Oh, they took a mission to find you.
Yep, and my fucking guy is...
He doesn't do cardio, so...
Oh, I'm heading over.
Oh, it's because we're defending the bomb, and they're
trying to...
Oh!
Okay, I'm heading over.
Oh, my God, we're literally playing CS right now.
Enjoy the machine.
I'll be in the corner.
Okay, I'm heading over.
What the fuck?
I can't...
Okay.
Oh my god, it's just like Rainbow 16.
Don't worry, I got this corner.
There we go.
I got this, guys.
do we die we get hit by that i think so no we're five nice
we got it we got an airdrop too wait there is a team coming
in is that the red thing airdrop rewards coming in all right
let's go grab that outside let's go all right
excellent it's okay i would like it there's a car over there
i like this gun please i don't know if you go get a custom
weapon over there if you want to oh we want to move in the
zone anyways i feel like every time we go for those random
ones that just drop there's always like three people looking
at it yeah we could do another mission and then get a free
one i got i have heard shots next to me okay i need to look
for alma i need to there's a car right behind us here oh my
legs oh i picked the worst gun oh i didn't know what gun to
pick i i thought i didn't know that's me shooting my gun so
i was like i was like is it really the worst gun don't say
that guys it's the best gun it's in it's in her hands it's a
safe what's that i think i just got rogan oh people behind
us behind us ping ping ping they're shooting from up the
hill fuck you guys ping i don't know oh no i got tanked oh
you got tanked okay we got oh god okay i'm good i'm leaving
i'm leaving oh i'm gonna shot it now all right i'm gonna i'm
running i'm running i'm running to the closest redeploy i
see it i see it it's to my left i'm heading there right now
thank you all i'm seeing oh you're Oh, you're fine.
Okay, never mind.
Somehow.
Grab this.
Yeah, armor tank heading your way.
No, no crap.
Oh my god, there's nothing here.
That hurt something behind me.
Where do we go?
Guys, can you cover me?
I'm running towards you guys.
That way is where the tank is.
Oh, that way.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'll go left then.
I'm trying to look for like a RPG or something.
I can destroy a tank, but...
I don't think that's possible.
Guys, there's nothing.
Wait, there's a custom weapon here.
Yeah, but I don't think we can get it.
I think the tank is going to look from above.
No, it's fine.
I'm literally at it right now.
All right, guys, which one's better?
Guys, tell me what weapon to get, and then I'll get it right
now.
Guys, guys, come on.
Tell me which one.
Right now, chat.
At chat.
I can't stand still.
I'm still getting sniked at?
Which one's the SMG?
I can't tell!
I'm so MG.
Which one is it?
M433?
The one on the very left, I think.
Which one?
I need some shields.
One, two, three, four!
SGX?
I declared it on more!
Okay, SGX.
Yeah, give me shield.
He'll take this.
Thank you, Axel.
See, that's an investment right there.
Alright.
We're good.
See you guys?
I didn't panic at all.
Woohoo!
all right I think we should go to here people are here yeah
this world's a scary place I'm heading straight to this here
right here okay I'm heading here that looks like the center
this is our next home I missed my corner it's her next home
i missed her bathroom oh the bathroom is so late until it
was yeah the bad so someone decided to break our only cover
actually i feel like maybe you do that axel come on yeah
that's bro that's actually yeah my yeah someone on the roof
yeah okay there's someone on the roof then i feel like maybe
we should just stay in this house then rotate slowly in
We're gonna stay here.
Okay.
Yeah, and then just like follow the zone.
Although this is our new home now.
You feel did nothing wrong.
Okay, but what if like...
You think people will know I'm here?
You think...
Hey, bro, do you think this...
Guys, this is so...
Can you see me for me?
Your legs clipping out.
Yeah, yeah, oh, I'm kind of like this.
Oh, that's perfect.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No one will know.
No one will know that I'm in here.
Well, look at the steam.
It's a hot tub.
Yeah, it's a hot tub.
Ooh, it's a steam.
Yeah, it's your hot tub stream.
Oh, I closed the door.
Oh.
Okay, someone, someone fucking shot the window.
So they know we're here.
Oh, there's a team in that house.
anyway.
Or, oh, there's a, there's someone resting right behind us.
You guys want to just follow this.
Oh, they're going to kill him?
We could.
Oh, they're, oh, their tank is there.
Okay, we got to be quiet.
We got to be very quiet.
There's a tank.
No tank.
We got to wait until the tank, like, leave us.
I'm going to, I'm just going to wait until the tank, like,
passes us.
I don't trust it.
I am a snail.
are calm people oh oh someone oh wait what the fuck wait
someone sent in an artillery strike on the tank oh someone
said two artillery whoa oh my goodness um goodbye tank i
guess we go left or right all the way far just want to go
left or right i know there's people to our right what uh
there's people on our left like there's like three people on
our left oh 175 i think we go right we go from the right
okay we can't really go right now there's people on our left
it's just the heads up there's people shooting all the way
oh yeah yeah yeah okay that's fine i oh what happened i did
smoke i smoked i smoked i'm smoked i took it over here i
smoked it Oh, no.
Squad's dead.
Sorry, Axel.
Nah, nah.
I just can't win in a fight.
It's just...
Bang.
Alright, we...
Can we redeploy?
Do we have a close redeploy?
It's like over here.
But I don't know.
Okay, we have to figure out right or left, though.
Um...
I would...
Because there is a team right in that house.
there's a team on the right side i saw them running from the
zone so maybe it's them i'm gonna follow windfield i'm gonna
follow windfield he ran already i need more shields there is
a car to our left
just ripe for the taking oh wait wait wind feels smart wind
feels smart just are we roof gang yeah we're roof gang roof
gang amadea's moot site that's what they call
oh how do you get up there
behind us the safe we're good oh my god okay where where
where where where where right here oh nice positions oh shit
nice out there above us above us above us do a little bit
right above us okay i'm getting inside
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
Did they have any shields?
Very nice.
Oh.
I don't know.
Oh, there's that's extra shields.
Thank you.
We gotta go in.
Yeah.
Oh, there's me.
Thank you.
Um, someone's all the way out here on one ping.
There's three people north at the house.
On north on the house.
Okay.
So we.
And there's one person west on ping.
We gotta go.
I guess we can go.
Is there anyone here on three?
Uh, I saw one person over there.
Alright, I guess we slowly rotate.
Our life.
Okay.
Oh my god, look at the end zone.
End zone is like the open field.
Okay.
Um, okay.
Let's try to get some trees for cover then.
I think all we could do is just we just have to rotate last,
I guess.
Yep.
Five squads left.
Five squads.
Four squads.
They killed two rats.
Nice.
They killed three more squads.
Three more squads.
I don't have any artillery, by the way, so two more squads.
Two more squads.
Hi, battle.
He's got to use the artillery strike.
Do we have artillery?
I don't think any of us have artillery, yeah.
We gotta go something.
Remember, there's still people above us, so...
Really?
We swat right.
No, we swat right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry, I'm sorry.
You're right.
It should be fine.
Unless there's another person right behind us.
Oh, the fire.
Oh!
Artillery!
How did they know?
That's a...
Oh my god.
I took a big hit.
I don't know how they knew we were there, but...
Oh!
They just crashed on it.
Oh my god.
I don't know if I'm gonna get I think I feel like I'm gonna
get strike there
good luck I know I don't know if I Winfield's playing it
very safely
yeah I also have smokes that was so unlucky one far north
far northwest that's a single I think okay there's um full
squad to our there's actually a full squad to our left um
yep i could feel it super far northwest still
oh there they oh my god wait that's not a single one of them
there's still three teams three teams
nice oh my god i'm in a bush
We're playing it so safe.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, it's in front of me.
He's in front of me.
He's literally right in front of me.
We got a danger point.
Oh wait, they downed each other.
There's two down.
Nice!
Cracked.
Cracked west.
Yeah, yeah.
What the fuck?
I got- I got kicked out of the game.
No, no!
What the fuck is- Bro, what the fuck is this game, man?
This game is absolute shit.
No.
Oh, shit.
What did I get hit?
I think that's on.
No, no, no.
That was no.
Oh, he was troning too.
No.
What's the strat there?
No, he got the rock.
We couldn't do anything because they were right there.
Oh, my God.
It was so close.
there's literally two teams just they had so much shield I
was nothing we just had to we just had to like I had no
place at it bro we like look for us one second yeah you're
back that was a three man I think you just queue up while we
were waiting oh i guess not bro they're still fighting
they're still fighting yeah
oh my god why am i flashlight on how do you turn off
flashlight
oh it's t oh okay guys do you guys know if you turn off
flashlight is to turn off flashlight it's t i'm gonna grab
my pizza i'll be right back guys got it for it
Max will entertain our chats.
Oh, I'm just in fire range right now.
How are you guys all doing, ladies and gentlemen?
This game is ass.
It's not like Apex.
You can't just fight them even with ping.
You are, you are fucked.
You are just absolutely fucked if you have shit ping.
Oh, what's a good fucking...
So what's this?
Carbine?
What's a better gun?
Assault?
This?
Firing range, okay?
Oh, I actually like this gun more.
The M4 is the best gun at the end of the day.
Hey.
Oh, strawberry, you think of the five gifts, yo.
Thank you very much.
But if I were to...
If I were to use this gun in hyping, I don't think it would
do much, to be honest.
How do I...
Hello, I'm back.
Thank you for waiting.
Welcome back.
I got myself some nice iced tea peach.
Ice tea peach?
I love peach tea.
Uh-huh.
It's strange.
I don't like I don't like eating peaches, but because I
think I'm slightly allergic Peaches I love the flavor of it
peach rings peach tea peach peaches Yeah
See if I can get a fourth How do we I
What are you up to?
I'm just in the firing range.
Why is it when I look this way?
And then when I...
What the fuck is...
This game is broken, bro.
I look away.
I look away when I'm not looking.
Bro, they're playing fucking Squid games with me, these
fucking...
Oh my.
This is actually a Squid game.
Dude, they are actually Squid Gaming.
Fucking piece of shit these guys.
Can I change my look?
Wonder.
Getting pranked out here.
Gosh, I look so cool.
Axel, how's the time in Japan with the boys right now?
Oh, it's okay.
Yeah, I met them like once or twice.
It's chilling, yeah.
Nice.
how much money have you guys spent going out not much
actually i remember spending so much money in japan yeah i
try to save as much as i can and now you guys don't have
that free housing right now right it's just no no you're
still looking um well i got my own place now i mean we only
had that yeah we only had that place um when we went for a
3d so other than that um yeah it's pretty expensive if you
try to get it yourself other than occasions i remember last
time i came i decided to go to the same place but i had to
um paint myself it's pretty fucking expensive hello i got my
pizza and i forgot to bring my sriracha so no sriracha
you'll get your sriracha no you're talking about being
italian for winners No!
That's fucking right!
No wonder why I don't like sriracha.
Sriracha's for winners!
We're gonna be winners.
You're literally talking about you wanting Italian pizza.
Okay.
So what's the difference between like Italian pizza and
regular pizza?
Is it like the way they make it?
Do they make it in stone ovens?
Do they flop it a little bit?
What do they do?
It's the pressed spinner.
Oh, like New York style pizza.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Italian pizza doesn't default to tomato sauce.
What do they use?
Like mayonnaise?
Mayonnaise?
What?
Sorry, I was fucking typing a word message.
What the fuck?
I had to like do a double take on that.
huh well they said that italian pizza doesn't default to
tomato sauce so like it's got mayonnaise it's got to be a
ketchup sauce mayonnaise berry jam what peanut butter pizza
that's good peanut butter pizza i hate peanut butter i'm
sorry there's just something about the nuttyness that's too
much i got stuff crushed for for my pizza hut i haven't had
that in so long soft crust is so good there.
If you had to have one, only one ingredient on the top of
the pizza, what would you have?
Only one.
For me, unironically, Italian sausage.
Really?
For me, it's pepperoni.
Pepperoni?
Like the good ones are the ones that like shrivel up too
much and are like plastic.
I mean you just said the good ones or the one that's bad
like I don't talk to girls very often I mean girls are the
ones that's fucking bad I don't know my mom likes sparkling
water I don't get it I don't know is my thing bog what is
what a poke is my screen of black um we're in game yeah I
think it's bogged oh Oh, no.
Maybe, like, alt tab and tab back in?
No, it's not.
I think it's just...
I think this game's broken.
Oh, no.
I'm in the void.
Maybe it'll fix once you get out of skydiving.
Yeah.
I don't think so.
We're in.
Yeah, no, I don't see anything.
Okay, maybe it'll fix itself when you die.
Nope.
Wait, can you, like, rejoin the VPCs?
wait is there that feature guys chat chat chat chat if you
like all at four can you rejoin us if he can't see chat his
screen's black someone said he has to leave i want to know
if he can rejoin i don't think so not i can't rejoin this is
this game man this fucking game apparently it's a bug or
some shit i like how like um i like how i think completely
dead okay nothing's showing it's all black my thing every
single menu i like how out of everyone that it had to happen
to it had to happen to axel all right yeah always axel had
to happen to him truly life now it's a sign they're telling
me hey don't play this game anymore no no no no no no no
it's a sign that you that we're gonna win this ha it's a
sign for me to stop playing no no no it's a sign that we're
gonna win this guys i believe i believe look they haven't i
believe if you stop believing that then we're gonna be
streaming for eight more hours ah why there's so many flies
just what happened what okay i don't know what the Hit me
there.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what happened to me?
What happened to me?
Come on, grab what you can.
I don't even know what happened.
Guys, Doki died.
No, I'm alive.
I'm alive.
Doki's alive.
Like, I don't even know what was going on.
Oh, uh, uh, north, north, north, north, north.
Someone just stars it, uh, parachuted.
I got him.
Lavender.
That's right.
I'm coming over, lavender.
That's all.
I'm down, but safe.
Down, but safe.
Oh, he's one!
He's actually one in there!
No!
I'm so sad.
It was sad.
Uh oh.
It was ok.
I got my rage.
The axel's gone.
And my pizza.
Om Yong, Yong.
Om nom, nom, nom.
Om nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Ow.
I believe.
Mama bomb.
A wow, bomb.
I got a gun now.
Someone was here.
This is all looted.
Wait.
What?
How do you do that?
What the fuck?
I'm heading over.
Like, do I swim over?
Oh my god, you can swim in this game?
I'm heading over, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm going to be a hero.
That was a dry bite.
Wow.
I'm coming over.
Load out.
Okay, I'm here.
Guys, I'm here.
Hello.
Alright.
I go...
Save me!
I go pick up Altair.
Merci beaucoup.
Don't worry, Altair.
We can do this.
We might be at the five-hour mark, but we can do this.
Hey, we just need one good one.
You know, we can fail as many times as we want.
Yeah.
Just gotta win one time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got the win.
We got it.
I believe, I believe.
We might need to sacrifice a couple along the way.
And that may or may not be Winfield.
I'm going to eat my pizza.
Mowmowm.
Mowm.
They're back.
Guess who's back?
I'm a hero.
Back again.
Guess who's back?
It's a me.
Oh, no.
Oh, where's Winfield?
Oh, Winfield's hiding there.
He's done.
He's like, I did not.
Oh, my.
He's like, I did not sign up for this for this long of a
session.
I think he thought we would have won a game like three hours
ago.
Sorry, Winfield.
We're trying, I swear.
I'm trying, too.
or am i not trying no or am i not trying windfield we needed
to use more than 10 of your power i need you to kill half
the lobby windfield i need you to get me a pizza all right
he has an enemy near him i'm gonna be on the house next to
him helicopter helicopter helicopter he didn't see me the
fuck someone's far from it okay i'm gonna go to one of the
houses i'm gonna do the house next to him wait this is the
parking lot area we need to do something for wind field a
few wins no we don't playing with us is the gift don't you
have a you know don't you want good morals you know to
reward those who did well no no don't you want to enrich
someone else's life by sharing your I rather enrich my own
life okay aren't you capable of love oh shit that's an
artillery strike I'm over at the big building am I like get
away from me to be safer no way this would hit me right
SMGG Custom weapon Alright, I'm heading over to your
building Knock knock Blue LMG Hello I'm gonna go under oh
wait is there?
Oh Okay, I wanted to go in the park.
Oh, oh no no Okay.
I got an idea.
Never mind.
Let's get out of here.
Don't.
Wait, I have an idea.
You see that?
Watch this.
Wait, wait, wait.
Enemy landing near us.
Do you think they know?
Okay.
were you mike irman shot you said anything near us and it
freaked me out okay but did you think they know my legs he
took my legs they're okay go out go out right here go right
here do you think it's noticeable can they see me i can see
your backpack about now no okay wait i got an idea how about
now no okay there you go perfect you go on the other side
you do the same thing but on other side.
There you go.
This is perfect.
Yeah.
There's no way.
Oh, we're not in zone.
You want an LMG, by the way?
Yeah, I'm good.
Aren't you good?
I'm good.
I don't know what gun I'm good.
I don't know.
I still have yet.
We've been playing for five hours.
I still yet to know which gun is good.
Oh, I think SMGs.
Oh, I don't think we're in zone, have a feeling that we
should maybe go someone super far over here maybe we should
go over here to one of those houses windfield go to one of
those houses for us and we'll meet you there on two uh
there's people flying into two so there's probably a fight
going on there okay then we'll go there's people on point
three what about here reposition move now two could make it
over there yeah we can make it wind field we're gonna go
let's go we're gonna go on our mission there's a car we take
that car and then like go to this don't worry i'm this axle
guy win it matty we're gonna do this we're gonna do this for
you axel i'm gonna take the car i'll say trust me on this
what if we get two cars okay let's get two cars
die all right the call tear hasn't seen me drift like this
before all right i'm going in i'm going to scout for that
house sorry beep beep okay wait this is my favorite place
Totally incantuous, humdy.
Wait, I know this place.
Oh.
They're right above me right now.
Um.
This is it, this is it, this is it, this is it.
This is it.
I just made it on one piece.
You guys better win this one.
I believe in you.
you guys there is a team on my there's a team in my house
there is a team in my house okay there is
i'm taking this house
oh it's a gas station
i think i found the perfect place for myself it's okay axel
we're doing this for you axel don't worry don't worry it's
gonna be so cool okay i can't go like five minutes without
axel or else i'll There is a team right above us.
There is a team right above us.
So really I'll go look.
And I'm taking a nap.
That's I'll tear.
I swear to fucking God.
I'm gonna go take a look.
I'll take I don't believe you.
I don't believe you.
I'm gonna go take a look.
I'm stuck in a door.
The Count Pinker and Kobe Bryant meditates before their
games.
Nobody on the roof.
I'm sorry.
roof is clear this is it we're fine we're fine can you let
me in I'm at the door can you let me in it's fine we're in
we are so much what if we're just in the middle of this
ocean
what if you think they'll know I'm gonna do it I think
there's everybody's north there's a lot of people north but
like what will happen if we're just in that middle of that
ocean like like will people look at the water like will
people know oh there is a tank well people know you could
try we can get the boat i don't think we can get that boat i
think it'd be more obvious if we use the boat we have to
leave though we have there's a tank out there okay let's go
let's go okay i think the okay what about that's cute okay
we gotta leave though we gotta leave guys we gotta leave
where do we go where do we go professing love um let's let's
go by the water let's do it let's do the water i feel like
we get sniped though we're in the water i feel like one
person should be in the middle of the water just to test
aetheria and then and then see if we get sniped i'll do it
i'll do it begin with w do it don't worry no no winfield
winfield is fracking we just won't tore windfield i'll do it
i will take one for the team okay we thank you i wonder like
will they know that i start swimming in the water we'll
cheer you on from here okay you got this noticeable isn't
noticeable when i'm in the water uh there's a dude right
close to us hold on but is it noticeable see you from this
angle is it noticeable when i'm swimming in the water i i
don't see you okay okay wait the strap might be it oh i
could kill someone i think they don't no no no no oh my god
no no i am talking where was i shot from wait where the was
i shot from tank tank tank tank no we could have seen that
coming who could have seen that okay guys so
apparently apparently there was a team at the bridge looking
down at the water oh there was oh there was a team
underneath that bridge when i sweat because i was like
thinking oh i'll swim near the bridge area instead of the
middle of the ocean that was the thing i fucked up on i
should have just stayed in the middle okay i'll tear yes you
test out my second do okay the water no no don't don't don't
do it don't do i think we need you and one field alive
but this wind would be nothing without axel even if we win
no no no even if we win he's it's we'll be free he's fine no
we shouldn't do that for the three oh oh they see you
wouldn't feel they They are sniping us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You guys gotta go to...
You gotta follow Winfield.
You gotta follow him.
Following Winfield.
He's got...
He's figuring shit out.
He's cooking right now.
He's cooking.
There is...
There are rats under that bridge.
I repeat.
That is where I died.
Whoa!
I think I see him.
that's how they got me thanks they got me through that can
we climb the bridge no oh wait they fucking flew away they
just that's my body
she's dead she's dead oh they're fighting above oh that's a
tank that's a tank just slowly just sneak behind the tank
Don't make any noise.
Be very quiet.
Wait, check the water.
Are there still rats in that water?
Maybe there's rats in that water.
This feels very dangerous.
You guys got this.
I believe in you.
As I take a nap.
Where is it?
Bridge is safe.
Six squads left.
Is that?
house safe, though.
Jesus, a lot of people.
There's a guy, too.
Oh, my God.
Maybe if I get inside this car.
Oh, don't do it.
There's someone in that house, I think.
Oh, my God.
He's crazy.
He's fucking crazy.
Oh, my God.
He blew up the tank.
He blew it up.
I think we hold this, maybe.
Oh, my God.
He's goddamn crazy.
crazy he blew up the tank just like that just like that what
a goat he's an engineer oh my god he's so smart hiding that
bathroom oh my god yes yes hide that bathroom out there out
there this is it this is it this is it hide that bathroom
you don't need you don't need to fucking yeah yeah yeah yeah
just did it just did it you just did it close the door if
you can can you close the door Yeah, close the door.
Okay, just stay there.
Yeah, yeah, you do and then it's like a firing squad It's
literally a fire squad and you walk through.
Yeah, that's the plan.
That's the plan.
That's it It is it we got the strap we got the fucking strap
Five squads left.
Oh my god.
Um, technically four squads left because here you're
technically four squads left because you're part of the Man,
wouldn't it be funny if I did not fucking swim in the middle
of that ocean?
in the middle of that ocean.
Oh, this hurts my soul.
This is such a cowardly way to fight.
Two bros across the hallway.
Two bros.
Looking at each other because there's nothing else to do.
Yeah, two bros.
Sitting in the hot tub.
Five in the car because they're not gay.
Fuck, I love that.
Two bros sitting in the hot tub.
5p in the park is not gay
We're not in the zen.
Oh, no, no, it's fine.
It's fine.
The zone closes really slow I believe okay, there's no way
people throw grenades to check No, they wouldn't they
wouldn't there's no way there's no way nobody ever throws
grenades in this game Nope Oh Oh.
I'm still here.
I'm safe.
No.
Oh.
There's someone on Winfield.
Okay.
I gotta heal.
No.
Where?
Um.
Just chill a bit.
Just chill.
It's C-Swiss 2.
You got this.
They're really on Winfield right now.
No!
Winfield!
Whoa, whoa.
Altair, nice.
Altair, I think you gotta leave him.
Oh my god, never mind.
I will never leave Winfield.
Never leave him.
I will never leave you!
Oh my god, two bros sitting in the hot tub.
It was very hot.
I see them.
They're across.
Okay, just chill.
Just chill.
Oh, last.
It's the last team.
It's literally the last team.
Bye!
Left!
No!
Again!
It was literally one guy left!
I thought I saw someone in front of me.
Okay, I would say that aim was very unfortunate to watch
too.
I'm glad you didn't have to watch it out here.
I'm glad you didn't have to watch it.
I, I don't, what happened, Winfield?
It was bad.
What, Winfield, what, you were clutching it.
What happened?
What the fuck happened?
Okay, we got to invite Axel back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, the next one might be my last one.
I'm so tired.
No, no, this is it.
This Axel, we clearly got second place.
It was one guy.
The fact that it was one guy.
I'm so sad.
Axel, we got this.
Come on.
I mean, I'll go in one.
I'll go in one.
But after that.
Battle set me a number.
When an account name is changed, should we add battle as a
fourth?
Yeah.
Get battle in.
Spiritually, he is Axel.
Hey, Winfield, you've been great.
Thank you very much for...
Thanks for...
Thanks for carrying us, man.
Thanks.
Take out.
Don't worry, Winfield.
I'm so tired.
Holy fuck.
I'm dying.
Sorry, Axel.
If only I didn't go for the swim.
if only i didn't go for i wanted to test my theory up i was
told that nobody could see me and i believed i believed you
what do you mean you and windfield
nah where's axel i don't know how to join for my Yeah, I
invited you.
Okay.
Good morning, Battle.
Oh, but it's still not in.
I think only you can kick people out there.
I can't kick people out.
Okay.
Because you're the party host.
Oh, wait, wait.
You left.
Okay.
Good morning, Battle.
Well, well.
A sad battle.
Battle, get in here.
Good morning, sir.
I think we're having a bit of difficulty, are we?
Yeah, okay.
How many years have you won?
better like 50 oh yeah i'm gonna look at your profile i'm
gonna look at it i don't actually know oh because it's zero
no oh how do we know you're not lying because i'm a
battlefield gamer oh yeah he never lies all right let's see
your level all right i'll tear him in yeah also to my to my
chat is better okay or is he too loud guys hi hi hi hi my
name's dad oh hi hi hi hi hi he's always like you're still
streaming yes we haven't won a single game yes i know i'm
still streaming i'm really rooting for you here yes if i'm
live right now it means we still haven't won a game okay
guys i understand what if we were just lying to you we're
just we won one maybe yeah yeah you could know yeah what if
we're just holding you guys hostage oh i believe it you're
you're being held hostage now so wait what i'm gonna hang
myself okay morale is high this is what i want this is what
we need we got this no we got this we got better now we got
better yeah it's fine as long as we have your luck we can
either do it or not we got i hope it's do it let's do this
Let's do this.
Oh, yeah, I gotta do a PNG for better.
I just gotta choose a location, you know, the forest or my
own room or like...
Don't worry, you're in...
No, no, no, no.
We're gonna win.
You won't need a location, bro.
Yeah, honestly, you don't.
Like...
Your own room is fine.
You're not in battle with what we're called.
What we're not called.
Where are you called?
Also, what the fuck is your PNG battle?
Like, what?
It's a puppet.
I'm a puppet.
It's a cute puppet.
What the fuck is that?
Wait, he looks just like...
That's right.
We're judging you.
I'm an idol.
Look at this, guys.
Look at this.
I'm just a puppet.
Look at this little guy.
The fuck is my...
She dropped for some reason.
They're scared.
They're scared of us.
Dead the game.
No, no.
They're scared.
of us they're scared of us is axel crashing out what is
going on we've been on axel it's only been six hours yeah
it's only been six hours guys it's five what's axel's
longest stream has he ever done like a 24 hour i wish i
could just strap a bomb on myself and just run at the man oh
my god i'm just looking at i can't help but look at betto's
png i'm sorry guys like hi hi he looks like he's method
acting looks like a fucking maggot no it looks like a little
maggot emerging from the ground yeah yeah like just me
out there in like yeah like a little maggot in the in the
sand mr maggot i was all right we got this oh my god level
68 better what the fuck i like i like battlefield what the
fuck bro have you if honestly like if we didn't know you
went outside recently i would not have believed it well i
mean there you go i mean i'm just real it's a chat i'm a
genuine gamer for once yeah chat it's very surprising but
this man actually touches grass i touch grass as much as i
can it's it's very surprising i know well at least your
level 68 thing is almost as green as the grass that you
touch yeah yeah one more level and it's all over though one
more level and you can retire yeah you will i won't be on
this game again so we gotta we gotta work fast
i got two hours guys i like how you i like how you join the
game also making sure it's not the level before it yeah
it'll be a big moment yeah no the level before it before it
the one under minus one oh true oh god that would have been
bad yeah yeah we can't have that all right better what's the
strat just one with battle here just the first one yeah
here's the bad thing i haven't played in a while oh okay but
what was the strat um well you dropping you i don't have a
strategy i just kill everyone i see okay but what happens
when they try to kill you i kill them first all right all
right okay bet bet what if you kill them second what
happened let's go to neighborhood neighborhood always works
okay i i say lying wait which is the highest okay so you
lied you actually lied i'm just stupid welcome to gavis I
just hit F to try and turn on my flashlight.
I haven't played too much Arc Raiders.
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
Wait, have you played Arc Raiders yet?
More fun.
X, have you played Arc Raiders yet?
Hell, no.
Not yet.
I don't know if you'd like it.
What's stopping you?
I mean, it's an extraction shooter, so it's like...
What's stopping me?
That game expensive, bro.
I gotta save up money first.
And then I'll probably get it.
What if a cheeky cheeky twitch prime sub got you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, what the hell?
What is that?
Right now?
Yeah, he's multi streaming.
Oh, no, he's he's exclusive streaming.
Not even multi.
They get to see me have a crash out on the front page.
Hey, welcome to actual thing.
Yeah.
That's good.
They gotta know more about you.
You ain't hiding.
Depressed VTuber, man.
Wait, is actual playing on 9,000 ping?
Oh, yeah, you figured.
Oh, God.
That's fine.
I have dog shit guns.
So what guns are good?
I like light machine guns.
Okay.
That's I got that.
That's in my hand right now.
Is there people on me?
I think that was...
No, that's us.
That's us, homie.
No, someone dropped like...
that was us someone called in an airdrop here no you're just
being crazy right now you're being did we lose anyone lose
this place already no i told you oh and who did i'm you i
think he wins that he wins that he wins that good job axel
so good let's see you didn't need help actually so good i
knew people up top of the hill careful that's their whole
team like that guy was like just on his own, like a moron.
I don't know.
Yeah, who would do that?
Who would fucking do that?
I would never, you know?
I would never just watch.
We have better standards for strategy like that.
If we do it, it's someone else's fault.
Yeah, exactly.
Like, who the fuck would do something that stupid right now?
As we sprint up there.
Call them, call them, call them, call them.
Rogue agents, rogue agents.
Who would fucking...
Like, we're surrounding them, like, we're actually FBI.
Like we're here like we're actually crazy We're like
actually sliding.
What is wrong with this game?
Bro, I swear.
It is kind of I'm kind of a waggy.
I'm feeling a little kooky.
I mean six hour mark anything can happen a little go get a
little bonkers Yeah I dropped this in a really bad place.
This is my fault.
Thank you.
Drop.
Welcome to team sack wackers Sack wack wackers.
Yeah, welcome to team sack wackers.
No, we're sack wackers.
We're here to whackers sacks okay well you know the stock
whacker there's a lot of slack buncher that's right yeah i'm
the sacks that you are the people i don't know people people
oh i'm coming over i'm by myself he's hurt he's hurt oh no i
just can't win fucking pinged man no no don't worry we got
you we got you are you dead i'm down i'm dead oh no that's
me two down two down two down okay i got another squad wipe
yeah nice nice nice yeah where's your body where's your body
oh yeah i'm coming back i'm coming back we're good yeah but
where's your loot i don't think you want it it's really bad
i dropped i dropped like a paper cold thank you rechucky
cheese tokens oh there's a salt rife i'm actually gonna take
that screen actually which is better wait better which is
better i'll start right for lmg lmg all right lmg tab i
don't think there's for me it's without question axel axel
come here all right take this what uh what do i flashlight i
already got a purple assault right okay all right i'm good
i'm good i'm good kind of but all right sorry i gave you No,
this is very shit the one I have.
Oh, I'm sorry That's right cry out.
How could you fucking do that to Axel?
Like after everything he's been with for you and with you
too.
I should have given him a legendary instead.
How could you do that?
What the fuck is an anti-vehicle drop?
Oh, it's like when it said in a vehicle and then someone who
Someone where oh wait It drops like anti-vehicle equipment
like bazookas or mines or Oh, I want that.
Wait, wait, wait.
I have some shields for you.
You want some?
Give me fucking bazooka, please.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, defense.
Yeah, I beg for it.
Was me saying, yeah, not begging for it?
No, that's not good enough.
Yeah, gravel.
Can I have them, please?
Just a morsel of them.
Just a singular morsel.
Just a small taste of what shields are like.
May I have some oats, brother?
the shoes what kiss the shoes that's right yeah one kiss
okay one kiss for shield hey don't stretch your fucking
lunch here give me those goddamn shields hey why don't you
give me oh shit i'm fucked up i think your guy needs to beg
a little bit oh shit wait wait you know i'm gonna die to
grab shields back from you i'm gonna die i'm playing i
pressed the wrong foot For the sake of the team, I'm giving
them back, but just know that's not because...
Oh, you guys should a lulule game with baby pier?
What are you guys doing?
We're in a war zone!
I'm getting my shoes.
All right, look alive.
No more fooling around.
We got no more fooling around.
We got...
I gotta go to bed in two hours, and if this isn't over in
two hours, I'm gonna be real upset.
Oh, you're gonna go to bed?
You think you're gonna go to bed in two hours.
Wait, what?
It's okay.
to bed no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
you're lying just with your title i just get locked guys
come on get out of that house let's go and we're jumping
around like freaks let's do it wait wait dokey dokey what
dokey what there's a cop there's a cop guy we're so fucking
dying in that come here come here okay myself i gotta freak
out i gotta freak out
the back of the golf crap so getting shot at and we're here
oh my God okay so we're is dropping we want that we want
that okay our shout was to find a house and say in a corner
what so far you guys are doing the camping strat no just
just kill everybody just kill everybody says it doesn't work
like that better no it doesn't work like that no you don't
know who you're talking through doing this for six hours
this was the best part it was the closest we've ever 30 p.m.
for you shouldn't you shouldn't be tired you should be yeah
i woke up i slept at 3 a.m 2 a.m and woke up at 5 a.m okay
oh that's on you i drank a coffee at 7 that's on you i need
this drop i need this i need this i need this i need this i
need this whoa whoa i got you better there's another smoke
too so they'll never know that there's something good work
team good work team good use of of uh why am i lagging where
what servers are we on I don't know.
I don't know where we are at.
I think we're east coast.
Okay, guys, what do we get?
What do we get here?
Let's go to a house.
I don't like standing in the middle of a golf field.
I don't know what to get here.
Oh, maybe I'll get this.
I'll get the SGX.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, someone right above us.
Oh, shit.
They're coming in.
Let's get some cover.
Oh, wow.
They're dropping in hot.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
One dead.
Nice.
They landed behind the house, behind the house.
Whoa!
He's one.
That's mine.
I didn't see anything.
I'm going in!
I'm going in either.
I don't see the people you're shooting at.
I broke the house.
I destroyed the house.
He's dead.
One down.
Nice.
Is that everybody?
I don't see that.
There are no squad wipes, so we don't know.
One of them might be like 20.
I'm at UAV up, so...
Wait, where's the guy we down here?
I think he...
Where is he?
No, you're right.
Stanley?
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
All right.
Oh, they're far.
What the shit?
Okay, well.
Wait, where did you see it?
Oh.
There's someone raising a chemical.
All right.
Well, they died.
They killed themselves.
That was cool.
Yeah, that's cool.
I think they couldn't play without their homie, you know?
What a good homie.
All right.
Where do we go, Beto?
Are you jealous?
All right.
there is a tank i can destroy tanks i got that tank
demolished looking ass well oh i have a i have an artillery
strike too oh i know i have a uav over i got a smoke screen
as well maybe this is the game southwest i have a uav
overwatch thing is that what it's called you want to go get
the custom weapon drop yeah sure whoa i don't know where the
why weren't you here earlier
He was playing outer wilds.
I was playing the outer wilderness.
Wait, wait.
There's a guy.
Do you see that?
Oh, I hit him.
Oh, my God!
Hit who?
There's a guy in this building.
Watch yourself.
He's in there.
He dropped in there, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, he's dropped in there.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know if he's still in there, but that's where he
was.
Oh, I don't say him.
I don't say him.
Maybe he ran like a little bitch.
I would too.
there still is that even reaching i think we're safe right
now now i'm pretty sure he ran away there's no way he's
still in there unless he's camping what is that red light
over there oh okay okay who sent that in who sent that in oh
my goodness keep that guy is that that guy's at the special
crate oh
floor oh that must have been him i'm looking oh wait wait
there's a teammate his teammates here
we don't have to cross this and fight honestly i see them i
feel like we're giving up we're here spot that we ran up
right by the car i'm gonna hold i'm gonna hold high oh he's
rising he's Oh, he is.
Let me get a better angle.
My game volume is on like 2 right now.
How are you guys still...
What kind of character?
That's why we're probably getting a hill.
He's gotta get it off.
Oh, you got it off, yeah, yeah.
Actually, wait.
I think he came...
No, he went inside.
He went inside.
He went outside.
You guys see him?
I see one.
I'm right here with you.
I'm right here.
Oh, he's trying to get...
He's dead.
Oh, he's dead.
Nice.
Yeah, I was gonna say he tried again.
Careful.
We split up.
I don't know where I got shot from He's hurt.
We got to be on my ass This is crazy.
Oh shit.
This is a there's an arc.
I'm waiting until the strike is down I think someone's
trying to take my eye Oh, fuck.
I fucked up guys.
I fucked up.
Oh, no, pedo pedo.
We're ping ping.
I shot a man and I Oh god, Beto, Beto, Beto.
Beto.
I killed him.
I killed a guy.
Oh my god.
I'm getting shot at.
Trying to get to you.
I don't know where I'm getting shot at.
I'm good.
No, Beto.
Axel, let's go.
He's on me.
Okay, okay.
We gotta go.
There's multiple teams.
They're down in the fire here.
They're killing me.
I'm killing me.
I'm killing.
I mean, there's a response station here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I gotta heal.
Oh, Christ.
Where's that sniper?
He's on me!
Okay.
I have to stay here.
I got the other guy.
Yeah, you guys are doing good.
You guys are doing good.
Okay.
It's getting tight, you guys.
You guys can do it.
You got it.
You're doing good.
Get in here.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Okay.
I'm leaving.
Am I dead?
No, no, no, you're fine.
You're fine.
You're so fine.
No, no, no, no, no.
You're so fine, buddy.
Oh, healthy.
Oh, my God.
They're, I'm getting shot.
Right here, right here, right here.
I'm ping.
Okay.
Take high.
Take high first.
There's people.
Oh, that's you.
That's you.
I see them.
Where are they?
Can you ping?
Ping?
One.
I nearly broke them.
Oh, my God.
He reloaded.
Watch your left.
Wait, there's a case right here in front of you.
Hide, just behind us.
Okay.
Come here.
Nice.
It's dead, dead, dead.
On your left.
All right.
Let's, uh, let's go together.
Axel is going.
I have no shields.
Oh, I have.
Shield, shield.
Thank you.
I'm following Axel right now.
Are you fighting someone?
Yeah, just a vehicle.
They ran off.
Okay.
Uh, I'm looking below us just in case.
Making sure there's nobody right behind us.
I like this car.
It's very safe.
Uh-huh.
Sure.
Okay.
There's people in front of us.
Yeah.
Are they in a vehicle or what?
Bad position.
I don't know how I can shoot that.
Careful training.
There's people on the street as well and up the hill.
I see the guy right here.
There's multiple.
I'm shooting the guy under the truck right now.
I don't see the guys on the hill right now.
I mean, I have smoke.
This is...
Where are we going?
Where are you going?
I can smoke us.
Just keep going.
Yeah, just watch up ahead.
Yeah.
It's gotta be on our left as well.
Alright.
I'm checking?
We're close.
Behind this hedge here.
We're in front of me.
Yeah, right in front of us.
Nice.
Right side, right side, right side, right side.
Oh, fucky.
He could use the smoke.
Yeah, I smoked, I smoked I smoke this.
Okay, yeah, yeah, just keep.
I have no shields.
Watch behind it, too.
I'll drop shields.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Watch behind as well.
Keep an eye on that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, watch him behind.
I'm watching too.
I'm watching.
Look better.
We're walking with zone actually.
Might be better.
Everybody good with shield?
I have four.
Yeah, I'm good with shield.
I don't know where that team behind us went, but we were
playing soft-side, so this is...
This looks okay.
We could take the jump tower if you want to.
I like kind of like playing this in its own way, but we
could take it.
All right.
Yeah.
so yeah give me a second give me a second to drain give me a
second to drain okay i'll let you know if it touches you
thanks i'll let you know if the fire gets closer shots uh
far over there all right there's a team right over here
everybody help me on me on here you're by yourself i'm away
careful i hit him for 16 about i'm just looking checking
behind us behind this behind this uh house oh west west west
i see them i see them yeah he's down guys one guys
yeah i think they're gonna have to come up in there crack
tonight under 60 64 oh he's so low oh my gosh oh watch out
that's fine yeah i got someone at 100 i hit 160.
what the are these guys aim they're so good they're pretty
nuts yeah from that range I didn't just have better guns.
I have smoke and we need it.
God, I have an awful loadout.
I need to look for armor.
I ran out of armor in that fight.
Yeah, I have one left.
I just gotta kill somebody.
We'll try to look for one if we can, yeah.
Is the guy close to us?
Oh, this guy's a red LFG.
He has red LFG watching for us here.
I got one?
Nice!
nice 5 bucks for the squads 4 squads 4 squads i'm gonna for
the squads for the squads chill in front of me i like this
ridge i like this ridge for a little bit he's down got armor
i got armor and that i'm coming back i uh i have to right
here i'm ready i'm paying on ping he's down nice i'm heading
over to you i en-gameed him i hit one nice i'm armoring up
real quick.
There's one ball behind here.
One net.
Nice.
I'm gonna loot up here.
There's armor.
He has armor.
I'm checking my left.
I'm checking.
I'll check left side.
I can give you guys armor.
Who needs armor?
I'm good.
I have three.
On me.
I'm with you.
I dropped armor.
It's just one left.
One left.
One left team.
I'm rising.
I'm pushing.
Watch for sure.
Watch ring here.
Yeah, I'm watching left for us.
He's 1 HP at the other side of the hedge.
Oh, fuck, I have no...
Oh, it's touching.
Oh, squad what?
All that?
All right.
I'm trying to get this guy's shields.
I'm about pushing for it here.
I'm going for it.
I'm coming over to battle.
We shall...
You need shields?
I'm okay for now.
Okay.
Actually, yeah, yes, yes, yes.
All right.
I like this right here.
Yeah, I dropped a shield.
Yeah, I'm gonna drain.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Oh, but they picked it up.
I'm gonna need shields.
Just one.
Over there.
Both teams.
Both teams southwest.
Southwest.
Okay.
Play slow.
I turn on UAV.
Watch your left.
Two on the left side and two on the right side.
I'm using the hedge as cover.
I'm gonna take an off angle on the right side if I can.
We kind of have ring here, so just be careful here.
If we have high... Yeah, shoot this guy.
she where he's down oh nice nice nice big one i'll see who
you're shooting at oh watch the right watch the right right
side right side okay i'm looking right i'm looking here i
see them can you pick them coming over coming over here huge
he's broken nice nice where the are you seeing them yeah
he's down on the hill here you know what i'm he's don't push
don't push don't push just play safe play safe play safe i
got a little two overzealous there he's got peek out but i
think there's only two people on this team on the right side
two people that's where my needs but i should wait it left
side left side 71 i'm pushing i'm pushing i'm pushing yeah
i'm pushing too i got my sim here let both left both left
one dead yeah well you got me i'm down he's on yes you guys
have a good night oh thank you we're free we're free let's
That's all we needed!
Fuck yeah.
Holy night.
Holy fuck!
That's all we needed!
We just needed an IGL here.
Oh my god!
Yeah!
That's us guys!
That's us!
I've never seen this screen before!
Me too!
Oh my god!
23 kills!
We just needed a leader.
was like the real leader all along is better with 10 kills
oh my god guys guess what level 69 wait really yep that was
my level up my god you know nice nice honestly nice that's
we did let's look at let's look at i'm gonna look at battles
wait it says 68 for me did you lie no no it's there guys 69
let's fucking go baby oh my god wait sorry i didn't match
why we match making yo yo yo yo what a game what a game
honestly full squad is fun though full squad is fun yeah
yeah yeah yeah now we play this some some other time yeah
yeah now that we yeah now that we figured out the perfect
No, no more bathrooms for us guys.
No.
What the fuck?
Bro, if Beto had been here earlier, we could, it could have
been over.
It's so much funnier than I wasn't.
The fact that it was the very last game that Axel was gonna
do.
And we won.
I was like, nah, this is, this is it, bro.
I told you.
The victory is just so much better.
it's so much better when you win smack sack sack sack whack
sack whack sack whack the sack whackers we did it ggs
everyone ggs guys hey jays thanks bettle yeah yeah of course
guys anytime thanks thank you thanks elton thanks axel had a
great time thanks for forcing us to do this Yeah, yeah, so
thank God you had this brilliant idea to play this game
until we win one game.
Yeah, no problem.
Yeah, we're not a problem.
We did it as a team, guys.
I've always knew, I always knew we were going to do it.
I believed in us that hard.
I knew, I knew it was going to happen eventually.
We just lost a little bit of our soul before it came up.
Yeah, yeah, but like we're fine.
Everything is fine now.
Everything is fine.
We made it.
looks darkest before the dawn yeah yeah we started from 25th
place 24th place no look at us i don't feel like i earned
any of this
yippee okay doki i guess i'll see you in two days yeah i'll
see you in yeah i'll see you in battle yeah yeah i'll see
you in two days yeah better you gotta teach us too because
we have yay okay a little bit of a taste for today
we did it we fucking did it guys we didn't need a rat we
didn't need a rat at all we just it's not crazy we just
played the game and we killed so many people guys we we
fucking oh my god we actually did it we needed an igl yeah
it was just too easy too easy guys anyway i'm i'm gonna head
out now thank you all for watching i'm tired as always
everybody say hi and posture check get up and move around
get that blood flowing you stay up for me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye